Scholastic Audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 11, The Lost Continent, read by
Shannon McManus.
The Lost Continent Prophecy.
Turn your eyes, your wings, your fire, to
the land across the sea, where dragons
are poisoned and dragons are dying, and
no one can ever be free.
A secret lurks inside their eggs.
A secret hides within their book.
A secret buried far below may save those
brave enough to look.
Open your hearts, your minds, your wings
to the dragons who flee from the hive.
Face a great evil with talons united.
Or none of the tribes will survive.
Prologue.
About 2,000 years ago.
If you are flying directly into a
hurricane, it is probably useful to be a
dragon who can see the future.
Then again, if you are a dragon who can
see the future, you are most likely far
too smart to fly directly into a
hurricane.
And yet, according to clear site's
visions, that was exactly what she needed
to do.
She shook out her black wings, which were
already tired from how far she'd flown
all morning and the day before.
Her talons clung to the slippery, wet
rock below her.
Her scales felt itchy with salt from the
ocean spray.
Above her, the sun peeked wearily through
cracks in the dull gray clouds.
She closed her eyes, tracing the future
paths ahead of her.
In one direction, south, and a little
east, there was a small island with a
warm, sandy beach.
Two coconut palms nodded toward each
other, and there were lazy tiger sharks
to eat.
The hurricane would pass it by
completely.
If she went there, Clearsight could rest
eat, and sleep in safety.
Then she could continue on in 2 days
after the storm was over.
But in the other direction.
A long flight west and slightly north, the
lost continent was waiting for her.
She knew it was real now.
When she'd left Pyria to find it.
She'd half expected to fly all the way
around the world, and end up back on
Pyria's other post.
No one was sure another continent even
existed.
And if it did, everyone knew it was too
far away to fly to.
Any dragon would tire, fall into the sea
and drown before reaching it.
But clear sight wasn't any dragon.
She had something no one else did.
The ability to carefully trace the paths
of multiple possible futures.
Standing on the edge of Pyria.
She could see which direction would take
her to an island where she could rest.
And then the next day, to another
island.
Shifting her course slightly each day
guided by her visions, she had found a
trail of small islands to take her safely
across the ocean.
A gust of wind roared over her
splattering a handful of raindrops onto
her head.
The hurricane was almost upon her.
If she didn't leave right now, dragons on
the lost continent would die.
Dragons who might one day be her friends
if she saved them.
Dragons who had no idea what was bearing
down on them, because there was no one
there to warn them.
Yet.
Clearsight took a deep breath, vaulted
into the sky, and pointed herself west.
Her mind immediately started flashing
through all the ways she could die in the
next 2 days.
This was why she hated flying in storms.
They were too unpredictable.
The smallest twitch of the wind in the
wrong direction, could send her
plummeting to the rocks below, or drive a
stray palm branch into her heart.
Don't think about that.
Think about the dragons who need you.
The other vision was fading.
The one where she flew southeast and
hid.
In that one, she'd arrived on the lost
continent in the hurricane's aftermath.
The images of the devastation and dead
bodies would be hard to shake off, even
if she prevented them in reality.
Will they believe me?
Will they listen to me?
In some of her visions, they did.
In some, they didn't.
All she could do was fly her hardest and
hope.
The hurricane fought her at every wing
beat, as if it knew she was trying to
snatch victims from its claws.
Rain battered her ferociously.
She felt like she'd be driven into the
endless sea at any moment.
Or maybe she'd drown up here in the water
logged sky.
But this was only the outer edge of the
storm.
There was far worse still to come.
Clear sight was trying to reach land
before the really terrible fury behind
her did.
She couldn't stop, couldn't slow down for
a moment.
At one point, she glanced back and saw a
spout of water sucked into the air.
In the middle of it, an orca flailed
desperately, before the storm flung it
away.
A while later.
After the sun had apparently been
swallowed for good, Clearsight saw an
entire hut fly by her, then splinter
apart.
She had to duck quickly to a lower air
current to avoid the debris.
Where had it come from?
Who had lived in it?
She would never know, her visions told
her.
And then, when Clearside was beginning to
lose all feeling in her wings, she saw a
shape loom out of the clouds ahead, a
cliff.
Land.
A lot of land.
A whole continent, in fact, She canted
her wings and soared toward the top of it
where she could see a never ending line
of trees tossing violently in the wind.
The hurricane made one more effort to
throw her back into the sea, but she
fought with her last reserves until she
felt earth beneath her talons.
She collapsed forward, clutching the wet
soil for a moment.
Grateful to be alive.
Keep going.
They're not safe yet.
Clearsight pushed herself up and faced
the trees.
They were coming.
The 1st 2 dragons she would meet in this
strange new world.
What would it be like to face unfamiliar
tribes, completely different from the
ones she knew.
There wouldn't be any night wings like
her here.
No sand dragons, no sea dragons, no ice
dragons.
She'd glimpsed what these new dragons
would look like.
But she didn't know anything yet about
their tribes.
Or whether they would trust her.
They stepped out of the trees, eyeing her
with wary curiosity.
Oh, they're beautiful, she thought.
One was dark forest green.
The color of the trees all around them.
His wings curved gracefully, like long
leaves on either side of him, and
mahogany brown underscales glinted from
his chest.
But it was the other who took clear
sight's breath away.
His scales were iridescent gold, layered
over metallic rose and blue, shimmering
through the rain.
He outshone even the rain wings she'd
occasionally seen in the marketplace, and
those were the most beautiful dragons in
Pyria.
Not only that, but his wings were
startlingly weird.
There were 4 of them instead of two.
A 2nd pair at the back overlapped the
front ones, tilting and dipping at
slightly different angles from the 1st
pair to give the dragon extra agility in
the air.
Like dragonflies, she realized.
Remembering the delicate insects darting
across the ponds in the mountain
meadows.
Well, butterflies, or beetles.
She sat up and spread her front talons to
show that she was harmless.
Hello?
She said, in her very least threatening
voice.
The green one circled her slowly.
The iridescent one sat down and gave her
a small smile.
She smiled back, although her heart was
pounding.
She knew she had to wait for them to make
the 1st move. said the green dragon
finally, in a deep, calm voice, way
root.
Take a breath.
You knew it would be like this at first.
My name is Clearsight, she said, touching
her forehead.
I am from far over the sea.
She pointed at the turning ocean
stretching way off to the east behind
her.
Anyone speak dragon?
The 2 strangers exchanged surprised
glances.
The old language, said the shimmering
dragon, awkwardly and slowly, as if
pulling the words from his memory bit by
bit.
You do know it, Clearsight said, hope
darting through her veins.
Some little, he said.
Much old, he smiled again.
The green dragon said something in their
own language and nodded at the ocean.
The other answered, and they spoke for a
few moments.
If they had been a pair of night wings
Clearsight would have guessed they were
arguing, but their tone was so peaceful
that she couldn't really tell.
The old language.
I wonder if their continent in ours had
more contact in the past.
Maybe we will again in the future.
I could teach them all dragon. especially
if some of them already know it.
That way, if any more Pyreans ever come
this way, they could communicate.
It was hard to imagine other dragons
making the journey she'd just made
though.
It was so far, and depended on finding
those small islands in such a vast sea.
But maybe she could help with that.
Not soon, though.
Not while I feel any temptation to wake
dark stalker.
I can't go back to Pyria until I have
forgotten him.
So, probably never.
Why are you here down?
The gold pink Dragon asked her.
There's a really bad storm coming, she
said, as clearly as she could.
Very bad.
He spread his wings and looked up, smiling
into the raindrops.
See that, he said with a shrug.
No, she shook her head.
I see.
She pointed to her head.
I see the future.
Tomorrow and tomorrow and the next day.
I see all the days.
This storm kills many dragons.
She waved her talons at the dripping
forest around them, rips up many, many
trees.
Both dragons were frowning now.
Tree harm, growled the green dragon.
Twig Hard Lot Splinter Fall.
But you can save them, Clear sight
pressed on.
The visions were crowding into her head.
She was running out of time.
She couldn't be diplomatic and patient
any longer.
We have to move everyone.
All dragons, far, far, far inland, as far
as they can fly right now, and wait there
until the storm is over.
She turned to the metallic dragon.
Her talons clasped together.
Please, save them.
The moment teetered.
Two paths waveringly possible.
Finally, the shimmering dragon nodded.
Move all.
We will do.
He said something in their language to
the green dragon, who nodded as well.
The relief hit clear sight so hard.
She nearly had to lie down again.
But the dragons beckoned her to follow
them, and they all took off, flying
cautiously through the storm tossed
treetops.
Dragons appeared between the leaves as
she swept through the forest with her 2
companions, all of them watching her with
startled curiosity.
Most of them were dark green and brown
with leaf shaped wings.
That's their name and dragon, she
realized from a new cascade of visions.
Leaf wings.
But about a quarter of them were the
other tribe.
The one clear site didn't have a name for
yet, and those glittered like jewels on
the branches.
Gold and blue and purple and orange, and
every color of the rainbow.
She saw a tiny lavender dragonette
clinging to a branch, and for a moment
Clearsight was alarmed to see that she
didn't have any wings.
And she spotted little wing buds on the
dragonette's back and remembered, or
foresaw, or remembered foreseeing, that
the glittering tribe grew their wings a
few years after hatching.
Growing up wingless.
That must be so strange.
Clearside's mind flashed to that other
vision, the horrible one.
Where this dragonette had been one of the
many bodies left in the hurricane
wreckage.
But instead, Tomorrow the little dragon
would wake up and chase butterflies in
the sunlight, complaining that she wanted
blackberries for breakfast.
I saved her.
I did something right.
The green dragon called out in a booming
voice like a bell tolling.
Whatever he said, the dragons around them
repeated it, passing it along.
Clearsight could hear the echoes of other
dragon voices rolling through the
forest.
She felt the drumming wing beats behind
her as both tribes rose into the air, and
followed them to safety.
You save us.
Said the shimmering dragon, moving around
to fly beside Clearside.
He smiled at her again.
You safe now too.
Maybe I am, she thought.
I stopped Dark Stalker.
I saved fathom, and the night wings, and
my parents.
And now I found a new home, with new
dragons to save.
I can help them with my visions.
I can do everything right this time.
New futures exploded in her mind.
She might marry this kind, funny dragon
whose name would turn out to be sun
streak.
Or she could end up with a dragon she'd
meet in 3 days while helping to clean up
the forest. whose gentle green eyes were
nothing like dark stalkers.
She could move in with an affable, very
old leaf wing named Maple, who spoke the
old language, or she could find her own
tree hollow to live in, or she could
explore the new continent first, then
come back here to build a home.
And there would be dragonettes, if she
wanted them.
Clearsight felt a sudden, dizzying rush
of love for dragons who weren't even eggs
yet, little Jewel, and whip smart
tortoiseshell, and cuddly orange.
Who names their dragonette orange?
Sunstreak apparently.
They might have to have some
conversations about that plan.
And Commodore, the king of giggles.
She would always miss the dragonette she
should have had with Dark Stalker.
But she would love the ones that were
coming with all her heart, and nothing
bad would ever, ever. happened to them.
They would all live the longest happiest
lives because she would be here, tracking
their paths, keeping them safe.
She would get it right this time.
Your root place.
Sunstreak said, gently interrupting her
thoughts.
Where?
She pointed back out to sea.
Pyria.
She waved her claws at the continent
around them.
This?
Where?
She asked.
He smiled again.
Pantala, he said slowly and clearly, and
with evident pride.
Pantala, she echoed back.
The lost continent is real.
And it has a name, and it's my home now.
Pantala, here I am.
Part one.
In the cocoon. 2000 years later.
Chapter one.
Blue was a dragon who liked things the
way they were.
That is, if he didn't exactly like
everything about live as a silk wing, he
had to admit that at least he was safe.
And you know, things were fine, really, it
wasn't perfect.
But at least his tribe and the hive wings
coexisted peacefully.
The hive wings protected them from
outside threats, and everyone followed
the rules, and the hives were beautiful
and spotless, and there were always
enough yams and okra to eat.
So wasn't that the kind of world everyone
wanted to live in?
Blue wasn't sure how everyone else felt.
But he wondered about it all the time.
He often tried to imagine himself as
other dragons.
Were they all as content as he was?
Or was he luckier than most?
Did they want the same things he did?
What did they worry about?
What did they hope for?
If they seemed unhappy?
Why was that?
His guesses were probably mostly wrong, he
was sure.
But Blue couldn't stop thinking about
it.
It felt like a constant tugging on his
imagination.
What was the fidgety dragonette next to
him in math class thinking, while she
drew hexagons in the margins of her
test?
What did their rose pink neighbor worry
about?
While he cleaned the dead bugs from his
webs.
What about the hive wings?
How were their lives and hopes, and
lunches, and morning aches, and
nightmares different from his?
The other lives drew him like a flame?
Or the scent of nectarines?
He spent the night before his sister's
metamorphosis as her, winding himself
deep into the dream of being Luna.
Perhaps her wing buds had started to
flutter open as she fell asleep.
Perhaps she lay awake for a while, gazing
up at the shrouded stars, thinking of the
moment she could leap from the top of the
hive and race the skylarks to the sea.
He thought she might also be looking
forward to the moon silk dark she would
spin herself, and the days of emerald
tinted sleep inside the cocoon.
No one could yell at her, or sign her
extra work while she was in there, growing
her wings.
He knew Luna wasn't scared, like he would
be in 6 days when his own metamorphosis
time came.
Luna had always felt ready for life with
wings.
Blue was not, and most of all, he was not
ready for life with her wings, which
meant everything changing.
Once she had wings, Luna would be
assigned to a work order.
Soon she'd be paired up with whichever
partner the queen chose for her, and
given another cell to live in.
She might even be moved to another hive.
It was normal.
It was the way life always was for silk
wings.
Everyone had a metamorphosis.
Everyone had a new life chosen for them.
Everyone moved on.
But now that it was happening to his
family, Blue founded extremely nerve
racking.
He was already awake when Luna bounded
across the web and started shaking him
shortly before dawn.
He wasn't sure he'd slept at all.
For a while, he'd been watching the glow
of tiny lights moving far below them in
Cicada Hive, imagining himself as one of
those early rising dragons on their way
to work, awake before the sun.
In the distance, he could see hornet hive
in one direction, and mantas hive in the
other.
Although the webs that connected them
were mostly invisible in the dark.
He'd never been to any of the other
hives.
But he knew they were spread out in a
wide circle around the plains of
Pentala.
The enormous dragon cities rose from the
grassland and reached for the sky, like
towering dragon made echoes of the trees
that used to dominate the land.
Their roofs arched out like branches, and
the dense silvery threads of silk wing
webs created a canopy, tying those
branches together.
So even wingless silkwing dragonettes
could travel between hives far above the
ground, if they wanted to. and were
allowed to.
He yawned and batted Luna's talons away
pretending he'd been in a deep sleep.
Dewdrops glittered all across the web
around and above them, as if it had
rained tiny diamonds in the night.
He could see the silk bundled shape of
Luna's mother on the outer edge of their
cell, still fast asleep.
His own mother was on a night crew these
days, and had been gone since midnight.
It's today.
It's today, Luna whispered.
Her pale green tail flipped back and
forth, sending tremors through the silken
threads.
She bounced closer to blue to poke his
shoulder again, and sent his hammock
rocking perilously.
Hey, watch it, he teased, nudging her
away.
Some of us won't have wings for another 6
days.
There were layers and layers of other
strong webs crisscrossing below his
family's web, ready to catch any falling
dragonettes.
But even so, it was hard to forget how
far down the ground was.
He always felt safer in the hives than he
did out on the webs, which he worried was
not a very normal silk wing attitude.
And some of us, she's saying, we'll have
them today.
She sat up and flexed the tiny wing buds
on her shoulder blades.
Well, not exactly, he pointed out.
Today is only your cocoon spinning day.
It'll take another 5 days for your wings
to actually, ah!
He yelped as she abended his hammock and
dumped him onto the web.
Don't you actually me, Luna said
sternly.
I'm your older sister, and I've been to
like 12 metamorphosis days.
Plus, I have the highest grade in our
class in silk studies.
I can actually you under the table.
Yes, all right.
Blue said, stretching his legs one by
one.
You're the smartest dragon in the
family.
I know.
I admit it.
He snuck a glance over his shoulder at
his own wing buds.
They looked the same as yesterday.
Small, tightly curled, and iridescent
violet, a brighter, more purple shade
than the gem like azure of the rest of
his scales.
Luna's wing buds were starting to unfurl
so he could see whorls of cobalt and gold
inside the pale green exterior.
There were also signs of her silk coming
in.
Already her palms and wrists were glowing
a little, as though tiny fireflies were
waking up under her scales.
That'll be me soon, he thought.
Tamping down a wave of panic.
After my own metamorphosis, I'll have
wings and silk too.
Maybe the changes would be small.
Maybe he'd be assigned to live right here
to help his mother strengthen the bridges
between hives.
Maybe Luna would stay too, and be a hive
drone like her mother, working for one of
the upper class hive wing families.
She wouldn't like that, though.
Luna wanted to be a spinner.
She was hoping to be paired with sword
tail in an artist's cell near the sunny
heights of the web.
She wanted to make a weaving so
beautiful.
It would have to be given to the queen of
the hive wings, who ruled both tribes, or
at least to one of the queen's sisters.
Blue had seen the queen only once when
she visited Cicada Hive.
Queen Wasp had come through to inspect
their school with 20 hive wing soldiers
marching in impressive exact unison
behind her.
Her scales glittered in perfect black and
yellow stripes, and her eyes were large
and completely black, surrounded by an
oval of yellow scales.
Imagining himself into her was almost
impossible.
It was like trying to imagine life as the
sun.
But he couldn't help trying.
He thought about how she must wake up in
the morning and eat breakfast, like
anyone else, although, if the rumors were
true, She ate as rarely as possible, and
only predators.
The head of a lioness for lunch one day
slices a black mamba in squid ink soup
for dinner 12 days later.
He wondered if her wings felt strong or
heavy as she flew from hive to hive to
check on her subjects.
Was she relieved to have sisters to share
her responsibilities with?
Or did she worry that they might covet
her throne?
How often did she check the book of Clear
Sight?
If he were queen, with 2 tribes full of
1000s of dragons depending on him, Blue
guessed he'd read it every day, until he
had it memorized.
At one point during her visit, she had
spotted Blue and Luna, and stared at them
for approximately a century and a half by
his internal clock.
He'd gotten the distinct feeling that she
was trying to decide between adopting
them or eating them.
Queen Wasp was as breathtaking and
superior as all the stories said.
After that, her sister, Lady Cicada, the
ruler of their hive, had never seemed
quite so terrifying to him again.
And maybe that was the point of the
queen's visits, to remind everyone whose
claws held the real power.
So, Luna said, taking one of his talons
in hers, my last day as a dragonette.
What are we going to do?
Lie around on the web in the sunlight?
He suggested, hopefully.
No, you lazy banana slug, she said.
All my favorite things.
That's the correct answer.
This isn't fair, he pointed out.
By the time it's my metamorphosis day
nobody will be left to do all my favorite
things with me.
You'll all be too busy flying around with
your big, flappy wings, doing fancy, busy
wingish things.
Luna managed not to make a face, but Blue
instantly felt guilty anyway.
He knew she wished Swordtail could spend
the day with them too.
But Sortell was on construction duty on
the west side of Cicada Hive all day
probably getting dusty and frustrated, and
missing Luna like crazy.
Sorry, Blue said.
Don't be, Luna said.
Once I have my wings.
Sortel and I can be partnered, and then
I'll see quite enough of him.
She grinned, as though applying for the
partnership actually meant they'd get it
which Blue thought was far from certain.
He didn't know any adult silk wings who'd
been given the partner of their choice.
His mother and Luna's mother, hadn't even
known their father, who had been whisked
away to another hive once there were
eggs.
Blue knew his name, Admiral, and nothing
else.
Better this way, though, he thought.
Burnett and Silverspot ended up loving
each other much more than they could ever
have loved Admiral.
They were a good family, the 4 of them.
It had all worked out for the best.
Queen WAS and her sisters knew what they
were doing with the partner assignments.
If Luna and Swordtail weren't matched up
it would be for a good reason.
So where do we start?
He asked.
No wait, let me guess.
Honey drops.
Honey drops, Luna sang, bouncing the web
again and fluttering her wing buds.
Move your tail and maybe we'll beat the
line at the checkpoint.
He dipped his snout into their due
collector.
Washing his antennae and the dry scales
under his eyes.
As Luna darted across the web to her
mother.
Silverspot sat up and wrapped her wings
around Luna.
Quickly enough that Blue wondered whether
she had been awake all night too.
Have a wonderful day, my darling.
I'll try to make it to the cocoon.
Silverspot promised.
But I know, Luna said.
It's all right.
Silverspot's mistress was bad tempered
and frantically insecure about her place
in the hive hierarchy, and she tended to
take out her rage on silver spot, with
1000s of small cruelties.
Keeping silver spot from her only
daughter's metamorphosis would probably
be the highlight of her year.
Just think, Luna said brightly.
Next time I see you, I'll have wings.
We can go flying together.
I can't wait.
Silverspot agreed.
But when she hugged Luna again.
Blue caught a strange expression crossing
her face.
Anxiety?
Fear?
He felt a weird chill run through his
scales.
Silverspot looked as though she knew
something they didn't.
As if, for some reason, Silverspot
suspected she would never see her
daughter again.
Chapter 2.
The creeping sense of foreboding followed
Blue, as he clambered along the webs
after Luna, the sun was rising, sending
shafts of filmy gray light through the
silken strands around them.
The soft hum of insect wings rose from
the tall, waving grasses of the savannah
below.
Luna was a reckless climber, weeping from
one level to the next like a monkey, or
like a dragon who already had her wings.
Blue was more sensible, relying on the
slight stickiness of the silk to keep him
anchored as he ascended, even so, today
he felt more airsick than he normally
did.
Each tremor along the silk seemed to
vibrate right into his bones, making his
antennae twitch nervously, and his teeth
ache.
He was relieved when they reached the
hive entrance, where the webs connected
to the uppermost tier of the city.
There was already aligned 20 dragons
long.
But at least here they could wait on the
solid ground of the entrance tunnel.
He stepped off the web onto the papery
dry surface and flexed his talons.
The walls of the tunnel were painted with
a mural of silk wings and hive wings
flying together in a bright blue sky, all
of them looking as happy as Luna on a
honey drop spree.
Much of the mural was covered up, though
by the posters that lined the walls.
Be vigilant.
We are always in danger.
Beware of leaf wings.
Report disloyal silk wings to a hive wing
authority immediately.
Queen Wasp sees everything.
Queen Wasp protects us all.
All hail Queen Wasp.
Leave wings, gone, or lying in wait.
Report any sightings of possible leaf
wings to a high wing authority
immediately.
That last one had a drawing of a snarling
dark green dragon on it, complete with
blood stained claws and teeth.
It seemed as if a new poster appeared on
the walls every other day.
And half of them were about the threat of
leaf wings.
Luna caught him studying the picture and
snorted.
What?
he said.
Come on, she said, you're not really
afraid of leaf wings, are you?
Why not?
he asked.
They nearly wiped us out half a century
ago.
Or has my genius sister forgotten all our
history lessons already?
But they failed.
She pointed out.
And now they're extinct, so there's
nothing to worry about.
It's not like they can attack us if
they're all dead.
We don't know that they are, he argued.
Tusig said his uncle saw one flying
overhead a couple of years ago.
And what about that section of mantis
hive that collapsed last year?
Everyone said that was leaf wing
sabotage.
Luna said scornfully.
What Tussock's uncle saw was a green
silkwing.
He's just hysterical, and that collapse
was caused by shoddy workmanship.
The sabotage story was so obviously a
cover up.
Blue said, glancing at the hive wing
soldiers up ahead.
They looked busy checking IDs, but they
might still overhear Luna's treacherous
talk.
Look, Luna said, lowering her voice and
rolling her eyes.
No one has really seen a leaf wing in
over 50 years, and we cut down all their
trees.
So where would they even be living if
they were still alive?
Slithering through the tall grass of the
Savannah?
No, they're gone, thanks to Queen Wasp.
So all of this is totally unnecessary.
She waved her claws at the warning
posters.
The hives don't cover the whole continent
he suggested, but she was already talking
over him.
The queen just needs us to have a, what's
it called, a common enemy, you know?
So the silk wings don't start complaining
or asking for their own queen or anything
like that.
Our own queen?
Lou was startled.
He never even thought about the silk
wings asking for a separate queen
before.
It was kind of alarming that Luna had.
That seemed like the kind of dangerous
idea sore tail might have put in her
head.
I mean, not that I think we should.
Luna said hurriedly.
And this time, she was the one to glance
over at the soldiers.
But you know, someone might, if they were
unhappy with the way things are.
Blue shook his head.
I don't think so.
I don't know any unhappy silk wings.
The poster behind Luna read, Loyalty
above all, with a giant drawing of Queen
Wasp's huge dark eyes.
Sometimes they were a comforting sight
but in the middle of this conversation
they were making him uneasy.
Everything is great in the hives.
We're safe, and we all work together.
So I don't see what anyone would have to
complain about.
The line moved them within earshot of the
soldiers, and they both stopped talking
instinctively.
Blue gazed at the long, pale blue wings
of the dragon in front of him.
Imagining where she might be going, until
finally it was their turn.
Names, said one of the soldiers in a
bored voice.
Every hive wing had at least a few black
scales, inherited from their common
ancestor, Clearsight.
But this dragon was almost entirely black
with only a few orange flecks here and
there.
Blue and Luna had seen him here at the
checkpoint nearly every day for 3 years.
And yet the soldier never gave any
indication of recognizing them, or caring
that they existed beyond their IDs.
His name was Hawker, not that he'd ever
told them that.
Blue had picked it up from listening to
the guards grumbling at one another.
Blue, he said, holding out his right
arm.
The soldier studied the letters that had
been carved into Blue's palm when he was
a newly hatched dragonette.
B for his name, forming a triangle with a
smaller B and A for his parents' names.
Luna always said she was glad the marking
happened while they were too young to
remember.
But Blue was pretty sure he did have
memories of that day.
A bright light, a searing pain, and most
clearly, a sense of betrayal.
Hawker grunted, and moved on to examining
the wrist cough on Blue's other arm.
It was a dull bronze color and annoyingly
heavy, although Blue was mostly used to
it by now.
It indicated that he was a student at one
of the schools in the hive.
So he was permitted to go in and out
through this checkpoint.
The name of the school was inscribed in
the metal.
Silkworm Hall.
And I'm Luna, said his sister.
Ah, said the soldier.
Turning to consult a list on a small
rectangle of paper.
Metamorphosis today.
That's right.
Luna said.
Blue could tell she was trying so hard
not to smile.
Smiling at soldiers was always risky.
You never knew if you'd get a rare smile
back, or if you'd end up spending an
afternoon on misbehavior's way, for
taunting a figure of authority.
Blue imagined that the soldiers had to be
that alert and suspicious.
If dragons didn't respect them, how could
they keep the peas and control the hive?
But he also believed that Soratel hadn't
deserved it any of the 3 times he'd wound
up on misbehaviors way.
Sortell had wild ideas, and talked a
little too freely, but he wasn't a danger
to the hive.
You'll have a new one of these next time
you come through here.
Hawker said, tapping Luna's wrist cuff
which matched blues.
I know, she said, as Blue's heart sank.
One more change.
Luna was done with school now.
He'd have to go without her.
Not for very long, though.
I'll be needing a new wristband soon
too.
How would it feel to have this one cut
off and exchanged for something else?
Surely it would be a bit like having one
of his toes casually replaced.
Well, said the soldier.
He looked at his list, and then back at
Luna again.
You may go.
Hawker cleared his throat gruffly as they
started forward.
Good luck.
Oh, thank you, Luna said.
Startled.
She dragged Blue Ford, managing to hold
on until they were far down the tunnel
before she burst into giggles.
He said so many words to us all of a
sudden, she cried.
I didn't know he knew so many words.
Maybe he likes you.
Blue suggested with a grin.
It was a joke.
But then, what if he did?
Blue felt himself slipping into visions
of the hive wing's possible life.
Did Hawker go home and dream of the silk
wing he saw every day, but couldn't ever
be with?
Did his friends tease him about his
dedication to his work?
Did he like being a soldier?
Following orders all day long?
Or did he ever wish the rules were
different?
Ooh, maybe we'll have a forbidden love.
Luna gasped, falling into blue and
knocking him back into reality.
Well, I am not going to be the one to
tell sword tail, he said.
Luna laughed and started telling a story
about something funny, Soratell had said
the night before.
Blue padded beside her.
Glad to be off the topic of silk wing
hive wing relationships.
Forbidden was putting it mildly.
Whatever the strongest word for illegal
was, that was the right word.
Prohibited, outlawed, punishable by death
all of those times a 1000000.
They reached the end of the tunnel, where
it widened and forked into several other
tunnels.
The path to the right led to the mosaic
garden, but they'd go there later.
Blue was sure.
It was Luna's favorite place in the
hive.
First, though, they made their way down 3
levels. through 2 more checkpoints.
It was warm, as always in the hive, with
sunlight filtering through the walls to
cast an amber glow over everything.
All the hives were made of tree stuff
which was a particular mix of wood pulp
and silk and clay, and other things blue
would learn about if he was assigned to a
construction crew.
It looked paper thin, and allowed light
to filter through, but it was solid as
rock.
Under his talons.
The tree stuff floor was dry and mostly
smooth.
Apart from a few lumps where workers
hadn't been careful enough.
The problem was, the hives had been built
back when there were plenty of trees all
over Pentala.
Now that the trees were all gone, or
mostly gone, the only wood pulp came from
the shrubby little bushes that fought
their way out of the dry soil of the
savannah.
So the only way to expand a hive, was to
take the tree stuff from somewhere else
in the hive, and reshape it where you
wanted it.
It was hard back breaking work.
Usually given to the silk wings who
caused the most trouble in school, such
as, for instance, sword tail.
Blue was really, really hoping he didn't
get assigned to a construction crew.
A silk work detail would be different.
What his mom did in the sky between hives
was half architecture, half art.
He wouldn't mind a job like that.
Blue had been a good, quiet, obedient
student at Silkworm Hall his whole life.
Surely he'd earned a better assignment
than tree stuff construction.
Finally, Luna took a path to the right
instead of the left, and they came to the
open market of Cicada Hive.
This was a huge vaulted space that hummed
with activity.
The best shops had permanent 6 sided
cells around the outer wall.
Everyone else had to scramble for stalls
in the Labyrinthian middle.
Overhead, yellow and orange lanterns hung
along silk filaments, crisscrossing the
ceiling like necklaces of tiny suns.
And, as always, soldiers perched on
balconies above the market, keeping a
sharp eye on the hustle and bustle of the
dragons below.
Some of them held long, needle like
lances that looked like bigger versions
of the stingers that could spring from
the tips of Queen Wasp's claws.
Not that Blue had ever seen her use them
but they were featured in several of the
posters.
Some of those in here, in fact, Her face
loomed over the market in murals and
posters, until he almost felt as though
he had a 100 lenses in his eyes, each of
them reflecting her back at him.
Luna led the way confidently through the
maze, until Blue realized she was aiming
for the best nectar store in the hive, a
tall, imposing cell front, with delicate
sugar confections arrayed in the window.
He jumped forward and stepped on her tail
yanking her back.
Ow, she yelped.
What was that for?
Three haughty looking hive wings nearly
ran into them, and he tugged Luna out of
their way, mumbling apologies.
They wrinkled their noses and spread
their wings, making a few other silk
wings duck to the side of the path to
give them space, and then they swept
away.
Luna, silk wings don't go into the sugar
dream, he said.
Let's go to droplets, like we always do.
It's my metamorphosis day, she objected.
We've only never been there because we
usually can't afford it, but today is
different.
Mother gave me enough scales for it.
She said to have the best last day ever.
Blue shivered involuntarily.
The phrase, last day, really wasn't
helping his anxiety about silver spots
face this morning.
Stop worrying, Luna said, nudging his
shoulder.
They'll take our scales no matter who we
are, and these might be the best honey
drops we ever get.
She bounded off again, and he followed
unconvinced, but aware that arguing with
his sister would get him exactly
nowhere.
There was only one other customer in The
Sugar Dream when they entered.
An older lemon yellow hive wing, with
black stripes on her wings, and ruby
scales freckling her nose and tail.
She peered over a pair of spectacles at
them.
Then went back to squinting at the
shelves of pale pink and lavender
candies.
But the hive wing behind the counter
stiffened and flicked his long red tail
disapprovingly.
His brows arching as high as they could
possibly go.
Hello, Luna said cheerfully, ignoring his
expression.
We'd like 2 honey drops, please.
She touched the soft gray silk pouch
around her neck as she spoke. so that the
scales inside jingled.
Who's your mistress?
The clerk asked.
Is she new to this hive?
She should know that shopping for luxury
items is not a task traditionally
entrusted to servants.
We are nobody's servants, Luna said
indignantly.
We want them for ourselves.
Nobody's servants yet, Blue added
quickly.
We're still in school.
He pointed to their wing buds.
It's her metamorphosis day today, actually
so we'll know our assignment soon.
And then I'm sure our, uh, the dragons we
work for will, uh, He made himself stop
talking.
Judging by the frown on the shopkeeper's
face. was clearly not helping.
Indeed, said the sales dragon.
Well, as you can see, I am currently
assisting another customer.
I'm afraid you will have to wait.
He narrowed his eyes, and tipped his chin
at the spectacled dragon.
Blue and Luna glanced over at her.
The elderly dragon had her snout down
close to a box of honey sticks.
As they watched.
She nudged a bag of sugar cubes closer to
her, and tapped it with a claw.
Mumbling as though she was counting each
cube.
Luna shot the clerk in, are you kidding
me?
Look.
He pretended not to see it.
We can wait.
Blue whispered to her.
Causing trouble would only get them
kicked out with no honey drops.
Several long moments passed.
Blue studied the beautiful spun sugar
artwork behind the clerk, an elegant pale
green praying mantis, a glittering blue
and white dragonfly, an array of
different jewel colored beetles, and
several miniature wasps.
He wondered if it felt disrespectful to
any of the hive wings to eat something
their queen was named after.
Was this Clerk the one who had made the
delicate sugar insects?
Did he spend his early mornings in the
back room of the shop, carefully pouring
honey into frozen teardrops, and lacing
chocolate stars with speckles of orange
peel?
Did he love coming here every day?
Or was he so sick of sweetness that all
he could stomach anymore was the saltiest
gazelle jerky?
Blue guessed that the shopkeeper had
hoped his rudeness would drive them
away.
And now he was regretting his choice
because it meant 2 silk wings were
lingering in his precious store, right
where anyone might wander by and see
them.
He probably wished he had taken their
money and gotten rid of them quickly.
But now he was stuck waiting for his
other customer to make up her mind, just
as they were.
The door swung open, letting in a burst
of noise from outside as 2 hive wings
entered.
Their giddy chatter dropped away abruptly
when they saw Blue and Luna standing by
the counter.
Oh, said one of them.
Schaefer.
What?
Interesting new customers you have.
The other one giggled, and edged past
blue, keeping her wings canted away from
him.
Don't worry, weevil, sir.
I'm sure they'll be leaving soon, Chafer
said.
Somehow managing to be oily and tense at
the same time.
Yes, we will, Luna piped up, as soon as
we get our honey drops.
Chafer twitched to snout at her, as if
she were an actual moth he'd found
nibbling on one of his rugs.
By the hive.
What a bore it must be to be wingless.
Weevil said, pacing around the 2 silkwing
dragonettes.
I bet you feel like half a dragon.
Hardly a dragon at all.
Such cute little wing buds, though.
Can I touch one?
He reached out toward Luna's back.
No, Luna cried.
Jerking away from him.
Blue wasn't sure which dragon was the
most horrified, himself, chafer or the
rude hive wing.
You can touch mine.
He said quickly.
It's her metamorphosis day, so she's
there.
It's um, better not to touch them right
before the change.
That wasn't true at all.
Luna was just being difficult and
impertinent to dragons who could really
get them in a lot of trouble if they
wanted to.
Those soldiers outside could be summoned
at a moment's notice by any hive wing.
Oh.
Said Weevil.
Right, of course, he added, as though he
obviously knew everything about
metamorphosis.
How exciting for you, little silk wing.
He reached out his talons and poked
Blue's wing buds roughly. as though
Weevil was trying to unfurl them by
force.
Blue tried not to wince.
He tried to make it better by imagining
Weevil's life.
A family who loved him, perhaps, who
hugged him goodbye in the morning.
Maybe he'd desperately wanted to be a
soldier, but hadn't qualified for the
academies.
Maybe he'd been reassigned to a
management or gathering job instead, which
made him bitter and imperious with anyone
he could safely push around.
It was difficult, though, to slide into
sympathy with this particular dragon.
Possibly, he was just a jerk, and had
always been that way.
The old hive wing with the spectacles
suddenly appeared at Weevil's side.
There's no need to be a brute weevil.
She said to him.
Could you help me with these nectar vials
over here?
I'm always afraid my old claws will drop
one.
Of course, Lady Scarab.
Weevil said deferentially.
He let go of blue and followed her to the
other side of the shop.
Waity scarab, Blue thought.
If she had a title, she must be related
to the queen.
A sister, or an aunt perhaps?
But not one with her own hive.
Still, she would be way up the hierarchy
of the hive wings, which explained
Weevil's behavior toward her.
Hmm, someone said honey drops, and now I
must have them, said Weevil's friend, who
had been blissfully pretending not to see
Luna or Blue.
We'll take 8 of those.
Six of the little sugar wasps and a box
of apricot taffy.
Make it pretty.
Of course, said the sales dragon.
He took a pale pink box out from under
the counter and started packing her order
into it.
Don't say anything.
Blue whispered to Luna, who was giving
Chafer her best murderous glare.
It's just the way it is.
To her credit, and Blue's surprise.
Luna bit her tongue until the 2 hive
wings were gone, sailing out of the shop
with their candy, and a few loud whispers
about poor wingless street urchins
cluttering up the place.
So, Luna said to Chafer, with strained
politeness, may we please have our honey
drops now?
After I serve the lady scarab.
He said sniffly.
But, those, you just, Luna protested.
I beg your pardon.
Blue turned and saw Lady Scarab, eyeing
Chafer like a bone she'd already chewed
on.
She had moved on from counting sugar
cubes to checking nectar vials under one
of the lamps.
But her talons were suddenly still, and
her tail was coiled up like a snake.
Am I to understand that you are delaying
these little no wings on my account?
It's no trouble, lady scarab.
Chafer oozed.
They can wait.
You are my 1st priority.
Well, I don't want to be, she snapped.
Serve them right now.
Blue poked Luna with his tail to try to
get the smug look off her face.
My lady, said Shafer.
I quite insist.
We do not serve 2nd class dragons before
royalty in this establishment.
Even if I insist, she said coldly.
They stared at each other for a long
moment, and Blue suddenly got the feeling
that there was something more complicated
about Lady Scarab's place in the hive
than he'd realized. something that made
this sales clerk willing to test the
edges of her dominance.
And then the air shifted.
Blue's nose twitched. and twitched
again.
It was some kind of smell.
It started small, a faint hint of
rottenness, but slowly grew stronger and
sharper and more horrible.
Luna covered her snout with a gagging
sound.
My lady, chafer cried.
Stumbling back as though the odor had
punched him in the face.
Please, don't.
I'll have to close my shop for the rest
of the day.
This isn't necessary.
I said, she hissed.
Serve them right now.
He scrabbled frantically behind the
counter, grabbed a small white box and
dumped 2 honey drops into it.
Here, he gasped at Luna.
Take it.
How much?
she asked through her talons.
Just get out of here, he begged.
Blue took the box, but Luna stopped to
pull a pair of scales out of her pouch.
She dropped them on the counter and
darted toward the door.
Thank you, I think, Lou said to Lady
Scarab, trying not to breathe through his
nose.
She looked serene and supremely
unbothered by the smell.
Choose an establishment friendlier to
silk wings next time, she suggested.
He nodded. and escaped out into the
market behind Luna.
Was that her?
Luna asked as they hurried between
stalls.
Did she make that awful smell?
I've heard some hive wings have that
power, he said, but I didn't think anyone
would ever actually use it.
I mean, why would they?
To terrorize their enemies.
Luna answered.
Moons.
I sure would.
If I had super stink powers.
I'd have blasted that weevil guy right in
a snout.
The moment he got anywhere near our wing
buds.
Ooh.
That would have been awesome.
For about too heartbeat.
Blue pointed out, and then it would have
been the opposite of awesome, because you
would be in jail forever.
Blue, she said.
Don't you think it's unfair that hive
wings can use their weapons on us anytime
they want, but we can't do anything to
fight back?
No.
He looked around quickly, but none of the
nearby dragons reacted as if they'd just
heard treason.
It was loud enough in the market, and
they were moving so quickly between
stalls, that he could hope no one would
overhear them.
The hive wings saved us, remember?
Our tribe agreed to accept their queen.
Besides, there's a reason why the
universe gave them weapons and not us.
That's why they're in charge.
But maybe, if we fought back, They
wouldn't be in charge, she pointed out.
Muna.
He herded her into the tunnels that led
to the other levels of the hive.
His voice dropped to a whisper.
For the love of silk.
What's gotten into you today?
I know sore tail is full of crazy ideas.
But please don't let him drag you into
prison along with him.
Those are my ideas, she said crossly.
He got them from me.
Well, then leave me out of it.
He covered his ears.
La, la, la.
Everyone's a good hive citizen here.
His sister rolled her eyes.
Oh, Blue.
She hesitated, studying his face, and
then shook her head, as though she hadn't
found the answer she wanted there.
All right, I'm sorry.
She flexed her claws and looked down at
her wrists.
It's probably because of my silk coming
in.
It hurts a lot more than I expected it
to.
Her palms and wrists were glowing even
brighter than before.
Blue hadn't noticed in the well lit
market.
But here in the dim tunnels, it was
impossible to ignore.
She seemed to have little balls of fire
clustered under her scales, bubbles of
molten orange and gold.
That doesn't look normal.
He said anxiously.
I've never seen anyone's silk glands do
that before metamorphosis.
Have you?
Sortail and his sister, Io, had gotten
their wings not too long ago.
He remembered their palms glowing a
little bit, but not like this.
And they hadn't mentioned anything about
it hurting.
Does metamorphosis hurt?
Why wouldn't someone warn us about that?
I'm sure it's nothing.
Luna said with a shrug.
Everyone metamorphosis a little
differently.
Should we take you to a doctor?
No way, she said.
She swiped the box of honey drops out of
his talons.
I'm not spending my perfect last day
getting prodded by some hive wing who
thinks we're all weird and revolting.
I'm totally fine.
To the mosaic garden.
Let's go.
Luna darted away up the tunnel.
Blue rubbed his own wrists worriedly, and
then followed her.
He could see the glow from her scales
reflecting off the tunnel walls.
Is she going to be all right?
If everything has to change, Could it at
least be ordinary predictable change?
Spirit of clear sight.
If you're listening.
Please take care of my sister.
Please let her metamorphosis be normal.
And if you have time, please could you
also make sure she's not arrested for
treason?
That would be great.
Thanks.
Chapter 3.
The mosaic garden glimmered in droplets
of amber and gold, cobalt and jade
obsidian and pearl.
Fragments of dragons prowled along the
walkways under claw and coiled around the
columns.
In the pavilions, claws and teeth roared
across the ceilings.
Ancient battles captured in bits of glass
forever.
Here at the top of the hive, the sky was
allowed to run free.
It was the only space where hive wings
could look up and see no roof, unless
they wanted to climb to the top layers of
the webs, which hive wings never did, or
venture into the dry savannah below.
Across the garden, sunlight drenched the
grassy slopes and hedgerows, soaking into
the obedient faces of the flowers that
marched rose carnation, marigold, violet
and orderly lines beside the path.
The scents were heavy and warm, like the
drowsy buzzing insects that browsed the
floral options.
The path itself seemed winding and random
branching and wandering back, but it
eventually spiraled everyone into the
central feature.
The Salvation Wall.
This morning, the garden was busy with
dragons, but Blue and Luna found a spot
on the grassy slope, where they could
sprawl with a view of the Salvation
Mosaic.
I'm not sure why you like this scene so
much, Blue said, as Luna passed him his
honey drop.
It has a few too many dead silk wings in
it for me.
His wing buds twitched, and he glanced
around, double checking that there were
no hive wings and earshot.
He didn't think, it was treason to
criticize the Salvation Mosaic, but it
certainly might be.
But even more dead leaf wings.
Luna pointed out.
Isn't that reassuring?
Blue didn't argue with her.
But he'd always found the mosaic sad
instead of triumphant.
He knew it showed the end of the war.
So it made sense that there were dead
dragons in it.
It should make him glad that these were
supposed to be the last dragons ever
killed in the war with the leaf wings.
He also knew they should all be grateful
to the hive wings for saving the silk
wings from the vicious green tribe.
But it just made him wonder why there had
to be a war at all.
Why didn't the leaf wings give up and go
away?
Or agree to be ruled by Queen Wasp.
Why did they fight so hard instead?
They must have known they couldn't win?
There were so many more hive wings.
And of course, there was the book, which
was guaranteed to guide the hive wings to
victory.
So why do the leaf wings bother
fighting?
Knowing so many dragons would die for no
good reason?
It was their own fault their tribe was
wiped out, if Luna was right, and they
were really gone.
Queen Sequoia should have given up her
throne and accepted Queen Wasp's
protection, like Queen Monarch did.
Then the leaf wings could have lived
alongside the silk wings.
All 3 tribes under one queen, working
together.
Maybe Queen Wasp would have left them
some trees to live in, between the
hives.
So what made them fight instead of
accepting that?
Had their queen really thought her tribe
had any chance of winning?
Blue studied the blocky, dark green shape
that was meant to be the queen of the
leaf wings.
It was so hard to imagine being Queen
Sequoia, leading an entire tribe into a
doomed war.
He didn't even like arguing with other
dragons.
If someone offered blue, peace and
stability.
And all he had to give up was a little
independence, he would say yes in a
heartbeat.
I hope I get to see it one day, Luna said
licking honey off her claws.
What?
he said, startled out of his reverie.
She pointed at the mosaic, at the central
yellow and black striped figure, holding
a rectangular shape over her head.
The only object in the mosaic made
entirely of gold tiles, so it caught the
sun like a fragment of fire.
The book of clear sight.
Luna said softly.
Don't you ever wonder what it says?
What the next big disaster will be?
Or what's going to happen to all of us
next?
Of course, Blue said.
But nobody gets to read it except the
queen and the librarian.
I could see it though, Luna said.
From a distance.
If I get to visit the temple one day.
Whoa, wasp hive's not that far away, Blue
said.
It'll be easy to visit the Temple of
Clearsight once you have wings.
If you're assigned a job with travel
permission and time off, he thought.
But didn't say out loud.
Luna had enough to worry about.
He stole a glance at her wrists, which
she kept rubbing and then resting in the
cool grass.
With the quiet lavender scales on his
arms glow like that in 6 days.
Was metamorphosis really more painful
than anyone had warned them?
He'd expected his wings to hurt a little
as they came in, but he hadn't even
thought to worry about his silk.
They heard the chatter of approaching
Dragonettes.
Enough voices that it was probably a
field trip from one of the fancy hive
wing schools.
Blue scooped up the empty sugar dream box
and they retreated to a less crowded
section of the garden, where they played
hide and seek, until the sun reached its
highest and began to slant back down the
sky.
They ate lunch at Luna's favorite cafe
and then wandered through the lady cicada
art gallery on one of the lower floors of
the hive.
Blue found all the different portraits of
Lady Zicada, little intense, but Luna
liked the tapestry rooms.
Weavings were the one kind of art that
was left entirely to silk wings.
A hive wing could probably buy dyed silk
threads from one of the market stalls, and
a loom, like the ones silk wing
dragonettes used for practice.
But none of them would bother with
learning to make a low silk wing art.
Which Blue thought was a bit silly.
They certainly didn't mind buying the
results, and hanging them all over their
walls.
He left Luna gazing at her favorite
tapestry, the one where Lady Cicada is
flying with a long trail of radiant silk
wings behind her in the sky.
While he checked out the sculpture
rooms.
Lady Cicada was old enough to have been
alive when there were still trees to
spare.
So there was one small wooden carving of
her in the middle of the clay and metal
and marble statues.
The wood was a shade of brown close to
her actual red color.
And Blue liked to look at it, and wonder
about the artist.
What did wood carvers do when there were
no more trees to carve?
Did they still get to make art?
And did they have to learn all new
techniques?
Or did the queen give them new jobs?
Did they ever wish all the trees weren't
gone?
Let's get to the cocoon, Luna said
appearing behind him.
Her pale green scales looked white in the
dim light of the gallery, and it was hard
to see the gold flecks along her back and
tail.
Her wing beds were definitely more
unfurled than they had been this morning
though, and her wrists were glowing as
brightly as the lamps.
We have a little more time, Blue said
seized with a sudden panic.
We could get another honey drop, or no
Luna said.
Her expression was strange, as though she
was already drifting into the
metamorphosis trance.
I think I need to get to the cocoon as as
quick as we can.
All right, Blue said.
Should he have made her see a doctor
after all?
But someone at the cocoon would know what
to do if there was anything wrong
surely.
They hurried to the outer spiral and down
level after level getting darker, as they
descended in strange silence.
For Luna, Blue couldn't remember a time
when she'd stopped talking for this
long.
Blue wasn't sure if he was imagining that
the hum seemed louder down here, as if
the insects outside were closer to the
hive, busily swarming around it.
The cocoon wasn't on quite the lowest
ground floor level of the hive, but it
was close to it.
Here, the streets were dimmer and
emptier.
The lamps fewer and farther between.
A few lower class hive wings lived down
here, in the small cells near the outer
spiral.
There was one hulking building that Blue
thought might be a training center for
guards.
The courtyard around it was open for a
few levels up, to give them space to fly
their exercises.
Blue glanced up as they went by.
Watching the dragons moving around the
streets above them.
Occasionally a flutter of black and red
wings broke the quiet.
As a hive wing flew from one side of the
hive to the other, to save walking time.
But the main thing on this level.
Was the cocoon.
A long oval dome, 2 levels tall, which
was swathed in so many beautiful weavings
it almost seemed to be made out of silk
itself.
Every silk wing and cicada hive came here
for his or her metamorphosis.
And according to tradition, Afterward
each one made a silk weaving for the dome
as an offering of thanks.
Some of the weavings, especially the
older ones were simple.
Shimmery, silver, gray silk, in the shape
of cobwebs, or sunbursts, or clouds.
Other dragons had used dyes to add
brilliant colors.
Here, a silver dragon spangled with
emerald green wings and matching green
eyes all around her.
Here a swarm of tiny orange butterflies
someone had even been able to afford 2
colors, weaving a midnight black shape of
a hive behind an iridescent blue web.
There were no trees, of course.
It was forbidden to include trees and art
ever since the leaf wings had been driven
out.
Even the hive shape was dangerously
closed to that of a tree.
And Blue wondered if the weaver had been
worried about that.
But for the 1st time, Maybe because
anxiety was sharpening his attention.
Blue noticed something on one of the
tapestries that looked like a leaf.
No, wait.
Was it a teardrop?
A single autumn red shape.
Somewhere between a leaf and a teardrop
and no bigger than his claw tip, gleamed
in the middle of the butterfly swarm.
Was he seeing that right?
Why spend the money on a 2nd die color
and only use it in such a small way?
Wait.
There was another one.
He blinked, startled.
This one was slightly darker red.
Hidden against the black backdrop of the
hive weaving.
His eyes scanned the dome.
There was another.
Veiled among a spray of escaping diamonds
from a waterfall.
Blue wrinkled his snout, puzzled.
Now that he was looking, there were
little red leaf drops hidden in half the
weavings he could see.
Why had so many silk wings decided to
include that shape and that color?
If it meant something, why didn't he know
about it?
Blue realized that Luna was staring up at
the dome weavings too, opening and
closing her talons nervously.
He thought about asking her if she'd
noticed the hidden red shapes.
But it wasn't worth it to start a
conversation that might stress her out.
What she needed was distraction and
calming down.
What you're weaving going to look like?
he asked.
Have you decided?
She'd been talking about nothing else for
weeks.
So Blue had heard all her ideas.
But he was mostly trying to get her to
smile, or blink, or do anything to
reassure him that his bubbly sister was
still in there.
Luna winced.
I don't know, she said.
I have to.
Get through this first.
You'll be fine, Blue said.
Taking her front talons in his.
I've never heard of anything going wrong
during a metamorphosis.
I'm sure what you're feeling is totally
normal.
All of this is normal.
It's going to be all right.
Everything is always all right in the end
you know?
You're going to wake up with awesome
wings and cool silk and fly everywhere
and be the greatest spinner in the
history of the hives.
Luna closed her eyes and whispered.
Everything is always all right, as though
he'd just said, the sun is always shining
or, the bees would absolutely love for
you to take all their honey.
Instead.
Blue was relieved to see a cluster of
dragons gathered near the low arched
entrance of the cocoon.
Maybe one of them could get through to
Luna.
Look how popular you are, he joked.
But his smile faded, as they got closer
and he realized that most of the gathered
dragons were hive wing guards.
Why are there so many guards?
He was sure that normally there were only
two.
He remembered the 2 extremely bored
looking guards who had fallen asleep by
the exit during Swordell's metamorphosis
while he and Luna called encouraging
words to their friend.
But today, there were at least 5 outside
and they all looked anything but bored.
Black and yellow and red scales shifted
and caught the dim lamplight, as the hive
wings scowled and stamped their feet.
Two of them carried weapons.
But the other 3 looked menacing enough
without them.
Most likely they had venom in their claws
or shot poisonous darts from their tails
or something along those lines.
Blue shot a worried look at Luna.
First silverspot, and Luna's weird
glowing scales.
Now all these guards.
What does everyone know that we don't?
Chapter 4.
Blue had to keep Luna calm.
Whatever was going on?
He didn't want her to go into her
metamorphosis feeling scared or anxious.
Why are there so many guards today?
Luna whispered to Blue.
Weren't there only 2 at SoraTales
metamorphosis?
Oh, I don't remember, he said brightly.
I'm sure there are always this many, and
we just never noticed them.
Hmm, she said doubtfully.
Muna.
Swartail cried, emerging from the group
and bounding toward them.
His scales were dark blue, with a small
pattern of white triangles along his
spine and snout, and then dappled all
over with orange splotches, as though
someone had melted a sunset in a cauldron
and flung it at his wings.
Blue always thought of his friend as one
of the shiniest silk wings around, bright
and gleaming, the way Sortell had been
when they 1st met on the school racetrack
5 years ago.
But lately, Sortell was always covered in
dirt.
With splinters of tree stuff caught
between his claws, entangled in his long
elegant horns.
And all too often he wore this
expression.
This worried, grim look that was really
the last thing Luna needed today.
Happy Metamorphosis Day.
Blue said to him, perhaps a little too
loud.
He widened his eyes significantly at
sword tail.
Isn't this exciting?
Are you all right?
Sortell asked, gathering Luna into his
wings.
She leaned into him, as though she'd been
flying for days, and he was the island
she'd been searching for.
He took one of her front talons in his
and soft gray silk spun out from his
wrists, gently wrapping around hers to
wind them together.
I can't believe you're here.
Luna said.
I thought Grasshopper would never let you
come.
Sortail made a face.
He didn't.
I finished all my work and asked, yes
very politely, blue, I promise.
And he still said no.
He shrugged.
So I snuck off when he wasn't looking.
Blue's idea of politely, tended to be
quite different from sword tails.
But Blue had met Soretail's boss once, and
was not at all surprised that Grasshopper
had tried to keep Soretail from attending
Luna's metamorphosis.
Silverspot's mistress would do it out of
spite.
Grasshopper most likely said no, because
he was still trying to teach sword tail
obedience and good behavior.
If Sordail would quit picking bites with
hive wings, and expressing unpopular
opinions all over the place, Blue
thought.
Perhaps figures of authority would be a
little less annoyed with him, and his
life would be a little bit easier.
Oh, sword tail, he said ruefully, you're
going to be in so much trouble.
Doesn't matter.
This is more important.
Soratel turned Luna's palms up. and
frowned at the glowing embers under her
scales.
Whoa.
Does it look weird to you?
Luna said anxiously.
Of course not, Blue said.
You're totally fine.
I remember a little bit of light where my
silk came in, but not this bright
Soartail said, completely trampling over
Blue's efforts to calm Luna down.
I'm not.
I'm not sure this is normal.
Io.
Have you seen anything like this before?
He turned to his sister as she came up to
join them.
Directly behind her was Blue's mother.
Burnett, who stepped around the others to
give Blue and Luna quick hugs.
No.
Io said, sounding even more alarmed than
he did.
Her wings had come in several months
ago.
Huge and dark purple, with shimmers of
aquamarine green.
She was only a year older than them, but
she had long aristocratic looking bones
and horns, and she towered over Luna.
You don't think?
They both glanced to burn it for some
reason, but she wouldn't meet their
eyes.
Oh, she said carelessly.
I've been to so many of these, and
there's always something surprising.
Never anything serious, though.
Nothing to worry about.
Blue had never heard his mother lie in
his own stretched.
Everything is fine here, voice.
It made him feel as if his nice normal
world was as thin as paper, and is easy
to stab holes in.
Are you Luna?
One of the hive wing guards said roughly
slithering up to them.
He muscled Sortell aside, breaking the
slender threads that bound him and Luna
together.
You're late.
Time to get inside.
Sorry Luna said.
Which was what she was supposed to say
and yet so unlike Luna to actually say it
that Blue shivered.
The ground felt unsteady below him.
Also, they were not late, not even by a
heartbeat.
All hive wings and silk wings had a
precise internal clock, that always kept
their days on schedule, and warned them
when the rainy season was coming.
Blues told him they were right on time.
But of course, he wasn't about to argue
with the guard.
I love you, Luna.
Swartail said fiercely.
We do too, said Burnett, and Blue
nodded.
Although his sister wasn't looking at
them and didn't seem to hear them
either.
You lot, up to the balcony, if you must
stay.
The guard said, waving one of his crimson
and black dappled wings at the side
entrance.
He gave Luna a small shove in the
direction of the archway, and she went
with only one last nervous glance back at
them before she disappeared inside.
Should we do something?
Io asked SwordTail, tell someone?
There's no time.
He said.
His long blue antennae unfurled.
Twitching, and he turned to stride toward
the dome.
And it's probably not.
I mean, it's so rare.
What?
Blue asked.
Tell someone what?
What are you so worried about?
Io, what's so rare?
Io looked as though she might be about to
tell him, but...
Nothing, Bernard said, putting one wing
over Blue's shoulders.
Don't worry, sweetheart.
Let's go cheer for Luna.
He let his mother steer him through the
side entrance and up the stairs. their
footsteps muffled on the ancient silver
silk carpets.
The gallery was a long open balcony that
ran around the entire dome, overlooking
the dim, quiet floor below.
The only light came from small candles
floating in the central pool of water.
Blue started toward their usual spot, on
the far side of the dome, but Burnett
gently tugged him back.
Let's stand here this time, she said
choosing a spot not far from the stairs.
Soretail and Io joined them.
The faint glow of candlelight rippling
along their iridescent scales.
Swordtail rested his front talons on the
thick stone railing so he could lean over
the edge, as though trying to get as
close to Luna as he could.
Blue wouldn't do that until he had
wings.
It wasn't far to fall, but it would still
hurt if he did.
All around them, silk wings were gathered
in the shadows of the balcony.
Friends and family to the 3 other
dragonettes undergoing metamorphosis
today.
Blue recognized many of their faces, lit
from below like eerie moons all around
the dome.
Most of them were whispering to one
another.
But a hush fell as Luna was escorted onto
the floor.
Like the others.
Her wristband had been cut off by the
guards.
Now, in the twilight room next to the
other dragons, and with her scales more
visible.
It was terrifyingly clear that something
different was happening to Luna.
Where the others had a pale, silvery
light coming from their wrists.
Luna seemed to have fireflies on fire.
Startling spots of molten gold.
Blue felt Io grab sore tails' arm, but he
couldn't look away from his sister, all
alone on the cocoon floor.
I'm the one who was with her all day.
I should have noticed that something was
wrong.
I should have made her ask someone for
help.
One Silkwing.
A starved looking turquoise dragonette
from their class at school, had already
entered her metamorphosis trance.
Two long seamless strands of moon colored
silk spiraled out of her wrists.
Her eyes were closed, and her talons
moved automatically, weaving the silk
into a cocoon around her.
As Luna glanced around nervously, a 2nd
dragonette drifted into his trance and
lifted his talons, silk threads spinning
out.
His cocoon looked like the 1st
dragonettes, like every silk wings.
It would shelter him for 5 days and
nights while his wings came in.
Sortell had promised blue, that he
wouldn't remember a thing about the trans
time.
The blue found that almost scarier.
The idea that he'd be unconscious to the
world for that long, and then he'd come
out looking totally different.
Not totally different.
Soritel insisted, I still look like me
don't I?
Which he sort of did, except that the
wings made him look quite a bit bigger
and more dramatic.
The 3rd dragonette was eyeing Luna's
wrists with concern and taking small
sidling steps away from her.
Whisperers were gusting through the
watching silk wings, like the sweeping
winds that shook their webs before the
storms of the rainy season.
There were even more guards now.
At least 7 of them, most standing
unsettlingly close to Luna, and
pretending not to watch her, while their
eyes darted constantly from her to the
balcony to the pool, to the others, and
back to her.
Luna held out her front talons, and the
whole world seemed to hold its breath for
a moment.
Then suddenly.
She let out a sharp cry, and silk began
to spiral out of her wrists.
But it wasn't normal grace silk.
Luna's silk flared like threads of lava
erupting from under her scales.
It hissed as it hit the air, lighting up
the room with sudden bright star
brilliance.
It was like the fire of the sun twisted
into filaments that snaked back to clutch
at Luna's talons, her legs, her whole
body.
Oh no, Io whispered.
She looked at Swordtail, whose face was
transfixed with horror.
Flame silk, he breathed.
Chapter 5.
Wood's flame silk, Blue asked frantically
as the guards advanced toward his
sister.
He shook sore tail with trembling
talons.
What's happening?
What's wrong with Luna?
The 3rd dragonette down below, bolted for
the far side of the dome, and tried to
scramble up one of the side walls, away
from the guards and the burning light.
Luna shrieked with fear, and leaped away
from the fiery silk spilling out of her
but there was nowhere to go.
It clung to her like a real cocoon wood
winding around her talons and legs, even
as she tried to claw it away.
Is it burning her?
Blue cried.
He turned to Io, his voice high and
desperate.
Io, is she all right?
What is flame silk?
It won't hurt her, his mother said.
But her voice was as sad and soft as the
splash of a silk wrapped corpse slipping
into the bay.
Did you know, Io asked Burnett, fiercely
over Blue's head?
Silverspot and I suspected.
Bernard answered.
Their father didn't say anything.
And you couldn't tell by looking at him.
But he was watched so carefully and taken
away so quickly.
We knew there had to be something.
You could have warned us.
Io hissed.
We could have hidden her.
Barnett shook her head.
Luna let out another fainter cry
collapsing forward with her eyes closed.
The flame silk spun on and on, and
everywhere it touched her she went still
as though it was tranquilizing her.
Everybody, please remain calm.
One of the hive wings said smoothly
spreading his wings to address the
horrified audience of silk wings.
We are well prepared for silkwing
diseases like this, everything is under
control.
Diseases.
Blue echoed in a choked whisper.
Io scowled.
His sister wouldn't be left to transform
quietly on the floor of the cocoon, like
the other 2 small silken bundles beside
her.
Already she was surrounded by all the
guards, spears lifted, swords and claws
and tail spikes all pointed at her, as
though her flame silk cocoon might sprout
fiery wings and try to escape.
And a dark metal cart was rattling
through the door.
Yawning mouth ready to swallow her up.
Luna!
Swartell shouted, shaken out of his
horror by the side of the cart, he
vaulted over the balcony railing, and
plummeted to the floor below, with barely
enough time to spread his wings to break
his fall.
His legs were already moving as he landed
galloping across the floor toward the
guards.
What do we do?
Blue asked Io and Burnett.
Should they all jump down and try to save
Luna?
But there were so many guards.
And maybe they were trying to help her.
They did say they were prepared, so
they'd seen this before.
Maybe they could take her somewhere to
cure her.
Maybe they could fix her silk and make it
normal.
You, run, Io said.
She dragged Blue away from the railing
and shoved him at the stairs.
Me?
Blue said, astonished.
He can't escape.
Bernard argued tiredly, following Io.
There's nowhere he can go.
It would be safer for him to turn himself
in.
No way, Io cried.
We can't just let them take him.
Why would they take me?
Blue yelped in alarm.
His talons scrabbled on the stone floor
as Io pushed him forward again.
I didn't do anything.
I'm not sick.
Neither is Luna.
Io pointed out.
She herded him along in front of her
talking fast as they stumbled down the
steps.
Flame silk is something you hatch with.
She must have inherited it from your
father, which means you have it too.
Which means they'll come for you next.
But why?
He said.
One of his claws snagged painfully on the
carpet.
He paused to unhook it, looked back up
the stairs, and saw his mother watching
him go with a bleak expression.
Watching, but not following.
She'd already given up.
What are they going to do with Luna?
We don't know, Io said.
We've never been able to find out.
Flame soaks are very rare, and the hive
wings make them banish immediately.
Vanish?
Blue echoed.
Like, forever?
His insides felt as if they'd all leaped
off the top of the hive, and were
currently plummeting toward the distant
ground.
Do you see why you have to run?
Io pushed open the door at the bottom of
the stairs and looked out.
All clear.
Quick, while they're busy with Luna and
Sortail.
Blue dug in his claws as she tried to
throw him out the door.
Wait, wait.
Run where?
He pleaded.
Anywhere. she said.
Run, hide, and don't let them find you.
But I'll get in trouble, he said.
I can't hide from the hive wings.
Mother's right.
If they want me, I should turn myself
in.
They won't hurt me.
His voice wavered, thinking of flame
silks vanishing forever.
Disappeared so thoroughly that he'd never
even heard of them.
Maybe they can fix me, so I won't have
flame silk.
Io groaned softly.
Why did it have to be you?
she said.
The one silk wing who thinks hive wings
have any good in them.
Listen, Blue, stop trusting them right
now.
They've let you go about your ordinary
life so far, but now, you look dangerous
to them, and they're not going to let you
have that life back.
It's gone.
But it doesn't have to be.
Blue protested.
If I'm good, if I do what I'm told, I
mean, I'm not dangerous.
I could never be dangerous.
I know, Io said, rubbing the spot on her
forehead between her horns.
Unfortunately, I think that's true.
She took his shoulders and shook him.
But they don't care.
Please, promise me you'll hide from them
blue.
Don't let them catch you.
For how long?
Blue said.
Where can I go?
What about my metamorphosis?
It's really soon.
And then I'll have to come back here.
Io sighed.
Let's hide you 1st and then figure that
out.
She said.
She shoved open the door, flung him
outside and bolted after him.
Blue found himself running, even though
his brain was shouting at him to go back
to ask the guards for help, to make sure
Luna was all right.
Was she still terrified?
Or had this silk entranced her?
Taking her into peaceful darkness even as
chaos swarmed outside her cocoon.
What had the guards done to Swordtail?
He could never fight so many.
A silk wing didn't stand a chance against
even one hive wing.
Was he lying beside Luna on the sand now
bleeding and swollen with venom?
Blue shuddered, his claws wobbling
underneath him.
They had just reached to the edge of the
outer courtyard when he heard shouts
behind them.
Stop.
You there.
Silk Wings, stop at once.
His feet obeyed instinctively.
Guards were talking to him.
Guards were to be listened to.
You never argued with high wing guards, or
else you'd get sprayed, or stabbed with
something.
Everyone knew that.
But Io didn't stop.
Io threw her talons around his chest and
hurled up into the air, her spectacular
wings pumping desperately.
I-O!
Blue yelped with fear. as his claws left
the ground.
Suddenly they were flying along the
narrow streets.
Flashes of startled faces peering out of
windows at them.
The indigo whirl of Io's wings beat
around Blue's head, and he covered his
eyes.
Stop.
Queen Wasp orders you to stop at once.
Where did Io think they were going?
There was nowhere in the hives where
Queen Wasp wouldn't find them.
Nobody ran from the queen's guards, and
she would surely kill them both for
disobeying her orders.
Io let out a small roar of frustration
and Blue peeked through his claws.
They were nearly at the exit that led to
the tunnels spiraling up.
The guards were closing rank in front of
it, spears crossed, teeth gleaming.
That's the only exit.
Blue thought frantically.
There weren't even any windows or ledges
to the open sky on this level of the
hive.
Oh, he realized, with a fresh burst of
terror.
That's probably intentional.
So there's no way for a flame silk to
escape.
I a whirled in the air. and shot down one
of the avenues toward the training
center.
Which, frankly, seemed like a poorly
thought out plan.
Blue could see a small army of eager
looking hive wing trainees swarming out
of the front gate.
Yellow striped wings flicked and buzzed
sharp white teeth snapped to the air as
the dragon spread out to search the
streets.
For us, they are searching for us.
But then IO banked suddenly left and up.
Up through the open courtyard toward the
higher hive levels.
Blue yelped again, as the ground dropped
even farther away, and then really wished
she hadn't even thought the word
dropped.
Shouts of fury rose from below. followed
by the sound of buzzing, beating wings, as
all the guards and soldiers took to the
air.
We're going to die, Blue thought.
There's so many of them, and they have
wait.
Why aren't they shooting at us?
He knew some of the hive wings behind
them had dart weapons and spears.
So why hadn't they thrown them?
Dragons on the surrounding levels, rushed
to the edge of the ledges to watch the
chase.
Blue had never had this many eyes on him
before.
What do they see?
What do they think?
Does anyone want to help?
Or are they all hoping we'll be caught?
And it'll be exciting to watch.
Suddenly, Io was jerked backward, and
Blue felt himself slip through her talons
for just a moment until she dug her claws
in.
Ouch, and gave a mighty heave of her
wings, kicking backward at the high wing
who'd grabbed her tail.
They struggled in the air, blue dangling
between them, and then Io swept her wings
in a huge arc, and threw blue up toward
the highest open level.
Yaha!
Blue screamed.
He flung out his claws and felt them
catch in their rough tree stuffed walls.
His body slammed into the side with a
bone jarring thump, and he dug in his
back talons desperately.
Up. Io shouted to him. as she swung her
attacker like a club, smashing other hive
wings away.
Climb blue.
Go. He tried to imagine he was out on the
webs.
Having a perfectly normal climb, with
lots and lots and lots of secure webs
below to catch him.
He pushed himself up and up again, and in
a moment, he felt the ledge above.
He clutched at it, his wing buds churning
as though they could help.
Two faces peered down at him, silk wings
ones he didn't know.
But he could guess what they were
thinking.
Should we help this wingless dragonette?
Will the hive wings punish us if we do?
What has he done to make the guards chase
him?
He must be a very bad dragon to be
running from the guards.
But if we let him fall, he'll die.
Talons reached down and circled his
wrists.
Strong arms pulled him up to safety.
He sprawled on the tree stuff, gasping
more from fear than exhaustion.
This was a residential level, full of
hive wing homes, a bit smaller than the
one where Silverspot worked, and he'd
landed in their school's practice
vegetable garden.
All around him were garden boxes full of
dirt and little tendrils of, maybe one
day I'll be a plant, labeled with
optimistic scrawls on flat wooden
sticks.
The 2 silk wings, watching him with
confusion, were the only dragons nearby.
But he could see hive wings running
toward him along the streets, and others
spreading their wings on the far side of
the city.
Io, he panted, scrambling up.
Is she?
Are you all right?
Asked the gray blue silkwing, with
speckles of yellow across her scales.
What?
began the other, but he broke off as Io
landed on the ledge behind Blue.
The seeds will grow again.
Io said to them.
She shoved Blue forward without waiting
for a response.
But he saw a look of recognition cross
their faces.
What?
He said to her, as they plunged down the
nearest empty street.
He glanced back and saw the silk wings
casually blocking the road behind them
their wings spread wide, as they started
arguing about something.
There are silkwings who will help you.
IO said rapidly, if you can find them.
A group called the Chrysalis.
The houses they ran past were narrow but
elegant, made of tree stuff that flowed
straight into the street below, and into
the roof above them, as though they had
grown with the hive.
Most of them had intricate patterns of
seashells, or glass tiles embedded in
their outer walls, spirals of pearl pink
coral, or zigzagging diamonds of
aquamarine.
Street lamps that hung from the ceiling
above, cast a warm glow over everything
deceptively calm and cozy, like a shroud
of silk around a wasp nest.
The chrysalis?
What?
Why don't I know about them?
Blue asked, breathing hard.
He'd never run this much for this long in
his life.
His sides ached, and his talons hurt, and
his eyes were blurry, and his heart felt
like a beehive about to explode.
Io snorted.
Because every time someone says to you
hey, wasn't that mean what that hive wing
did, you say, oh, maybe she's tired, or
frustrated with work, or just lost
something important, or is having a fight
with her sister.
And then it's kind of hard to follow up
with, well, so care to join a movement to
take her down?
A movement?
Blue sputtered.
To take who down?
The street abruptly ended, spilling them
out into a hive wing park.
Or at least, it looked a bit like a park
but without any grass or flowers.
Instead, the vast circle was full of
playground structures carved from real
wood, dark and smooth, like the abandoned
bones of ancient trees.
Many of them arched all the way to the
roof, which was probably a lot of fun if
you are a dragonette with wings, and a
chance of surviving a fall from that
height.
A hive wing school, shinier and much
bigger than Silkworm Hall, loomed along
one side of the park, and in the center
of the circle was a pool of water lined
with silver bright mirror tiles.
On the far side of the park, Blue caught
a glimpse of slanting sunset light
through one of the openings where dragons
could fly in and out of the hive.
Out that window were the savannah and the
open sky.
But how could they get there?
The park was full of hive wings
dragonettes playing, parents gathering
water from the pool, guards and families
and teachers who'd finished school for
the day, all strolling the paths, filling
the space between here and escape.
He'd wondered why the houses they ran
past seemed to be empty.
Apparently, this park was the place where
the entire neighborhood gathered at the
end of the day.
Duck your head.
Io said.
Pretend to be a servant.
Walk quickly, but not too fast.
She folded her wings in close. and darted
out onto one of the more crowded pathways
weaving between dragons.
With her head bowed submissively.
She blended in with the other silkwing
servants blue could see here and there
many of them carrying heavy water jugs, or
keeping an eye on young dragonettes, while
hive wing parents chatted with each
other.
This is never going to work, Blue thought
as he ducked his head and followed her.
And yet, for a moment, it seemed as if it
might.
The hive wings barely glanced at 2 more
lowly silk wings.
They were so busy with one another.
It was as though the silk wings didn't
exist.
Many of them were watching a group of
young dragonettes lead from a climbing
structure, their tiny wings pumping to
help them drift down.
One little black and orange dragonette
crashed into blue as she ran across to
her friends, but she just yelped, oops
sorry, and kept going.
It looked like a nice place to live.
Perhaps not as huge and impressive as the
higher level where Silver Spot's mistress
had her mansion, but a place where
families were friends with one another.
These dragons made one another laugh
worked hard, cared about their
dragonettes.
They were happy to be safe.
They weren't so different from Blue and
his family.
Surely they wouldn't let him be dragged
away by guards to whatever happened to
flame silks.
Did they even know about flame silks?
Behind him, he heard clanking and running
talon steps.
He tried to deck his head even farther
following Io around a tall, fort like
playhouse, where 3 hive wing dragonettes
passed pretend honey tea out the
windows.
The open air wasn't too far away now.
In a moment, Io could swoop him off into
the grassland.
Hive Wings didn't like going out too far
into the Savannah, so they should be able
to find somewhere to hide out there.
And then Io could explain everything to
him, and they could figure out a safe way
to make this right.
They were passing behind a cluster of
tiny dragonettes in a sandbox, when the
silence fell.
It fell so suddenly, like a wall of
nothingness, that Blue found himself
pausing to touch his ears in
bewilderment.
Why did everyone stop?
Talking.
He glanced around uneasily.
They hadn't just stopped talking.
Every hive wing inside was frozen.
Right in the middle of whatever they'd
been doing.
The dragonette halfway up the climbing
structure had one claw raised.
The twins in the sandbox were scowling at
each other, mouths open, but no sound
coming out.
Io slowed to a stop in front of him.
Spreading her wings slightly to keep him
back.
Her gaze nervously darted around at the
silent dragons.
Blue realized that the other silk wings
in the park were looking around too, many
of them just as bewildered.
And then the hive wings lifted their
heads.
All of them at once, and tilted their
chins toward the east.
Blue felt a scream building in his
throat.
All of their eyes had gone pure white.
Find the flame soaked dragonette.
The hive wings said in unison.
Capture him, and bring him to me.
Chapter 6.
A shriek of terror ripped through the
heavy air.
But it wasn't coming from blue.
It came from near the pool.
From a young silk wing, with pale blue
and pink wings, holding a baby hive wing
in his arms.
The tiny dragonette glared up at him with
its fathomless eyes.
Aphid?
The silk wing cried.
What's wrong with you?
Aphid, can you hear me?
Aphid bared small teeth, and twisted his
body fiercely, struggling to get free.
Let him go, said an older silkwing softly
touching the younger one's shoulder.
They're not themselves right now.
The dragonette snapped at his caretaker's
talons, as the silk wings set him gently
on the ground.
Where is the flame silk?
Avid said, and spine chilling unison with
the other hive wings.
Who can see him?
The hive wings all slowly.
Eerily began swiveling their heads
staring in turn at each silk wing in
their line of sight, like snakes studying
a herd for the weakest prey.
Io?
Blue whispered as softly as he could.
I think.
Run, she whispered back.
They bolted for the exit.
Blues, legs, screaming in protest.
Every head snapped toward them.
A black spotted scarlet dragonette, no
taller than Blue's wing buds, threw
herself off a slide at them, hissing.
She landed on Io's back and sank in her
claws, but Io dove into a roll and
knocked her off.
Blue felt pin pricks of pain stab into
his ankle.
He glanced back as he ran, and found an
orange dragonette with his teeth embedded
in Blue's back leg, too small to do much
damage, but hanging on grimly.
How do I shake him off without hurting
him?
Blue thought frantically.
There was no more time to think.
Two much larger hive wings blocked their
path, wings spread and claws gleaming.
Give up, wingless, they said, you cannot
escape me.
Blue skitted to a stop, and the
dragonette tumbled off his ankle.
There were hive wings in every direction
all focused on him.
The voice was right.
There was no, Io barreled into the 2
dragons in front of them.
Her wings flapped huge and purple in
their faces, driving them back for a
moment, clearing a path.
And there was the sky.
Blue darted to the opening and ran pell
mell toward the ledge.
It was close now.
He could see 2 of the 3 moons rising.
He could see small twisted trees, and a
distant giraffe, and the long yellow
grass waving far below. too far below.
He reached the edge and froze.
The wall of the hive plunged down before
him.
Impossibly steep, impossibly terrifying.
This level was far below the webs, but
still a long way from the ground.
Blue couldn't possibly jump from here.
He would break his neck and die.
If only I had my wings.
He turned and saw Io fighting off 3 full
grown hive wings.
Their talons slashed at her side, and one
had his tail raised to stab her with a
stinger at the end.
Io!
Blue cried.
Go, Blue, she shrieked.
Get out of here.
I can't.
He felt tears finally start to flood his
eyes.
I can't go without you.
In a way, he meant.
I can't fly from here.
I need your wings.
But in another deeper way.
He really meant that he couldn't leave
her at the mercy of these zombie
dragons.
He couldn't keep running, alone.
Knowing she would be caught and punished
and punished worse if he did escape.
You have to.
She shouted.
But she must have realized he couldn't
take that leap.
As he took an indecisive step back toward
her.
She kicked a hive wing in the face and
broke free for a moment, just long enough
for her to grab a twisted ladder
structure, and knock it over between her
and her attackers.
And the breath that gave her.
She shot a twist of silk from her wrists
up at the ceiling, and another that
coiled around Blue's ankle.
A heartbeat later, he was hurled toward
the roof.
His claws caught the webs that Io was
shooting across the top of the cavern.
Instinctively, he swung to the next one
and then the next.
He jumped swiftly.
Like they'd learned to do in school
during emergency drills.
What if the web is falling?
What if you have to get to a hive quickly
for safety?
What if you only have a few strands of
silk to escape along?
But those drills had been about the
thread of leaf wings attacking the webs.
They were practiced so that little
wingless dragonettes would be ready to
flee to a place where hive wings could
protect them.
Never once, despite his overactive
imagination.
Had Blue ever imagined using these skills
to run away from hive wings?
He shot over the heads of the families on
the playground so fast that they lost
track of him for a moment.
As they whipped their heads around
buzzing and hissing, he reached the end
of Io's silk, shielded by a tall slide
near the walls of the school, and looked
back.
Io was almost the ledge, and with the
hive wings distracted, looking for him.
She might be able to get out and fly
away.
But not with him.
She'd only be able to escape without
him.
He gouged a chunk of tree stuff out of
the ceiling above him, and threw it as
far and hard as he could.
It landed with a scattering thud halfway
across the playground, and all the hive
wings spun toward the sound.
Blue let go of Io's silk, and dropped to
the top of the school wall, then over it
and down into the small courtyard
beyond.
Triangles of lime colored chalk marked
out the games young hive wings played
here during recess.
For a moment.
Blue thought about grabbing one of the
pale blue metal practice spears that
leaned against the wall.
But the truth was that he'd be more
likely to hurt himself than anyone else
with one of those, and he couldn't even
begin to imagine stabbing another dragon
on purpose.
Where do I go?
He glanced around the courtyard, trying
to catch his breath.
It was surrounded on all sides by the
school, except for the wall behind him
which had the neighborhood park and a
horde of white eyed zombie dragons on the
other side.
They'll follow the trail of Ayu silk. and
figure out where I went in a moment.
Even if I can get out of this school
somehow.
Where would I go after that?
I can't go back to mother.
I'm sure Swordtail will be on misbehavors
way by morning.
If he's still alive.
And I have no idea what they've done with
Luna.
He pressed his talons to his mouth.
He didn't have time to cry.
He didn't have time to be sucked into
imagining how Luna and sore tail, and
Burnett and Io must be feeling right
now.
He started across the courtyard toward
one of the school doors.
Although at this time of day, he was
afraid they'd all be locked.
Psst.
Over here.
Blue whirled around.
A small equipment shed was built along
the side of one of the school walls, the
door was open a crack, and a pair of
golden yellow talons was reaching out of
it, beckoning to him.
He could hear the hive wing voices
issuing commands on the other side of the
wall.
There wasn't time to be worried and
indecisive.
He bolted toward the shed, and let the
strange talons yank him inside.
The door snicked shut behind him. leaving
them in pitch darkness.
Blue tripped over a ball under his claws
and the other dragon caught him, strong
arms holding him up.
He felt the brush of wings against his
side.
This was a silk wing who had already gone
through metamorphosis then, but it must
have been recently.
This dragon was smaller than he was.
Who?
He whispered.
She said.
She wrapped her front claws softly around
his snout.
The shed was small, and packed with
paraphernalia.
There was barely room for Blue and the
other dragon to stand.
His claws fell clumsily entangled with
hers.
His neck kept bumping against cool scales
and her tail lightly rested over his.
But she was so perfectly still, that he
couldn't pull away.
Or at least, he feared that if he did, he
might knock over a wall of armor or
something.
He wondered if she could feel his heart
slamming around his chest.
Did she work at the school?
cleaning hive wing classrooms, or
preparing their snacks.
Had she ever seen the hive wings act like
this before?
As though their minds had all melded into
one?
Did she know what was happening?
And how dangerous it was to protect him?
Don't move, she whispered.
Apple scented breath in his ear.
She let go of his face, and in the dark
he felt her crouch beside him, reaching
for the inner wall.
Her wings were like a cloud of
butterflies against his scales, touching
down and taking off in a 1000 little
brushes.
Maybe she was scared too.
Or had she rescued other silk wings like
this before?
He tried to imagine being that brave
brave enough to see a dragon in trouble.
And an entire tribe turned terrifying, and
still reach out to help.
Maybe if he imagined it hard enough, he
could make himself a little braver too.
She took one of his front talons and
touched it to the wall, or rather, to a
spot where the wall disappeared, an
opening, a trap door into a tunnel.
Stay close to me, she whispered.
The tunnels can be confusing.
Are you with the chrysalis?
He whispered back, his nose bumping hers
as he turned toward her.
She touched his mouth again.
A hush gesture before ducking into the
tunnel.
He followed as close as he dared, trying
not to step on her tail.
It was like crawling through an ant farm
following the tunnels in a winding maze
through the walls of the school.
Here and there chinks of light shone
through the cracks, and blue caught
glimpses of the buttercup yellow scales
of the dragon in the dark.
Through the cracks, he could also see
fragments of the school, even rows of
tables, a blackboard covered with neat
columns of numbers, an easel divided into
narrow lines of blue and black paint.
At last, she stopped, and peeked through
a small hole just at eye level.
After a moment, she unlatched a trap door
pushed it open, and climbed out, beckoning
for him to follow.
He had to deck his head as he came
through.
Since the trap door opened out of the
wall under a long table.
Blue's eyes were dazzled for a moment as
he crawled out.
Although the room they were in was not
particularly bright.
It had no outer windows and was led only
by a few small lamps.
The 1st thing he saw, as his eyes
adjusted, were the books.
Shelves and shelves of books, reaching
floor to ceiling all around the room.
He stretched his aching legs and turned
in a slow, wondering circle, thinking of
the students who were lucky enough to
attend a school with so many books.
Had anyone read all of them?
Did the librarian love handing them out?
Or did she wish she could keep all of
them safely within the circle of her
wings?
This is our library. said his rescuer
hopping up onto the table and curling her
tail around her back claws.
I know, it's pretty small, but it's
closed most of the time.
We share our librarian with a bigger
school up level.
So it's a good place to hide when the
rest of the tribe goes all creepy eyes.
Blue turned slowly toward her, his heart
thumping like mad.
Her claws were small and sharp, like a
leopard's, and her fore wings swooped
down from her back in beautiful smooth
folds.
She had an open, curious face, gold
rimmed spectacles, and warm, dark brown
eyes that made him think of owls and tree
hollows.
In the glow of the lamplight.
Her scales were gold and tangerine.
But speckled here and there with black
scales that looked like tiny ink blots.
Black scales.
The unmistakable sign of a dragon
descended from clear sight.
Silkwings never had black scales.
His rescuer was a hive wing.
Chapter 7.
Blue inhaled sharply.
I I thought, he stammered.
Wow, you're beautiful, she said
wonderingly.
I've never seen a silk wing in those
shades of blue and purple before.
Is that what your parents look like too?
Um, he said, looking down at his Azure
talons.
Not exactly.
Or I mean, I'm not sure.
I've never met my father.
Shouldn't you?
Really?
She said.
She tipped her head at him.
Catching sparkles from the lamps and her
glasses.
Why don't you know your father?
Is that normal for Silk Wings?
Don't you live with your parents?
Or, I'm sorry.
Is that a question I'm not supposed to
ask?
I ask a lot of questions.
I'm not supposed to ask.
Apparently, according to most of my
teachers.
Also my parents.
Actually, according to pretty much every
grown up hive wing.
Too many questions, cricket, don't you
know what happens to nosy little hive
wings, they lose those noses.
Which is silly.
I've never seen a dragonette without a
nose, and I'm sure I can't be the 1st one
with this many questions.
What's your name?
Oh, that's another question.
Sorry.
I'm Cricket.
Blue, he said.
I'm Blue.
You sure are, she said, and giggled.
Oh dear, I'm sorry.
I bet you've heard that one before.
He took a step closer to her. trying to
rearrange his understanding of what kind
of dragon she was.
A hive wing who helped silk wings.
That wasn't a thing.
Um, shouldn't you be all mind controlled
too?
She finished for him and hesitated.
Yes, I should be.
Every other hive wing is, I have no idea
why I'm not.
She flicked her wings and settled them
again with a little laugh.
I can't believe I've kept that secret for
6 years.
And the 1st dragon I'm telling is a
strange silkwing.
Katy did is going to be so mad.
Is that what happened to everyone?
Mind control?
You didn't know about that?
She said.
I mean, I suppose I didn't either until I
saw it happen the 1st time.
She doesn't do it very often, but Queen
Wasp can control every hive wing in the
tribe, one at a time, or just one hive, or
everyone at once if she wants to.
Whoa.
Blue said, reeling a little.
I know, she said.
Except you?
He said.
Except me.
Isn't that fascinating?
Her face lit up, like all 3 moons rising
at once.
I can't figure it out.
There's nothing in any of these books
about how she does it.
Is it genetic?
Am I some kind of mutation?
Or could it be something we eat?
But I ate everything.
And like, a lot of everything.
I'm always hungry.
It's so mysterious.
There is seriously nothing about me
that's different from all the other hive
wings.
Blue thought there was.
He'd never met another hive wing like
her.
First of all, willing to talk to a silk
wing as though they could be friends.
Second of all, looking at him as if he
was a real dragon.
Not a wingless curiosity or nuisance to
be stepped over.
That must be such a weird feeling, he
said.
Having someone take over your body like
that, making you say things and do things
you wouldn't say or do yourself.
Do you think they remember it afterward?
Are they in there feeling trapped?
While it's happening?
They do remember it, she said.
They remember pretty much everything.
My sister, Katie did, says it's not a
trapped feeling, though.
It's more like, suddenly you really want
to do exactly what everyone else is
doing.
There's no struggle.
She says it's kind of peaceful. having
someone else make all the decisions for
you for a bit.
Maybe.
Blue thought of the tiny dragonettes
attacking him and shivered.
Except then later you'd feel like
everything you did was still your
choice.
And you'd probably feel guilty about it
even though it wasn't really you at all.
She looked surprised.
And then her gaze drifted up the shelves
of books as she thought about what he'd
said.
That's true, she said. after a moment.
I don't actually know if it ever bothers
them.
I wonder how I can find out.
She flicked her tail thoughtfully, you
know, without getting my nose cut off.
I think, do you ever feel bad about what
Queen Wasp makes you do?
is definitely one of those questions I am
not supposed to ask.
Especially if you don't want anyone to
know that the mind control doesn't work
on you, he said.
Right.
Cricket fiddled with the earpiece of her
glasses.
Katie did is the only one who knows.
I'm worried Queen Wasp might be angry if
she found out.
So, I hide whenever it happens and hope
no one notices.
I won't tell anyone.
Blue promised.
She gave him a sweet, slightly sad smile
and it occurred to him that he might
never have a chance to tell anyone
anyway.
He felt a sharp prickle of pain under his
wristband.
So, what did you do?
She asked.
Why is the whole hive looking for you?
What kind of criminal enterprise have I
gotten myself involved in?
She kept smiling, but Blue noticed a
shiver tremble across her wings.
He guessed there was a part of her that
had suddenly realized she was alone with
a dragon who might be dangerous. him, of
all dragons, scaring a hive wing.
Nothing, he said quickly.
He looked up at her and put one talon on
the table palm open.
I promise, I am totally harmless.
The most harmless, thoroughly, utterly
completely incapable of harm doing.
Oh, she said.
She thought for a 2nd.
That is reassuring.
Thoroughly, utterly, completely
reassuring.
Except for how it's exactly what a
dangerous criminal would say.
Is it really?
He asked, wide-eyed.
Cricket laughed.
I don't know.
I guess I'll have to ask all my dangerous
criminal friends.
He liked the way her laugh made sun
colored scales ripple all down her long
neck.
His head was starting to feel strangely
woozy.
What would the least dangerous dragon in
the world say?
he asked.
Why would the least dangerous dragon in
the world be running away from hive wing
guards?
she countered.
What could he possibly have done that's
so terrible?
It made Queen Wasp bust out her mind
control powers?
The question hit blue like an entire hive
collapsing on his chest.
What did I do?
I've always been a good dragon.
Why is this happening to me?
Oh no, she said.
Slipping off the table and crouching
beside him as he folded to the floor.
Why did that make you look so sad?
What happened?
She unfolded her wings to shelter the
curve of his back.
I don't know, he said.
It was splendid having her wings over him
like being hugged by the sun, although
actually it would probably be terrible to
be hugged by the sun.
This was much cooler.
What was he talking about?
Oh, right.
The worst day ever.
One moment, it was a normal metamorphosis
day.
And then suddenly, Luna was on fire, and
Swordtail was attacking guards, and Io
was carrying me, and I don't even, I mean
I would never disobey a hive wing.
It all just happened so fast, and I was
so scared.
Where the book's blurrier from this angle
or were his eyes losing focus?
It's your metamorphosis day?
Cricket said.
She tipped her head at his wing buds, but
politely didn't touch them.
A polite hive wing.
How did she get so weird and perfect?
Are you sure?
They don't look ready yet.
She picked up one of his talons and
examined his wrist scales.
No, no, Blue said.
It's Luna's metamorphosis day, my
sister.
The one on fire, Cricket said.
Is she all right?
Why was she on fire?
Lightning?
I think I'd have noticed a lightning
striking the hive today.
How would fire even get into?
She stopped suddenly, staring at him with
her mouth open.
Did you get frozen?
He said in a panic.
Are you being mind controlled right now?
Your sister's a flame silk?
She whispered in her own voice.
A real one?
That's amazing.
It is.
You, you know about those?
He tried to get to his feet.
Discovered that his knees had chosen an
entirely different life goal, staggered a
little sideways, and fell into her.
Uh-oh, Cricket said, wrapping her wings
around him.
Let me see your wristband.
He could barely move his arm over to
where she could catch it.
She tugged on his wristband, trying to
slide a claw underneath it, but it was
heavy and snug.
Why is my?
He tried to say.
But apparently words were too hard.
Really?
It was just unreasonable to expect entire
word sentence groups arranged in order.
Shh, she said, helping him lie down on
his back.
Don't be scared, but there might be a
toxin in your wristband.
I read a study about the idea once, but I
didn't think they'd implemented it yet.
Did you feel anything?
Like a needle poking you, kind of?
I bet they rigged it to inject you if
they ever couldn't find you.
Why?
He mumbled.
He wanted to ask if it was going to kill
him.
He thought he should probably be worried
if he was about to die.
But it would be much easier to close his
eyes, wouldn't it?
And stop thinking about it.
It would be much easier to think about
how sparkly cricket's glasses were, and
how they made her face all interesting, as
though there were lots of unexpected
angles and layers to it, like a prism.
Prism.
Words were funny.
They are hoping you'll flop over
somewhere and be easy to catch.
She said, wiggling a folded piece of
paper between his wristband and his
scales.
Joke's on them, though, because you've
got me to hide you.
The paper caught on something hidden
tearing a little gash in his skin, and he
yelped with startled pain.
I'm sorry.
Cricket cupped his face in her talons and
caught his eyes with hers.
Like her gaze was amber, and he was safe
inside of it.
Don't conk out.
We might have to go back into the tunnels
if they start searching the school.
Can't.
Move.
He slurred.
I'm going to take off your wrist cuff, she
said.
Is that all right?
Blue, can you hear me?
Blink if that's all right with you.
No way.
He managed around his numb tongue.
I'll be in.
So much trouble.
Oh, beautiful dragon.
She said sympathetically.
Don't you know how much trouble you're
already in?
He closed his eyes.
Something wet was leaking out of them.
Apparently, the toxin had affected his
tear ducts, too.
Crickets scrambled up and disappeared
from his side.
He opened his eyes again, afraid that
she'd be gone completely.
But she was only across the library
carefully unscrewing one of the lamps
from the wall, with a dust rag wrapped
around her claws to protect them from the
heat.
Soon she had uncovered a small, glowing
glass ball from inside the globe of the
lamp.
It shone bright enough to make Blue's
eyes hurt.
She folded the cloth over the ball. and
carried it to the librarian's desk, where
she cleared away the books and papers
then set down a metal plate from a side
drawer.
Woom.
Blue mumbled.
Don't worry, I've done this before, she
said.
I mean, never anywhere quite so.
Flammable, but I'm sure it'll be fine.
She dug through the rest of the drawers
until she found something that looked
like a long, thin pair of tweezers.
Blue had seen tools like that before.
He'd even used them a few times, to
untangle particularly messy snarls of
silk.
Cricket took a deep breath, unwrapped the
ball, and caught it between the tweezers
setting it down on the metal plate.
She threw the rag into a far corner, still
holding the ball steady, and then picked
up a marble paperweight shaped like a
coiled python.
She moved so confidently and efficiently
that it didn't occur to Blue to be afraid
until the last moment, when she looked up
at the ceiling and whispered, Please help
me not set the library on fire, clear
sight.
He couldn't have stopped her anyway.
As she brought the pale grace snake
smashing down on the light ball.
Glass splintered across the desk, and a
powerful burnt metal smell filled the
air.
But cricket pounced forward with the
tweezers and lifted something up.
It looked like a filament of silk, as
long as one of Blue's claws, but a light
with fire from end to end.
That was the source of light in all the
lamps in the hive.
Flame silk.
How had he never known that before?
He'd never even wondered how the lamps
worked.
He'd assumed it was a hive wing skill.
If he'd had to guess, he would have
imagined that perhaps some of them could
create fire, like the dragons from the
old stories he'd once lived across the
sea.
Scarcely breathing.
Cricket eased across the room toward him
holding the flame silk thread in the
tweezers.
Could she really set the whole library on
fire?
With that little thing?
He wondered.
If so.
She's taking a big risk for me.
She crouched beside him, and lifted his
left arm gently in her free claws.
Don't move.
She said.
I mean, I know you can't, but really
don't.
With infinite caution.
She traced the flame silk across his
wrist cuff.
It seared a smoking black line in the
bronze, right across the W in Silkworm
Hall.
Hawker is going to kill me, Blue thought
deliriously.
When I get to the checkpoint, he's going
to make that very stern frowny face, and
tut, tut, and check his list, and grumble
about paperwork, and then stab me with
his spear thingy.
Cricket traced the line again, and then
again with a flame silk thread, burning
it a little deeper each time.
The smell of blacksmiths and melting
chains filled the room, swamping the
scent of old paper.
And then, a few careful passes later.
The metal gave way and fell off his wrist
brushing against his scales, and leaving
a small scorch mark that hurt like a
viper bite.
Blue bit back a whimper.
Oh, shoot, Cricket said.
She jumped up and ran back to the
librarian's desk. grabbed a small
watering can, and poured water from it
over his burn.
Then she dropped the flame silk thread
into the water that was left in the can.
A sizzling, hissing sound, and a cloud of
steam billowed out of the top of it.
Blue's arm felt like it was floating.
Like maybe it would drift right up to the
roof and bump around between the books on
the top shelves.
He felt untethered from the earth, a
feeling that was tangled up with how
close he was to cricket, and how she
maybe had superpowers.
Or at least the absolute very best brain
in the world.
Cricket laughed.
I don't know about that, she said.
And he realized that he must have said
something out loud.
My teacher seemed to think my brain is
terribly annoying.
I like it.
Blue said.
Everything still felt blurry, but his
mouth was working a little better, or at
least, words were coming out of it in
order.
Even though those words didn't seem to be
waiting for approval from the rest of
him.
He managed to sit up and smile at her.
It's my new favorite brain.
And then the world kind of tipped
sideways and went dark, and Blue slipped
quietly into the nothing.
Chapter 8.
Blue had the impression that he should
wake up.
That it might be a good idea, that the
reason it was a good idea, might have
something to do with how, wherever he was
sleeping, wasn't swaying in the breeze
the way it was supposed to.
This web hammock he'd fallen asleep in
was weirdly still and hard underneath
him.
And there was someone shaking his
shoulder, someone whose wings brushed his
face sometimes.
Mother?
Mother never smelled like books and
apples.
The way this dragon did.
Are you awake?
The dragon whispered, Blue, if you're not
could you be?
Please?
Now, ish?
Blue said.
Which was odd. because he'd been trying
to say, you bet, but apparently, was good
enough for the dragon with all the
questions, because she started trying to
nudge him up to his feet.
Oh, questions.
It's cricket.
What are you smiling about?
She said curiously.
I hope that's a good sign.
Do you think you could smile and stand up
at the same time?
I would love to let you sleep more, but I
think we really need to move.
She froze for a moment, with him leaning
heavily against her shoulder.
Now the library was coming into focus
around him.
The glow of the lamps, the rows and rows
of books, the sound of tramping talons
from the hallway outside.
Um, the what?
He pointed at the door in alarm and she
nodded.
That's why I woke you, she whispered.
Quick, into the tunnels.
She bundled him under the table and
through the trap door.
His arms felt all wobbly, and his tail
seemed to be entirely in the way, but he
somehow managed to crawl into the dark
space beyond.
He dragged himself forward so Cricket
could scrunch in behind him.
The glow from the library lamps vanished
as cricket pulled the trap door shut.
Blue started to retreat farther into the
shadows, but she caught his nearest talon
and put one claw to her mouth in warning
Blue froze.
And in that instant, he heard the library
door slam open.
Three sets of talons thundered in, shaking
the room, so that a couple of books
toppled off tall shelves, and a small
cloud of book dust wafted through the
cracks in the trap door.
He twisted his neck to peek over
Cricket's shoulder.
And the glimpses he could see as they
moved around.
The hive wing's eyes were blank white
pearls.
So the queen was still mind controlling
them.
He wondered how long he'd been
unconscious.
He wondered how long she could keep it
up.
He wondered if she planned to keep them
all as her zombies until she found him, no
matter how long that took.
And then his heart stopped in his chest
as he remembered the wrist cuff cricket
had burned off him.
He couldn't see it from his angle, but
wasn't it still lying out there on the
floor?
Wouldn't they see it and know immediately
that he'd been here?
But several agonizing moments passed, and
the searching dragons didn't cry out, or
roar for backup, or hiss in triumph.
They moved mechanically, soundlessly
through the room, checking every obvious
hiding spot.
One crouched down to look under the table
and Blue closed his eyes in fright, not
daring to breathe.
But the trap door must have looked like
part of the wall, because the hive wing
jet black, with flecks of red along his
ears, wings, and claws, only grunted and
moved on.
Cricket twitched suddenly, as if startled
and Blue realized he was leaning against
her side, their tails entangled, their
talons touching.
He had been too terrified to notice, and
he was afraid that pulling away would
make a noise the searchers might hear.
He checked her face, or what little of it
he could see in the tiny bars of light.
She had her gaze fixed on one of the hive
wings.
A yellow orange dragon freckled all over
with black spots, but he couldn't quite
interpret her expression.
Dismay, regret.
Anger?
What is she feeling?
He wondered.
Hiding from her own tribe, in the dark
with a stranger, risking her queen's
wrath to help a silk wing.
He wondered about the hive wings out
there too.
Their sweet family evening of slides and
seesaws and zebra meat snacks had
abruptly turned into a dragon hunt.
Everything they'd been planning to do
tonight had been ripped out from under
them.
They didn't even know where their own
dragonettes were because right now
finding glue was all they cared about.
The giggling little dragonettes had gone
from playing tag, to prowling the shadows
of the hive with snarling teeth, every
scale ready to attack.
How could they all go home after this?
Back to family dinners, and wing
aerodynamics homework, knowing that
someone could take over their minds and
change their whole lives at any moment.
The 3 hive wings touched their foreheads
with one talon, all at the same time, with
exact mirrored movements.
Nothing in the library.
They said in unison.
A ripple of fury crossed each of their
faces simultaneously.
It must be here somewhere.
Keep looking.
They marched out the door.
But Blue could hear their talon steps in
the corridor for a long time after they
were out of sight.
Cricket opened her mouth to say something
and this time he was the one to shush
her.
His antennae unfurled softly. feeling the
vibrations in the air.
Now that he was calmer and more awake, he
could sense at least 20 other dragons
searching the school.
He could also feel crickets heart
beating.
Very close to his, and almost as fast.
Don't be scared.
He tried to think to her.
There was no reason not to be.
If they were caught, he was sure she'd be
in awful trouble.
But he'd do everything he could to keep
her out of it.
He'd let them catch him first.
He reached out carefully through the dark
and took one of her talons, pressing it
to his own heart.
I'm so glad you're here with me.
She looked up at him.
Small cracks of light dappling her face
in gold and shadow, and he felt her pulse
jump to match his.
Oh.
This is the thing that's forbidden.
Blue realized, this feeling.
Looking at a hive wing like this.
Her looking back.
If they could be in more trouble than
they already were, This was how.
But maybe that wasn't what she was
feeling.
Maybe he was still woozy from the toxin
and confused by his life being upended.
Maybe he was just imagining the flutter
in their twining heartbeats.
His antennae twitched quietly, following
the vibrations of the dragons moving away
from this section of the school.
I think they've all gone upstairs, he
whispered.
Is there an upstairs?
Yes.
How can you tell where they are?
She whispered back.
Your antennae?
He nodded.
I found some old biology books that said
hive wings used to have antennae too, she
said softly.
But when I asked my science teacher about
it, he said not to be impertinent, and
then the books disappeared from the
library.
She sighed.
Everything interesting is off limits.
Why can't we study our own evolution?
Don't you want to know what the tribes
were like 2000 years ago when Clearsight
arrived?
I never thought about it, he admitted.
But she was right.
If hive wings were all descendants of
Clearsight.
What had they been like before she came
to Pantala?
They stayed there, quietly, in the dark
with their talons and tails entwined.
For a long time, the sounds of the search
tramped above them, around them, in and
out, and along the halls, and every room
of the enormous school.
Blue felt the jarring thumps of tables
being overturned, the rattling clatter of
closets being emptied, all their contents
clawed out and thrown on the floor.
He felt tremendously sorry for whoever
had to clean up all this tomorrow.
He guessed Queen Wasp wouldn't helpfully
brainwash them into doing that.
At last all the vibrations faded, and
Blue tested the air until he was sure the
school was empty again.
They're all gone, he whispered.
That's a pretty cool superpower, she
said.
Smiling at his antennae as they curled
back in.
Not quite as cool as knowing everything
about everything, he said.
She blanked.
Are you talking about me?
I hardly know anything.
There's so much, I don't know.
I mean, yet.
One day I will.
I hope.
I'm working on it.
She wrinkled her snout, as though the
existence of unanswered questions was one
of the greatest trials of her life.
Like, how Queen Wasps mind control
works?
I really want to know that.
Do you wish?
He hesitated, then plunged into his
question.
Do you wish you were like the other hive
wings?
If you could make yourself, um, mind
controllable.
Would you?
No, she said.
Her wings brushing his sides as they
flared out and hit the walls of the
tunnel.
Would you?
Who would?
No.
I'd fix it so it didn't work on anyone if
I could.
That's what you would do too, isn't it?
At the very least.
I'd fix Katy did.
Oh, he said.
Was that your sister?
The yellow one with the black spots you
were watching.
She exhaled.
Yes.
She is my sister and my best friend.
She normally looks much Kinder. than
that.
It must be awful.
Blue said, studying her face.
Seeing someone you love transformed, like
her brain and soul were stolen.
She looks like her, but she's not.
And you don't know what she might do, or
how she might treat you, but you know you
can't reach her.
Cricket tilted her head at him.
That's right.
She said.
That's exactly what it's like.
Katy did says it's fine and she doesn't
mind, since it happens so rarely.
But she can't see herself all creepy
eyed.
She doesn't know what it feels like for
me to have to hide from her.
She shivered slightly, and Blue realized
he was still holding her talon.
He let go of it reluctantly.
I hope you do find a way to save her, he
said.
And all of them.
I know the grunting one who checked under
the table too.
Cricket said quickly, as though she was
trying to change the subject so she
wouldn't cry.
His name's bomb the deer.
But he's awful.
So there's not much difference between
regular him and brain dead him.
He thinks I'm in love with him, if you've
ever wondered what the most enormous
arrogance looks like.
I guess I'd still save him, but maybe
like, last.
Why didn't they see my wrist cuff?
Blue asked, or the broken glass, and the
flame silk thread in the watering can?
I cleaned it all up, of course, she
said.
You didn't notice, and between your
snores?
I wasn't.
Did I?
I didn't.
Cricket laughed.
No, you're a very polite sleeper.
Don't worry.
She glanced out of the library again.
The only thing I couldn't do was replace
the missing light globe.
But those burn out or get stolen all the
time, so hopefully no one will connect it
to you.
So every white globe in the hive has a
bit of flame silk inside it.
He said tentatively.
Of course, she said.
Every light globe in every hive.
It would be tough to live the way we do
without flame silk.
We'd all be bumping around in the dark
treading on everyone's claws.
Plus, we need it for everything else
that's made with fire.
Metalwork, glass.
She touched her spectacles self
consciously.
Do all the hive wings know about flame
silks?
he asked.
Because I'd never heard of them until
today.
I think they know the queen has a source
of flame silk.
She said thoughtfully.
But most of them probably don't think
about where it comes from very much.
It's just something you order when you
need it.
Blue opened and closed his mouth on his
next question.
He remembered the eerie golden lava
erupting from Luna's wrists and weaving
around her scales.
Her silk was a, A commodity to the hive
wings, something to be ordered, and
bought, and sold and used.
If your sister's a flame silk, Cricket
said, reaching for his wrist.
Does that mean you're going to be a flame
silk too?
She traced one claw over the spot where
his silk would come out, and he
shivered.
I don't know, he said.
I who said I would be, but we weren't
taught anything about flame silks at
Silkworm Hall.
But that must be why they're chasing you
right, she said.
Queen Wasp would never let a flame soak
wander around her hives unguarded.
I've never been guarded before, he said.
I've never done anything wrong.
I'm really good at following the rules.
She doesn't have to worry about me.
He frowned.
Touching the spot on his forehead that
was starting to hurt.
Maybe she just doesn't know that.
Maybe I could go to her and explain that
I'm a loyal silk wing.
Maybe if I promise I'll be careful.
She'll let me go back to my normal life.
And Luna too.
Luna isn't dangerous.
Cricket hesitated.
I think...
I think hive wing policy is that all free
flame silks are dangerous, no matter what
they say.
She unlatched the trap door and crawled
back into the library.
Blue followed her as she pulled a book
off one of the high shelves, fluttering
her wings a little to lift herself up to
where she could reach it.
She flipped through the pages, then
flitted under his nose.
Scarlet colors leaped off the page
assaulting his eyeballs.
The picture was of a hive on fire, burning
from top to bottom, with screaming hive
wing faces dimly visible through the
smoke.
At the top, huge dark letters proclaimed
the consequences of unchained flame
silks.
Yikes, he said.
I guess that's supposed to be you.
She said, pointing to a silk wing
standing in the middle of the burning
hive, with fire pouring out of his
wrists.
The illustrated dragon had a gleeful
unhinged grin on his face as he torched
the city.
Blue shuddered.
I would never, he said.
Why would anyone ever?
That's just horrible.
Cricket tugged the book back over to her
and turned to the next page, studying the
words.
Her eyes darted so quickly across the
text that Blue couldn't believe she was
actually absorbing any of it until she
said, okay, here.
Flame silk genetics.
A dragonette with one flame silk parent
has a 50% chance of being a flame silk
2.
So we know Luna is, but you might, or
might not be.
She looked over the top of her glasses at
him.
Do you think you are?
Do your wrists ever feel like they're
burning?
What symptoms did Luna have?
She didn't have any, Blue said.
I mean, not until today, when her silk
started coming in all arr, now there's
lava everywhere.
She's been totally normal before now.
So there's no way to know if you are or
not until your metamorphosis day, Cricket
said.
Hmm.
They must want to keep you locked up
until then anyway, in case you try to run
away.
My friend IO's the one who made me run
It wouldn't have occurred to me to run.
Blue pointed out, at least, not until
they started chasing me.
What's the chrysalis?
Cricket asked.
The what?
When we 1st met in the shed.
You asked if I was with the chrysalis.
Blue felt a twist of guilt in his chest.
He was pretty sure that whatever the
chrysalis was, hive wings weren't
supposed to know about it.
Even smart, sympathetic hive wings with
interesting glasses.
Io would be furious if she found out he'd
blurted it out to the 1st dragon he met.
Cricket was studying him curiously.
Is it a secret?
She said.
A silkwing secret?
Do you guys have lots of secrets from
us?
Can you tell me some of them?
I promise not to tell anyone.
There's so much I don't know about silk
wings, but father won't let me ask the
servants anything.
I don't really know what it is.
He admitted, trying to stem the tide of
questions.
My friend just told me they'd help me if
I could find them.
But I have no idea how to do that.
He slid the flame silk book over and
studied it himself, hoping he hadn't hurt
cricket's feelings.
So, if Flame Silk is so useful, then
Queen Wasp probably isn't killing them
right?
Of course she isn't.
Cricket said, startled.
We are not barbarians, Blue.
The queen's a little scary, but she's not
a murderer.
Blue would have said the same thing
himself this morning.
But something about watching those guards
surround Luna, and then hiding from white
eyed mind controlled dragons, was making
him a little less certain about the
queen's trustworthiness.
Do you think I should turn myself in?
He asked hesitantly.
That sounded like the right thing to do
except that it felt very, very wrong.
Io's warning that he couldn't trust any
hive wings rang in his ears.
And here I am, of course, doing exactly
that.
Cricket thought for a moment, tapping her
claws on the book.
No, she said finally, slowly.
They won't kill you.
But if you are a flame silk, they'll, Well
you'll end up with the other flame silks
I guess.
Where is that?
He said, with a sudden rush of hope.
That's where Luna will be.
Oh, I'm sorry I made you look so excited
Cricket said anxiously.
Nobody knows where the flame silks are
kept.
Are you sure?
Blue asked. someone must know.
You're right, she said, leaping to her
feet.
Let's think.
Flame silk orders go out all the time
because each thread only burns for about
one cycle of the smallest moon before it
fades, which means someone has to get the
flame silk from the dragons producing it
to fill the orders.
So whose job is it?
And someone must keep them fed and taken
care of.
And guarded, Blue put in.
She flinched.
Yes, probably that too.
She started pacing up and down between
the library tables.
And of course, Queen Wasp knows.
So there must be a way to trace the flame
silk back to wherever the dragons are.
This is definitely a solvable mystery.
Cricket hurried over to the librarian's
desk and opened one of the bottom
drawers.
All right, forms, where are you?
She's always complaining about how many
there are to fill out.
Order forms?
Replacing library supplies.
You would think a librarian would be all
about alphabetizing her folders, wouldn't
you?
Do you think she noticed if I
alphabetized them for her?
Oh, light globes, here.
She pulled out a sheaf of papers and
narrowed her eyes at them.
Blue glanced at one of the lamps.
It was weird to think that there was a
tiny thread of silk in there, glowing and
burning.
It was even weirder to think that the
thread had come from a dragon very much
like him.
Or Luna.
A dragon trapped somewhere, spilling
flame from her arms for hive wings to
gather and snip into little useful bits
that could be packaged and sold across
the continent.
A dragon whose whole life would be about
producing flame silk for hive wings, and
nothing else.
Maybe it came from my father.
The thought dazed him for a moment.
His father was a flame silk, kept under
guard wherever other flame silks were
kept.
That's why Blue had never met him.
He'd only been brought out for a moment
to father more dragons.
In the hopes of creating more flame silks
Blue guessed.
Which meant Queen Wasp knew exactly what
Luna and Blue might become.
She'd created them on purpose for that
purpose.
Hmm.
Cricket said.
It looks like the order forms get sent to
a department in Wasp Hive.
So maybe the flame silks are there.
Or maybe that department forwards it on.
If we can figure out where they are, Blue
said.
Maybe I could go see what it's like.
Maybe it's not so terrible.
Maybe that would help me decide whether I
should turn myself in.
Cricket tipped her head up at him.
And if it is terrible, she asked.
Would you want to rescue your sister?
I. Yes, he admitted.
Of course, that was what he was really
thinking, and of course, cricket had
figured that out.
But I'm not exactly the right dragon for
that job.
Why not?
Well, I mean, he waved vaguely at
himself.
I'm not very.
I don't like making trouble.
Troublemakers.
I need sword tail, he blurted.
He's the one who should rescue her.
All right.
Cricket said, whisking the forms back
into the drawer.
She smiled brightly a blue.
Then let's go get him.
Chapter 9.
It's not that simple.
Blue argued.
Following cricket into the dim hallway
beyond the library.
Swartail attacked a bunch of hive wing
guards.
He's either on misbehavior's way, or
somewhere worse by now.
And I can't exactly stroll around the
hive with everyone looking for me.
I bet I can solve that problem.
Cricket said.
Let's think.
Both problems maybe?
Will you let me try?
Um, sure.
Blue said, distracted by the school
around him.
Rows of cubby holes lined the corridor.
Many of them overflowing with crumpled
papers, books, sticky bags of half eaten
nectar snacks, seed packets, and little
buckets of dirt.
Every few steps, there was a glass
terrarium embedded in the wall, with
something growing in it, tidy clusters of
blue forget me nots in one, long white
carrots in another, prickly cactus balls
bristling in an orderly row from a
third.
Whoa.
Blue said.
It's so Planty in here.
We're an agriculture track school.
Do Silk Wings have those?
Cricket said.
They passed one glass case that was full
of water, crowded with dark flaps of
purple seaweed.
Blue squinted at it, and realized that it
was lit by a small light globe on the
roof of the terrarium.
They all were.
Tiny flame silk suns kept these plants
alive.
Maybe, Blue said.
But I think they usually figure out which
job to assign us after we finish school.
Our lessons are things like the history
of the leaf wing war. silk weaving
reading, web structure, and following
directions.
Lots of following directions.
I wish I could go to your school for a
day.
Cricket said, her wings twitching, as
though she might fly out one of the
skylights at any moment.
I'd love to hear what other dragons are
learning, wouldn't you?
Are your teachers interesting?
How big is your library?
Do you have music classes?
I wish we did.
I don't understand music at all, and I
really want to.
But our curriculum is very focused so we
can all become farmers and gardeners.
That's what this is all about.
She waved her claws at the corridor
walls.
Every student is assigned a terrarium for
practice.
Oh, Blue said.
You don't seem like a farmer to me.
I'd be an awesome farmer.
If I wanted to be, she said, which I
don't.
I want to be a librarian, or a scientist
or an inventor.
But I'm a terrible farming student.
Apparently there's only one way to do
things, and that's how it's always been
done, and there's no point in trying to
innovate cricket.
It's a waste of seeds.
And oh dear, why can't you just grow
potatoes like a useful dragon?
She paused at one of the terrariums and
tapped it lightly with her claw.
This is mine.
Blue was pretty sure he could have
guessed that on his own.
Unlike the other orderly terrariums.
This box was a riot of leaves and color.
As though a host of sunflowers had thrown
a gala, and some marauding butterflies
had crashed it.
Velvety orange petals jostled for space
with elegant trailing spider plants.
Sapphire blue bulbs peeked out from
behind heart shaped leaves with pink
edges.
It's like your brain, as a garden, Blue
said wonderingly.
Cricket laughed.
And equally popular with my teachers, she
said.
Cricket.
What a disaster.
Why didn't you use one type of C like all
the other students?
Why must everything you touch be such a
mess?
Blue stepped closer and peered through
the tangle of foliage.
Deep in the heart of her terrarium.
Well hidden by the other plants, there
was a tiny tree.
It was no taller than the length of 2
claws, but it had a trunk, and miniature
branches, and little perfect tufts of
forest green needles all over it.
It was beautiful.
That, he breathed.
That's a real, how did you?
I found the seed on one of our gathering
field trips.
I had no idea what it was until it
started to grow.
She smiled at it wistfully.
I had a feeling you'd see it.
Most dragons don't.
I think my terrarium is too messy to look
at for very long.
It offends their eyes or something.
But my botany teacher finally spotted it
last week.
He wants me to uproot it and throw it
away.
She sighed.
Poor little innocent tree.
She turned and kept walking, and Blue
followed her.
Although he wished he could stay and
stare at the tree a bit longer.
He couldn't believe it was real.
Surely Cricket loved it.
It looked like a loved little tree.
That's so sad, he said.
What an awful thing to ask you to do.
You brought it to life.
I'm not going to let my tree die, she
said firmly.
But where can I hide it?
Somewhere with light, where I can visit
but no one will find it.
I'll figure something out.
She pushed open a door at the end of the
hall.
Revealing a room with long desks covered
in glass beakers and small pots of soil.
A metal cabinet at the back of the room
was lit by a tiny globe inside, and the
shelves were lined with neatly labeled
bottles of liquid, organized by color.
The top shelf ranged from a bright ruby
red to a pale pink.
The 2 middle shelves were shades of lemon
and emerald and lime, and the bottom
shelf held a few milky white bottles, and
several with nearly colorless liquids in
them.
Blue crouched to look at one of them, and
realized it was slightly aquamarine when
the light hit it in a certain way.
He didn't understand any of the labels
printed on the bottles.
There were letters and numbers, and some
obscure squiggles symbols in between, but
none of them formed recognizable words.
This is our chemistry lab.
Cricket said.
We use some of these to help plants
grow.
Others will kill certain weeds if you
apply them the right way.
But a lot of these have other non
botanical uses too.
How many do you think I can take without
Professor Earthworm noticing?
Take, Blue said, startled, you can't
steal from your school.
She paused with a vial, the color of
chamomile tea in her claws.
But, Blue, these will help us.
Don't you want to get your friend?
Yes, but.
But stealing is wrong, he stammered.
He imagined the chemistry teacher coming
in tomorrow morning and finding bottles
missing.
Wouldn't she be upset?
Wouldn't she feel guilty and worried
about who had taken them, and what might
be done with them?
She might blame her students.
Someone might get in trouble unfairly.
You really are good at following the
rules, aren't you?
Cricket said, intrigued.
Like, you really believe in them.
Don't you?
he said.
Doesn't everyone?
She thought about that for a moment.
He liked the way she stopped and thought
carefully about the things he said.
Most dragons already had their ideas
settled in their heads.
If they paused to think before responding
it was only about how to explain to you
that you were wrong.
But cricket seemed to take in information
and questions, and hold them up against
the things she thought she knew, to see
if there was anything new she'd missed.
Weird, she said finally.
I usually think of rules as things that
get in the way of all the stuff I really
want to know.
I mean, how can don't ask questions, ever
be a good rule, or only borrow one book
at a time from the library.
That's just ludicrous.
No one ever explains rules like that in a
sensible way.
But don't hurt other dragons.
That's a rule I think everyone believes
in. right?
So, I guess I believe in some rules, and
I think rules in general can be useful.
But I also think it's all right to stop
and question some of the rules sometimes
if they feel wrong to you.
Doesn't that make sense?
But don't steal is a rule everyone agrees
on too, isn't it?
he asked.
I think that help dragons who need help
might be more important than don't steal
Cricket said.
I mean, turn over fugitives to Queen Wasp
when she is looking for them, is probably
a rule too, you know?
But I don't think you're dangerous.
And I want to know more about flame silks
and silk wings, and I think I can help
you.
I'd, I'd like to help you.
Blue looked back at the citrus colored
vials.
He didn't want to drag her into more
danger than he'd already put her in, but
he did need help.
And more important, Soartail and Luna
needed help.
This isn't their 1st rule line breaking
he thought.
The 1st rule I broke was running, even
after the guards told me to stop.
He still felt shaken all the way through
his scales at the memory of disobeying
hive wing orders.
But if I'm going to rescue Luna, Or, at
least, get Swordtail to rescue Luna.
Then this won't be the last rule I break
either.
You're right, he said.
Oh, my goodness, she said, looking
genuinely startled.
No one has ever said that to me.
Then the dragons you know, haven't been
listening to you very well, he said.
I bet you're right about almost
everything.
Ooh.
The perfect title for my memoir, she said
grinning.
Write about almost everything.
Bye cricket.
He laughed, letting her smile chase away
his nerves.
She carefully selected 6 vials from the
back rows, rolled them in a thick black
cloth, and tucked them into a bag she
tied sideways across her chest.
One more stop.
She said.
They hurried through the school again.
Blue unfurled his antennae at each corner
but he couldn't sense any other dragons
anywhere in the building.
The hunt for him had moved on.
Or maybe paused for the night, he hoped
without much optimism.
The next room cricket took him into was
huge and abutted the side of the hive
because there was an enormous glass
window all along one side of it.
Outside, it was very dark, with only
fragments of the savannah grass shifting
silver in bits of moonlight.
The 3 moons and most of the stars were
hidden by thick clouds.
After a few moments of blinking around
Blue realized this was the art room he
had glanced briefly through the cracks in
the tunnels.
Here was the easel with its perfectly
perpendicular lines of blue and black.
In fact, there was an entire row of
easels with exactly the same painting on
each one.
Blue wasn't sure it was a painting.
It seemed more like a plan for a
gardening plot.
In another corner of the room.
A long table was lined with large sheets
of paper, each one with a nearly exact
replica of an orange painted in the
center.
The orange that had merited all this
attention, was still posed nonchalantly
on a stool in front of the table.
Blue looked around.
But none of the artwork looked like
cricket's glorious terrarium.
Where's yours?
he asked.
Oh, I'm not allowed to take art classes
anymore, Cricket said.
With a kind of carelessness, he was
pretty sure she was faking.
You can probably guess why.
Good heavens, cricket, he said, putting
on the voice she'd used several times
already.
No one has ever used that many colors on
one piece of paper before.
Look at this mess.
Why can't you just draw a normal blue
blueberry like every other dragon?
She laughed so much, he had to catch her
before she fell into one of the easels.
Were you there?
She gasped, wiping tears from her eyes.
That's exactly what principal lovers
sounded like.
I bet your art was beautiful, he said.
A beautiful pile of shredded scraps when
she was done with it, she said with a
half shrug.
I had dreams for a while.
That bee eaters and weaver birds found
the pieces, and tucked them into their
nests all across the grasslands.
She wrestled another cabinet open.
This time revealing rows of color coded
paint pots and drawers of the cleanest
paintbrushes Blue had ever seen, most of
them as thin as his antennae.
Um, he said, as she started selecting
brushes and paint.
Do I want to know what's happening?
We are going to disguise you?
She said with delight.
What color have you always wanted to be?
I mean, I think your scales are perfect.
But like you said, you can't wonder the
hive looking like yourself, can you?
That's a purple anyone would spot from
the next hive over.
For a moment, I thought it would be so
cool to disguise you as a hive wing.
But then I was like, silly cricket.
That won't work.
There are no wingless hive wings.
So what do you think?
Orange?
Our cook is mostly orange.
You're going to paint me?
Blue said.
Or you could paint yourself, but I think
I better do it, unless you're good at
it.
Are you?
I have no idea, he said.
I've never painted a dragon before.
Me neither, she confessed.
But I think it'll work if we use the
right paint.
Do you mind?
Can I try?
You think?
He echoed nervously.
Maybe a darker color.
To be sure it'll cover yours, she said.
Are there any sort of darkish silk
wings?
Swore tail has mostly dark blue scales
Blue said.
I've seen dark greens and reds and all
shades of brown.
Cricket pulled out a range of chocolate
maroon and navy paints.
All right, she said, herding him onto a
drop cloth that covered part of the
floor.
Stay really still.
Blue closed his eyes and froze.
I'm putting myself in her talons, he
thought.
I really, really hope she knows what
she's doing.
Because if she doesn't, and someone
recognizes me, and we get caught.
We're both going to be in worse trouble
than I can imagine.
Chapter 10.
I don't see how this could work.
Blue protested.
As cricket dipped a brush and to paint
the color of the sea during a storm.
Won't I just look like a silk wing with
paint all over me?
Not unless they look closely, and no one
looks closely at Silk Wings.
She started dabbing paint lightly across
the purple scales on his back.
It felt like salamanders prowling over
him, tiny wet toes sliding along each
individual scale.
It felt like purrs and whispers, and
ferns full of dewdrops trailing along his
nerves.
Cricket switched to a sponge to smooth
out the paint, then to another brush for
a different color.
She hesitated, lightly touching his
shoulder.
I'm going to paint around your wing buds
but I won't touch them, all right?
He nodded.
It was hypnotizing, the gentle brushing
touch sweeping over him.
He felt half bewitched, as though the
toxin from his wristband might still be
running through his veins.
Cricket.
Why are you helping me?
He asked.
Her talent stilled for a moment, then
kept going.
I don't know.
Maybe because I know what it's like to
hide while everyone is mind controlled.
And because I've never met a flame silk
and I'd love to know more about you.
And because you're, She paused, struggling
for a word.
Pathetic, he offered, desperate, a tragic
story.
No, she said.
Not that at all.
You're... she trailed off again.
Ah, ha, he said, devastatingly handsome.
She laughed and poked his neck with the
other end of the paintbrush.
Stop it.
You mustn't make me laugh while I'm
wielding paint at you.
He smelled cinnamon as she leaned in to
paint around his ears.
After a moment, she said, I mean, you're
not, not.
But what I was trying to say is
interesting.
You're interesting.
And I usually spend all day with dragons
like bombardier and earthworm, who are
definitely not interesting.
Huh.
He said.
She wants to study me.
He caught himself thinking.
I'm one of the forbidden library books
come to life.
That's all.
A chance for her to learn more about my
tribe in Flame Silk.
It's not really about me.
Which is better?
Safer, for both of us.
He sighed and closed his eyes.
He imagined a 1000 moths weaving a web of
silk around him, shrouding him in a 2nd
skin.
The paint felt like tiny beetle shells as
it dried, glossy and thin and hard.
After a while, Cricket said, hmm, what do
you think?
Blue half expected to see something like
her terrarium when he opened his eyes.
He was a little afraid he'd look like a
rose garden on fire.
But the dragon looking back at him from
the cabinet mirror, was a nondescript
silk wing in dark blues and the browns of
dead leaves, with touches of deep red
barely visible along his spine and
snout.
There were a few blobby spots around his
claws, and his brighter blue peeked
through here and there.
But for the most part, the paint was
even.
He looked like a dragon no one would
glance at twice.
He blinked.
Wow.
Thank you, cricket.
It's not perfect.
But hopefully, it'll at least get you out
of the hive, she said apologetically.
Especially if everyone is still looking
for you.
Out of the hive, he thought with a
shiver.
He'd never gone any farther than the webs
around cicada hive.
Unlike Luna, he'd never even wanted to.
I guess I'm ready to go find sword tail
he said uncertainly.
He'd never walked the streets of the hive
alone at night before.
He always went home to the webs before
dark.
Burnet and silver spot must be so worried
about him.
Which made him think.
Cricket, don't you have to go home?
She glanced out at the dark savannah, and
the twinkling lights of other hives in
the distance.
I doubt my father will notice one way or
another.
Katie did well, but she knows I sometimes
hide for a while after Queen Wasp takes
over everyone.
I get nervous that it'll happen again
right away.
And it's hard to be around dragons.
Even Katie did, after seeing that.
She started cleaning away the paints and
brushes.
Blue moved to help her, but she stopped
him.
Now, stay still until you're completely
dry.
Anyway, she's the only one who cares
where I am, and she'll cover for me.
For how long?
He wondered.
How far would Cricket's curiosity take
her before she decided to leave him to
his fate, all the way to Wasp Hive, to
Luna?
Did he dare hope for that much?
Where do you think Sortell is?
Cricket asked.
Tucking the last pot of blue paint into
place?
Blue noticed that she'd put 2 of the pots
in the wrong order?
One was darker than the other, so it
should come later in the line, and
reached past her to switch them.
My only guess is misbehaviors way.
Blue said.
He doesn't like being told what to do, so
he's been there before.
But I'm afraid.
I mean, he's never actually attacked a
hive wing like he did today.
He felt a fizzing twist of anxiety in his
stomach.
What would the hive wings do with sword
tail if they decided he was really
dangerous?
It's still the 1st stop.
Even if he'll be moved to prison after
that, cricket said.
So that's probably where he is.
I've never been to Misbehavior's way.
She leaned forward and lightly tested the
paint on his snout.
Although father is always saying that's
what my teachers should do with me.
Like, we all know it's inevitable, just
sticker there now, that kind of thing.
You've never, haven't you at least walked
along it?
He asked.
He was flummoxed when she shook her
head.
But, really?
It's only a couple levels up from here.
My school has 2 field trips there every
year.
Field trips?
Cricket echoed, fluttering her wings
back.
What for?
What can they possibly teach you there?
Isn't it kind of scary for little
dragonettes?
She glanced around, making sure all
traces of their activity were gone, and
started for the door.
Yes, he said fervently.
I found it terrifying every time.
I still do.
That's um, kind of the point, I think.
His scales felt crackly and strange as he
walked behind her, but kind of cool too
like wearing a mask fitted exactly to his
face.
Oh, she said.
So it's to teach you to follow the
rules.
Poor little silkwing dragonettes.
Do all your schools do that?
I think so.
Do they spend a lot of time scaring you?
she asked.
Like, on purpose?
He shrugged.
It was hard for him to concentrate on
their conversation, because they had
reached the front door of the school.
Through the narrow windows on either
side.
He could see slivers of the prehistoric
shapes of the playground structures
outside, the ones that he'd last seen
swarming with dragons trying to attack
him.
Now it looked deserted, like the bones of
a whale graveyard at the bottom of the
sea.
Cricket stopped and peered out, pressing
her face to the window so she could see
as far in each direction as possible.
I don't see anyone, she whispered.
She hesitated.
Her tail flicking back and forth
uncertainly as she stared out at the
playground.
Blue's heart was beating like a trapped
insect, throwing itself at the glass
walls of its prison.
But he had a sudden bolt of
understanding.
She felt the same way.
Cricket had never gone outside while the
mind control was happening.
She was as scared as he was.
I'll go first, he whispered.
Really?
She glanced at him, her eyes darting
worriedly over his painted scales.
But, don't worry, I have my awesome
disguise, remember?
He said.
If the high wings are still under Queen
Wasps control.
They'll notice that you're not right
away.
But with luck, they won't notice a random
silk wing wandering the park, I'll
signal.
Once I know if it's safe for you to come
out or not.
She hesitated again before nodding.
He took a deep breath, pushed open the
heavy door, and slipped down the stairs.
Chapter 11.
Blue walked cautiously through the park
glancing around for dragons, but seeing
no one.
He made his way to the ledge and looked
out of the cloud covered moons and
rustling savannah.
What had happened to IO?
Did she get away?
But there were no signs, no clues.
Nothing in the quiet around him indicated
that a massive dragon hunt had started
here earlier that evening.
He ducked his head and started back
toward the school.
Halfway there, he saw a dragon hurrying
out of his side street, half in shadows.
The stranger picked up a toy that had
been left on one of the structures and
paused, squinting at Blue.
You'd better get back where you belong, he
called in a sharp voice.
The hunting parties will be leaving at
dawn tomorrow.
Yes, sir.
Blue said.
Trying to walk like he had a destination
and study the dragon at the same time.
The stranger grumbled something and left
and in the glow of the street lights, blue
caught a glimpse of black stripes across
his back.
A hive wing, one with his own eyes and
his own mind.
The queen had released her tribe for
now.
Blue waited until the hive wing was out
of sight, then beckoned to cricket.
She slipped out of the school, and
together, they hurried down one of the
deserted streets toward the outer spiral
inside a few of the houses, blue saw
lights glowing or moving around.
He wondered how long ago the queen had
let them go.
He wondered how long it had taken all the
families to reunite, and how they were
all feeling.
Were any of them resentful of the queen?
Or did they blame him for disrupting
their evening instead?
Or perhaps they all felt as if they'd
been useful and important helpers in the
search for a dangerous criminal.
Me, a dangerous criminal.
When all I've ever wanted is to stay out
of trouble.
Wait.
That hive wing, Blue said softly.
He said something about hunting parties
leaving at dawn.
To look for you?
Cricket asked.
Uh-oh.
That means we need to move fast if we
want to get a head start on them.
Their guards slumped at the entrance to
the spiral.
But their eyes glanced over Blue's muted
colors, noted the haughty tilt to
cricket's snout, and slanted away
uninterested.
Cricket went 1st and Blue followed.
Keeping his head low, acting the part of
a humble servant, following his
mistress's midnight whim for a stroll.
She paused a few levels up and glanced
back at him.
He nodded, through there.
This was one of the only levels with a
gate, although it wasn't locked.
There was no risk of anyone escaping
after all.
Blue suspected the gate was there, so
high wings wouldn't have to accidentally
see the prisoners on their way between
levels.
Cricket pushed open the gate, and they
emerged onto a path that was roughly
cobbled with chunks of sharp stones.
She winced as one stabbed her feet, then
looked up at the columns that lined the
walkway.
Normally, Blue came here in a crowd of
other dragons, young silk wings all wide
eyed and hushed with terror.
He always tried to stay near the back, so
he wouldn't have to look at the prisoners
too closely.
But they were impossible to miss.
Mounted on stone pedestals for all the
world to stare at, looming over the heads
of the visiting students.
The stony path wound all around the level
in and out, and over roughly shaped hills
until it connected back with itself at
the beginning again.
In between the prisoner pedestals, were
engraved tablets listing the rules of the
hives, the consequences for breaking them
odes to the greatness of Queen Wasp, and
quotes from historical figures about
obedience, safety, and community.
Some of the quotes were from Clearsight
herself.
Blue had always liked that she sounded
like she cared about the rules as much as
he did.
Above each prisoner hung a small
spotlight, and on each pedestal, there
was always a list posted of that
prisoner's crimes described in dramatic
detail.
Tonight, the 1st few pedestals on
misbehavior's way were empty.
But as they walked the path, they saw
figures on the ones up ahead.
Cricket gave a start, jumping back to
crash into blue, when she noticed the 1st
one a few paces away.
Sorry, she whispered.
Is that, is it real?
A real dragon, I mean?
Or is it a statue?
But I can hear it breathing.
Can't I?
That's a dragon.
Blue confirmed.
A silk wing, but not sword tail.
The colors were all wrong, mostly white
and brown, with flecks of green.
She watched the immobile prisoner for a
long, wary moment.
It's not moving at all.
She can't.
Blue pointed out. of them can move.
They drew closer to the occupied
pedestals and looked up at the trapped
criminals.
Misbehavior's way had no need for cages
or chains.
Instead, Queen Wasp used an elite unit of
high wing soldiers, all recruited to the
job because they had a nerve poison in
their claws or tail stinger. once the
criminal, or misbehavior, was stabbed.
That dragon wouldn't be able to move for
an entire day.
I read about this, Cricket said.
Shifting her wings uncomfortably.
But it's not what I pictured.
Blue kept walking.
He could see the colors of the prisoners
with a glance.
But it was hard to avoid getting caught
by their expressions.
So many of their faces were frozen in
erectus of rage or fear.
Most of them had been paralyzed while
trying to run or fight.
So they were contorted in odd positions
stuck there until the toxin wore off.
They passed a pale pink silk wing with
long rose petal wings, his talons
outstretched, as though he'd been
pleading for mercy.
His snout still wet with tears.
They passed a snarling, scarlet hive wing
in a defensive crouch, teeth bared.
Another silk wing and shade of turquoise
and tan looked as though she'd been
trying to leap into flight when she was
caught.
Her neck strained hopelessly toward the
ceiling.
Her wings were in an awkward, half open
position.
That would probably feel awfully sore
when they could move again.
I thought they'd be asleep.
Cricket said in a small voice.
I thought the toxin knocked them out, like
putting them in a temporary coma.
She glanced up at the next frozen dragon
and flinched away.
But these dragons, Are they awake in
there?
So they can see everyone watching them?
Do you think it hurts?
It does, Blue said.
Swordtail says, getting stabbed feels
like fire burning every nerve in your
body.
Eventually the pain fades, but you're
still paralyzed.
So all you want to do is run or fly, or
even blink, but you can't move a single
muscle until the toxin wears off.
Everything about misbehaviors away
featured in his recurring nightmares.
I didn't know, she said.
I can't believe this was right here and I
had no idea.
I'm a terrible dragon.
I don't think so, Blue said.
He inhaled sharply as they rounded a bend
in the path.
There, that sword tail.
He darted forward.
Skidding to a stop at the base of Sword
Tails column.
Swordtail's paralyzed wings were spread
wide.
His tail frozen as it lashed back and
forth.
One of his front talons was outstretched
the claws curved as though he was about
to slash someone's face.
It was a little scary, honestly, seeing
his friend on the attack like that.
Sortell's expression was determined and
desperate.
As though this was his very last chance
to save the world.
Hey, Blue said softly up at him.
Sortail couldn't react, but Blue knew he
could still hear.
It's me, Blue.
This is cricket.
We're going to What are we going to do?
He asked Cricket.
Pick him up and carry him out of here?
She wrinkled or snouted at him.
A glimmer of her cheerful side sneaking
through for the 1st time since they'd
stepped onto misbehavior's way.
I'm sure that would be very
inconspicuous.
She crouched on the cobblestones, took
off her bag and unrolled the pouch of
vials.
They gleamed like raindrops on flower
petals and the light shining from above.
I don't know if this will work. she said
pushing her glasses higher on her snout.
I thought we needed to wake him up, but
maybe this one would be better.
Cricket selected a liquid, the color of
grass. and gave blue a wry, nervous
look.
At least, we use this to save plants that
have been poisoned.
On plants?
he said.
Is it safe for dragons?
I think so?
She said.
Have I ever tried it on a dragon?
Not exactly.
But it shouldn't make things worse
anyway.
This was not the most comforting answer.
Blue looked up at SwordTail, wishing his
friend could give him some sort of sign.
Was Swortail willing to risk a mysterious
unproven, possible antidote from a
strange hive wing?
Or would he rather be left alone?
Who am I kidding?
Sortell would risk anything to save
Luna?
I'm the one who would find it too scary.
Do you want me to try it on him?
Cricket said.
I understand if you don't.
I do, Blue said.
I think we have to.
He glanced back along the deserted path.
He had a feeling that everyone in the
hive was at home, recovering from the
Queen's mind control earlier, and that
was why they'd seen so few dragons out.
But he was also afraid that WASP might
seize control of them again at any
moment.
He couldn't imagine trying to fight his
way out of the hive alongside cricket.
But with sword tail, they might stand a
chance.
And Sordail would be able to rescue
Luna.
He was strong and brave, and not afraid
of hive wing soldiers.
All right, Cricket said.
How am I going to do this?
Let's think.
She poked through the vials and drew out
the tweezers she'd used on the flame silk
in the library.
Blue hadn't even noticed that she'd
brought them along.
Find me a big rock, she said to Blue.
That wasn't too hard here.
Blue found a loose cobblestone and kicked
it until he could wobble it free.
He brought it to cricket, and she beat
her wings once, twice, 3 times, just
enough to lift her up to the light over
Swordtail's head.
Here she hesitated, glancing down.
Can you cover his eyes for me?
She asked Blue.
And keep yours closed too.
Blue climbed up to balance awkwardly on
the corner of the pedestal, where he
could lean sideways and put his talons
over sore tail's eyes.
Obediently, he closed his own as well.
There was a smashing sound from above him
and tiny bits of glass pattered down all
over him and sore tail.
He shook his head, and squinted open his
eyes into the new brightness.
Sorry about that, Cricket said.
Are you all right?
He nodded.
She was using the tweezers to work the
flame silk thread out.
He couldn't look straight at her or the
thread without getting a headache.
A moment later, she had it free.
He hopped down to the ground, and she
took his place on the pedestal, with a
few careful strokes.
She burned through Swordtail's wrist cuff
in the same way she'd burned off blues.
Blue met sore tail's eyes as the heavy
band clunked to the ground.
He didn't think he was imagining the
spark of jubilation in them.
All right, moment of truth, Cricket
said.
Would you mind passing me the vial?
Very, very carefully.
He uncorked it and held it high, keeping
his claws as steady as he could, while
she reached down for it.
Now you might want to hold your breath
she said.
Clearside only knows what this could do
to us.
This is such a cool experiment.
I feel like a real scientist, don't you?
She took a deep breath herself and
dropped the flame silk into the vial.
The liquid started bubbling furiously.
Cricket clamped the tweezers around the
vial, and held it out under SwordTail's
snout.
Green smoke boiled up from the top of it
enveloping Swordtail's face in a thick
emerald cloud.
Blue stared up at them.
His heart pounding.
Chapter 12.
Please work.
Blue prayed.
Please, please be all right, sword tail.
Clear sight.
If you're listening.
Please set him free.
They waited several long, agonizing
moments, all 3 dragons frozen in place.
And then Swordtail twitched suddenly
violently, knocking cricket off the
pedestal with one flailing wing, Blue
jumped to break or fall.
The vial shattered on the stone path
spilling what was left of the hissing
green chemical.
Crickets scrambled over to pick up the
flame silk in her tweezers again, tucking
the thread into a small stone jar with a
tight lid that she'd also had hidden in
her bag.
Sortell let out a gasp, his jaw clenched
his eyelids closed, and slowly, he
lowered his reaching talon, shaking it
hard as though it had been asleep.
Sore tail?
Blue said, Blue.
Sortail croaked.
He opened his eyes and gingerly inched
his head around to look down at them.
The poison seemed to be wearing off
gradually.
From his face, through his wings and back
and at last to his tail.
Do you feel all right?
Cricket asked him.
Anything weird?
How's your nose?
Did that hurt?
I hope it didn't hurt, but it might
have.
I don't know.
The plants can't exactly tell us if it
does.
Are you dizzy?
How are your lungs?
Sortail raised one talent to feel the
trickle of dried blood on his neck.
Oh, right, he said thickly.
Cricket, Blue whispered.
Are his eyes supposed to be turning
green?
The whites of Swordtail's eyes.
Around his normally dark blue irises, or
turning a shade of emerald green, only
slightly paler than the liquid from the
vial.
Oh.
Fascinating.
Cricket said.
Why would that happen?
Is it affecting your vision?
Can you see all right?
She asked Swordtail.
He blinked a few times.
Bit greenish, he offered.
No, wait.
Uh-oh.
Definitely bad.
Blue is all the wrong colors.
Oh no, Blue said.
That's just paint.
Don't worry.
Huh.
Sorrytails said.
Sure.
Sounds normal.
Swordtail crouched.
Then arched his back into a stretch like
a jungle cat.
He flared his wings and leaped down from
the pedestal, landing in a wobbly
sprawl.
Woof, he said.
Legs, disagreeing with me.
He sat down heavily and frowned at his
feet.
Whoa.
Very demanding licks.
Cricket.
You're a genius, Blue said.
I can't believe that worked.
Neither can I, she said.
I should write a paper about this.
No, a book.
I mean, it's a real scientific
breakthrough, right?
We could.
She stopped, realizing what she was
saying.
Oh, no.
I guess I can do that.
The Queen probably wouldn't appreciate
it.
Blue agreed.
Soratell looked at them.
A gleam in his newly green eyes.
But I know some dragons, who would be
very interested.
He said.
His voice was only a little bit slurred
now.
Very, very, very, ever so very
interested.
Does he mean the chrysalis?
Blue wondered.
He glanced back along the path at the
other frozen figures.
Would they set all these prisoners free?
If they knew how cricket did it?
And if they did, What would happen then?
He imagined all the prisoners staggering
off their pedestals, green eyed like
sword tail, all of them angry and free at
the same time.
Would they attack hive wing soldiers?
Or would they all run away?
What does the chrysalis want exactly?
Sortail shook his wings out again.
Blue.
Wow.
I can't believe it's you.
I mean, it's amazing that it's you.
You, here.
All kinds of amazing.
He opened and closed his mouth a few
times, as if trying to make all his
muscles work again.
That is, I mean, of all the dragons, I
might have expected to come rescue me.
He said.
You and a strange little hive wing are
probably the last on the list, but thank
you.
Did I say thank you?
I've been thinking thank you very
loudly.
Probably should say it a few times.
He touched Blue's shoulder with one of
his talons, then let go, and gave an odd
hop sideways.
Sortail's whole body seemed to be
vibrating just a little bit.
Iu tried to get me away.
Blue said, but we had to split up.
Cricket saved me.
Are you all right?
Cricket asked Swordtail.
What are you feeling right now?
What happened to Luna?
Swartail asked, all his manic energy
suddenly focused on the question.
Blue shook his head.
I'm not sure.
But we think they've taken her to where
the queen keeps all her flame silks.
We think it might be in or near Wasp
Pive.
So that's where we're going next.
Cricket interjected.
Blue blinked at her.
That sure sounds like she's coming too.
He didn't want to ask.
He was afraid to jinx it, but he smiled
at her when she looked his way, and she
smiled back.
I should get help, Sordell said.
His tail had started lashing back and
forth, like a whip, but he didn't seem to
notice.
His claws extended and closed.
His ears flicked up and down.
Even his antennae were fully unfurled and
waving around.
Help is a useful thing.
There are dragons I can reach out to.
The chrysalis?
Cricket asked.
How will you find them?
What can they do?
He narrowed his eyes at her.
How do you know about the chrysalis?
She doesn't, Blue said quickly.
She knows as much as I do, which is
pretty much nothing.
Then it should stay that way.
Swartail growled.
His shoulders twitched, making his wings
flutter up and back.
Let's see.
It would take a while.
Leave a message, wait for a response.
We'd have to find a safe place to hide.
Blue doesn't have time to wait for other
dragons, Cricket said.
He needs to get as far away from this
hive as possible before dawn.
That's when the queen is going to take
over everyone again and send them out
looking for him.
You can stay and contact the chrysalis if
you want.
Blue said.
But we are leaving right now, Cricket
finished.
We are, Blue Thought, with a little glow
of happiness.
Cricket and me.
To find Luna, Soretail asked.
Blue nodded.
Then I'm coming with you.
He said.
Yes, to save her.
That is the most me thing to do.
I am most definitely coming with you.
He flexed his claws and bounced in place
for a moment.
And then Sortell suddenly ran at the
stone pedestal and smashed his shoulder
into it.
Sore tail, Blue yelped.
Soartail looked at him, grinning.
Large cracks had appeared all along the
stone.
Look what I did, he said.
I feel like I could knock over
everything.
All the columns, any building.
The whole hive.
Blue said with alarm.
Cricket, is this normal?
I have no idea, she said, wide eyed.
What I gave him is sort of a stimulant
and it does make the plants grow bigger
and faster.
I feel bigger.
Swordtail declared, at a horrifying
volume, I feel faster.
He turned and sprinted away down the
path.
Uh-oh, Cricket said.
Um, any chance he's always like this?
No, Blue cried.
This is definitely weird.
Hmm, she said.
How long do you think it'll last?
How would I know?
Crash when something up ahead of them.
Thud, smash, ha, ha.
Swordtail shouted.
Blue bolted after his friend.
Cricket close behind him.
They found sword tail merrily lifting
enormous rocks, and throwing them at the
wall of the hive.
Even paralyzed, the 2 nearest prisoners
somehow managed to look alarmed.
What are you doing?
Blue yelped, catching Swordtail's arm.
Making us a door, Swordtail answered.
I'm in construction, you know?
This is totally my job.
He lifted another boulder, which looked
much heavier than anything glue could
have picked up and hurled it at the
wall.
The tree stuff was already splintered and
cracked, with several small holes in it.
Hey, grasshopper.
Sortel shouted, making blue jump.
Look how hard I'm working.
Are you happy now?
Swordtail.
Please be quiet, Blue bagged.
It's probably too late for that, Cricket
said, glancing back along misbehavior's
way.
Take that, Sortell yelled.
He heaved an entire stone tablet out of
the ground and threw it as hard as he
could.
It smashed right through the side of the
hive and plummeted out of sight.
Blue stared at the gaping hole that was
left.
Fragments of tree stuff feathered out on
all sides of it, and wood smelling dust
hazed the air.
This is vandalism, he thought, and
destruction of hive property.
There are definitely rules about this.
Possibly on that tablet, Thorotel just
hurled through the wall.
On the other side of the hole.
He could see clouds rimmed with moonlight
and the far off lights of another hive.
Where other dragons are having a
perfectly normal evening that doesn't
involve getting painted, hiding from
soldiers, or watching their friends lose
their minds.
Let's go.
Swartell cried, charging toward the
opening.
I can't, Blue said.
We're too high.
I don't have wings, remember?
I'll carry you, Soratel said
enthusiastically.
I can do it.
I'm as strong as 10 dragons.
I can carry both of you at the same
time.
Absolutely not.
Thank you, Cricket said.
My own 2 wings work perfectly fine.
She turned toward Blue.
I think we have to go out this way, don't
you?
We can't go back.
There must be guards coming to
investigate the noise.
Are you sure you want to come?
Blue said.
You could go home now.
You could be safe and stay out of this
whole mess.
And never find out what happens.
She adjusted her glasses and smiled at
him.
Are you kidding me?
Sore tail flapped his wings at blue.
Time to fly, short stuff, he shouted.
By all the hives, sore tail.
What is happening to you?
Blue asked.
Instead of answering, Sortell shot a long
strand of silk at him and snared Blue's
shoulders.
He tugged blue closer, and wove several
more strands into a quick harness to bind
them together.
Blue noticed that Swordtail's silk had
also turned a strange new shade of pale
green.
I'm not sure this is a good idea.
Blue said nervously, as Sortail clasped
his front talons around Blue's chest.
This close to the hole.
He could see the rippling grass far, far
below him.
I'm not that light, and it's a long way
down.
To the moons, swordtail hollered, leaping
out into the air.
Blue felt a terrifying, plummeting
feeling in his stomach, as they lurched
awkwardly for a moment, down and down
again toward the savannah, and then
suddenly up, sideways, and up, and
finally away, beating forward at a steady
pace.
The wind whipped and blew his face.
It was cold out here in the dark, after
the close warmth of the hive.
He peeked backward and saw cricket
soaring alongside them.
Get it?
Sortails said conversationally, Because
Luna is like lunar, which means moons.
So, to the moons is like, to Luna, but in
code.
So, awesome.
I thought that was clever.
He kept chattering as he flew, as though
he couldn't stop the flow of words coming
out of him.
Blue looked back again, this time at the
vast shape of cicada hive, and the
silvery tangles of the webs far
overhead.
He thought of Burnet and Silverspot
sleeping alone in their cell for the 1st
time since Luna had hatched.
Could they sleep?
Or were they lying awake?
Wishing they'd been wrong about Admiral?
Worrying about Luna and Blue?
Will I ever see them again?
His home was disappearing behind him.
He didn't know what was ahead.
He only knew he couldn't turn back.
And so he looked out toward the dark
Savannah, and let his friends carry him
forward into the night.
Part two.
Out of the hive.
Chapter 13.
They flew all the rest of that night
swooping low to the savannah whenever the
moons breached the clouds, just in case
anyone was watching for them.
Sortell charted a course straight across
the circle toward Wasp Hive, which made
sense, but quickly brought them to a part
of the Savannah, where dragons rarely
ventured.
The grass was long and wild, and shapes
prowled below them, growls, and shrieks
and curling hoots rose from the darkness
slicing through the constant hum of the
insects.
Once he got over his fear, Blue found the
rhythm of sword tails' wings, lulling him
into a kind of doze.
His friend seemed tireless, soaring on
and on without stopping.
Blue hoped cricket was all right.
He tried to call to her a few times, but
the wind whipped his voice away.
After a long time, Blue noticed that he
could see the outlines of shrubs below
him, gray and ghostly.
He glanced up and saw an expanding band
of pale yellow light along the edge of
the sky.
It's almost morning.
He called out to Swordtail.
We should hide for the day.
That's what I think, Sortail answered.
It's still half a day's journey to Wasp
Hive, and they'll be out looking for us
in force today, and it would be better to
get there at night anyway.
Night, an excellent time of day for
heroics.
Cricket, Blue called, trying to twist
around to see her.
Hide, she panted behind them.
She looked exhausted, but her wings beat
valiantly.
Yes, good.
Where?
Blue studied the Savannah as far as he
could see in each direction.
The yellow grass rippled, broken only by
gnarled little shrubs, patches of barren
dirt, or the winding path of dry river
beds.
The rainy season was coming soon.
So the ground below them was dry.
There was nothing large enough to hide in
or under, or behind.
Hunting parties of hive wings would spot
them from the air with no trouble at
all.
Disguise ourselves as grass?
Soitel suggested, disguise ourselves as
shrubs.
Disguise ourselves as elephants.
That's it.
Let's do it.
That stuff still hasn't worn off.
Blue called to Cricket.
Or I can build us a web.
Swartell said, a giant web, and we hide
underneath it, and they'll think there
must be some massively enormous spiders
colonizing the Savannah.
This will totally work.
Let's fly a bit farther, Cricket said
between breaths.
Try to find somewhere.
Blue barely blinked.
He was staring so intently at the
ground.
Off to his left, he saw a herd of teeny
tiny deer with enormous ears bounding
through the grass, which was shorter and
scrubbier here.
A tall, long necked gray and white bird
stalked slowly along one of the sun baked
river beds, ignoring the smaller birds
that perched on its back, or flew down to
poke the barren soil.
There was nowhere to hide.
Blue's heart sank. as they flew on, and
the sky grew brighter.
This was a mistake.
The savannah was the worst place they
could have gone.
And then, as the sun peaked over the
horizon, he saw the vast looming shape of
a hive in the distance, wasp hive.
His heart kicked hard in his chest.
The home of Queen Wasp, the grandest and
wealthiest of all the hives, the location
of the temple, where the book of clear
sight was worshiped, and protected by
generation after generation of librarians
a hive full of power, and soldiers, and
secrets, where the queen might be hiding
his sister.
And his father, and other flame silks.
Are we really doing this?
He thought, with sudden crashing anxiety
what are we doing?
Do we think we can sneak into Wasp Hive?
of all places, and find something the
queen wants to stay hidden?
Sortel banged around, making Blue's
stomach drop, and swooped back to
cricket.
We shouldn't get any closer, he said.
She might send out hunters from her own
hive to search for us too, if she's
paranoid, which she is, which she should
be because He cut himself off abruptly
and nodded a few times.
Because reasons.
But where?
Crickets spiraled in the air.
There's nothing out here.
I didn't know it would be like this.
She looked tired and worried, and Blue
felt a surge of guilt for dragging her
into his mess.
He tried to imagine what it must be like
for her, far from home.
Helping 2 runaway silk wings, knowing how
much trouble she'd be in if she was
caught with them.
Is that something over there?
Blue asked, pointing.
There was a dark slash in the unending
sea of cracked earth and yellow grass.
Let's find out.
Swartell said.
He beat his wings and sword toward it.
It's a hole.
Blue thought. as they drew closer.
A really big hole.
It looked as though the earth had
suddenly dropped away here. a long time
ago, leaving a cavernous shaft lined with
moss covered rocks, and long green plants
trying to clamber out into the sunshine.
It was impossible to see the bottom.
Even when they landed on the rim, and
tried to peer down into it.
Outcroppings of rock blocked most of
their view, and where they could see past
those.
All they saw was more darkness
disappearing down and down.
Sortail used his claws to cut away the
silk connecting him and Blue.
Blue took a few wobbly steps, shaking out
his legs, and trying to get the feeling
back into them.
Are you all right?
He asked Cricket.
I was crouching on the edge of the
sinkhole, holding her glasses on with one
talon while she peered down.
Absolutely, she said.
What is this?
How deep do you think it goes?
What to the bottom?
How did it get this way?
Have you ever seen anything like this?
I haven't been out on the savannah much
either?
He admitted.
I didn't know it had sinkholes.
Are we going down it?
she asked, turning to SwordTail.
Can we?
Her eyes were shining, as though her
tiredness had evaporated in the
excitement of a new discovery.
I don't know, he said, hopping from one
foot to another with a restless energy.
This seems like the most obvious place to
hide, so I assume they'll check here, and
then we'll be trapped to the bottom of a
hole with no way to escape.
I still think my elephant plan is the
best.
Elephants are great.
I can look like an elephant, no problem.
He struck an odd, dramatic pose, which
blue guest was supposed to look
elephantesque.
What do you think?
Cricket asked Blue.
Sortel had a point, but where else could
they hide?
He turned to look over his shoulder at
the distant shape of Wasp Hive.
For a moment, he thought his vision had
gone blurry.
Then he thought, fleetingly, that a swarm
of insects had surrounded the hive.
But finally, with a chill of terror, he
realized that the buzzing motion around
the city came from the wings of dragons
pouring out of every window and door, and
shaking the webs with the wind they
raised.
Dawn was here.
The hunt had begun.
We go down, he said, quickly, right now.
Cricket didn't hesitate.
She dove over the edge and vanished.
Sortell hooked his front talons under
Blue's arms again, and leaped off as
well.
They dropped down and down, pushing off
from the craggy lichen covered walls when
they got too close, and maneuvering
around bulbous outcroppings.
The air got cooler and more damp as they
descended.
The shaft was narrow, leaving barely
enough room in places for Soretail to
keep his wings spread.
What if there is no bottom to this hole?
Blue worried?
Or what do the hive wings get here before
we find the bottom?
Did they know about this sinkhole?
How long before they came to search it?
Finally, below his claws, Blue saw the
rocks converge onto a kind of ground.
Although it was really just more rock, but
at least he could stand on it, and it
seemed to be the bottom of the hole.
Sortail let him down gently, and hopped
onto a ledge to stretch his wings.
Blue glanced up at the tiny strip of
sunlight far overhead, then around for
cricket.
The rock under his feet slanted down and
away from the shaft into a dark tunnel.
It was the only way Cricket could have
gone, so he followed uneasily.
After a few steps, the tunnel widened
into a cave, although by now, the light
was so dim that he couldn't tell how big
it was, he heard the faint drip, drop, of
water, somewhere up ahead.
Cricket, he whispered.
Right here.
She materialized out of the dark and
brushed his shoulder with her wing.
This cave is enormous, and watch your
step, because there's a lake that starts
a little ways down this slope, a lake
blue, under the savannah.
Would you have guessed?
Isn't that wild?
And there's something else strange?
Come see.
Or, I guess, feel.
Seeing isn't really an option down here.
She nudged him through the dark until he
felt water lapping at his claws, and then
a few steps later, something bumped
against his leg.
He jumped back, thinking it was alive.
The cricket reached for it, and guided it
into his talons, so he could feel that it
was a large object, floating on the
surface of the lake, and there was a rope
tied to one end of it, which led to a
stalagmite that jutted from the rocky
floor.
A rope, which meant someone had been here
before them.
What do you think it is?
She whispered to him.
I have no idea.
He whispered back.
Someone must have left it like this. she
said.
Maybe to carry things across the lake.
But why not just fly across with whatever
they had to carry?
This is so mysterious.
Blue heard the rustle of wings, as
Soretailed ducked into the cave with
them.
I think I heard voices up above, he
whispered.
Can we go deeper?
Let's see, Cricket whispered back, barely
a breath on the air.
They felt their way deeper into the cave
staying close to the wall, and skirting
the edge of the lake.
Soon, that became impossible as they ran
out of shoreline, and they had to wade
into the cold, still silk of the water.
It was terrifying, wading into the dark
and ever deepening water, but not as
terrifying as the thought of the hive
wings behind them.
Blue shivered as the water climbed up his
legs, lapped at his underbelly, and soon
covered his wing buds.
He'd seen the ocean in the distance from
the top of the webs, but he'd never been
submerged in water, and he certainly had
no idea how to swim.
If the water got any deeper, he wasn't
sure he'd be able to go on.
There's a passage here, Cricket whispered
or an alcove or something, I think.
Ripples flickered around blue as cricket
ducked away, then came back to tug on his
arm.
He held out his tail for sore tail to
catch, then let Cricket guide him under a
dip in the roof.
Now he could feel walls on either side of
him, and to his surprise, here and there
he saw what looked like sticky trails of
light webbing across the roof above, or
sliding down the walls.
Cricket paused, and brought her nose
closer to one of these, studying it
curiously for a moment before moving on.
They waited forward for what felt like an
eternity.
And then the passage curved, and ahead of
them, reflecting off the slick wet walls
was the glow of firelight, blue froze
touching cricket's wing.
She stopped too, with a little gasp.
Fire.
Is this it?
Did we find where Queen Wasp is hiding
the flame silks?
Or, What are we about to walk into?
Chapter 14.
Blue glanced back toward SwordTail, his
face was dimly visible in the
phosphorescent glow from the walls.
Sortell edged past them to take the lead
and they all inched forward, step by
careful step.
There was a cavern ahead.
Stalactites bubbled down from a high
ceiling.
Streaks of orange and white marbled the
stone walls, shot through with veins of
glittering black and gold ore.
The water lapped against the shore here
before continuing into another, wider
tunnel.
Rock formations twisted up in shapes like
dragon tails, making the cavern look like
a weird forest of petrified trunks.
The firelight wasn't coming from any
flame silk dragons.
It flickered from a small pile of burning
sticks, not far from the water, and next
to the fire, sitting with its back
against one of the stalagmites, was a
creature Blue had never seen in any
animal studies in school.
It looked a little bit like a monkey, but
bigger, and not quite so hairy, apart
from a patch of floppy brown fur on top
of its head.
It had nimble little paws, which were
holding something that it was gazing at
intently.
Parts of it were wrapped in something
like a cocoon made of jaguar fur, and
deep red silk.
At first, it didn't notice the 3 dragons
emerging from the tunnel.
It was too immersed in whatever it was
looking at.
Blue and Cricket exchanged wondering
glances.
She looked as bewildered as he felt, but
also enchanted.
Then Blue stepped on a rock that turned
under his talons, and he lurched forward
with a small splash.
The creature's head popped up and its
eyes, as brown and big in its face as
crickets went wide, it jumped to its feet
revealing that it stood on 2 paws instead
of 4, dropped whatever it had been
looking at, and drew a long knife from
its cocoon.
Blue and his friend stopped and stared at
it.
It stared at them.
What is it thinking?
Blue wondered.
Can it think?
What does it know about dragons?
Is it just scared?
Or is it having other emotions?
What a sweet little face it has.
Like a marmoset.
But I've never seen a monkey with a knife
before.
Sometimes a monkey wandered up into the
webs by accident, long black spidery
limbs racing up the high vines, and out
onto the silvery bridges.
Blue remembered one that IO had played
with for an entire day.
She'd wanted to keep it, but her parents
made her take it back to the Savannah and
release it.
They told her that if the hive wings
found it, they might eat it, and that
would be much more upsetting.
It was hard to argue with that.
This monkey's limbs seemed the wrong
shape for climbing vines or swinging from
trees, and its coiled energy was more
like a panther's poised to spring at
them.
Do you really think it's going to try
stabbing us with that thing?
Cricket whispered.
Her voice broke the spell.
The creature spun around and fled between
the stalagmites, disappearing through a
crack in the wall behind it.
Oh no, Cricket cried.
Wait, come back.
She floundered through the water up onto
the shore, and scrambled after the little
animal, but the crack was too small for a
dragon to fit through.
She crouched beside the opening, trying
to peek inside.
I promise we won't hurt you, little
monkey.
What are you?
Please come back.
That was really cute, Blue said.
He waded onto the shore, carefully
skirting the fire so he wouldn't
accidentally put it out.
After the darkness of the previous
caves.
It was nice to be able to see, and much
warmer nearer the fire than in the lake.
I thought it was freaky, Sortell said.
Weird little thing.
Did you see how it was looking at us?
It was, I don't.
He interrupted himself with an absolutely
enormous yawn.
I really want to know what it was, Cricket
said, stamping one foot with
frustration.
I thought I'd studied all the flora and
fauna around here, even the prehistoric
stuff.
I don't remember any pictures that looked
like that.
She tipped her head up, staring into
space as though she was flipping through
pages in her mind.
Not a gorilla, not an orangutan, not a
chimpanzee.
What in the hive?
Blue picked up the object the creature
had been looking at.
Oh, wow.
Cricket, check this out.
She wound her way back through the
stalagmites toward him.
He turned the thing over in his claws.
The outside was flexible leather.
The inside was many layers of smooth
beaten paper, and there were little marks
all over each page.
What?
Cricket said, astonished.
She took it from him and flipped through
it gently.
Is this a book?
It can be.
Monkeys can't write books or read them.
It's not a dragon book.
It didn't come from a hive.
Blue pointed out.
Look how tiny it is.
A dollhouse book?
Cricket tried.
Which the monkey found somewhere?
She shook her head.
No, you're right.
This is the monkey's book.
When we came in, I thought its expression
looked familiar.
And that's because it was reading.
She hugged the book to her chest.
Mystery animals in a cave under the
savannah?
Who can read?
Blue.
This is the biggest scientific discovery
of our lifetime.
I wouldn't have to be a gardener if I
told the queen about this.
I'm sure she'd let me change disciplines
so I could study them.
Don't you think?
I'm a little worried she'd have them all
rounded up and eaten, Blue admitted.
Cricket looked horrified.
No way.
Is that really what you think of hive
wings?
That because we eat meat where heartless
monsters?
Do all silk wings think that?
Um, Blue said.
I mean, I wouldn't have said heartless
but eating animals does seem kind of
unnecessary.
Cricket frowned and rubbed her head.
As though she'd never spent any time
thinking about whether eating animals was
necessary.
We don't eat everything, she said after a
while.
We don't eat lizards or snakes, since
they're probably related to us, and I'm
sure nobody would eat a species that can
read and write, and might be as smart as
we are.
A loud rumbling sound broke into their
conversation before Blue could answer.
They both spun around in fright and
discovered that it was the sound of sword
tail snoring.
The handsome silkwing was passed out by
the fire.
Wings flopped across the stone as though
he'd staggered out of the water and
collapsed in the 1st dry place he found.
Well, that makes sense, Blue said.
He did carry me halfway across the
savannah.
He probably needs to sleep for a week to
recover.
He caught himself.
It was only a joke, but who knew what
would happen to sword tail as the
stimulant wore off.
They couldn't afford to have sore tails
sleep for a week.
They needed to get to Luna as soon as
possible. before she emerged from her
cocoon all alone.
Do you want to sleep too?
Cricket asked.
I can keep an eye out in case any hive
wings come all the way down into the cave
find a passage, and follow it through to
here.
Which I don't think they will.
No, you should sleep.
And I'll take 1st watch.
Blue said.
You were flying all night too.
He could easily imagine how tired her
wings must be.
If he were in her scales, he knew he'd be
feeling very anxious and emotional as
well, given the stress of running away
from her own tribe, and upending her safe
hive wing life, surely even the
excitement of discovering a new
intelligent species couldn't outweigh the
danger she'd put herself in.
Which she did for me, to help me.
All right, Cricket said with a yawn.
If you're really sure, I wouldn't mind
sleeping a little bit.
Of course.
He watched her stretch her wings and curl
up on the rock, close enough for him to
touch her talons if he needed to wake
her.
Her orange gold scales rose and fell
slower and slower as she drifted off to
sleep.
The firelight flickered little shadows
across her back, as though the ink blot
splatter patterns were spreading, and
shrinking, and dancing.
Maybe she's not as scared as I would be
he thought.
Maybe for her.
Finding out new things is enough to drive
out her fear.
Maybe this feels like an adventure to
her.
But that was hard for him to imagine.
Especially when he pictured the army of
mind controlled hive wings far above them
combing the grasslands stalk by stock, who
wouldn't be afraid of that.
Maybe Swordtail, his best and bravest
friend.
He was a dragon who'd face that entire
army to save Luna or Blue.
His courage had always seemed foolish and
dangerous, and impulsive to blue.
But now he wished he had even a 10th of
it himself.
He lay down with his chin on his front
talons, and thought about everyone who'd
become entangled in this web.
Io, who could be anywhere right now.
Burnet and Silverspot, alone and worrying
about their children.
Katie did, wondering where her sister
was.
All the hive wings who were being forced
to hunt for him, whether they understood
why or not.
And somewhere in the center of that web
Queen Wasp, stealing the flame silks, and
using her subjects like puppets.
Was she angry right now?
Or coldly certain that she'd find him
soon?
At least Luna was unaware of all this.
Somewhere deep in her cocoon, she was
asleep.
Growing her wings in peace.
She had no idea what kind of chaos her
metamorphosis had set off, or what
strange new prison she was going to wake
up in.
I'm coming, Luna, he thought fiercely.
Sortell and I will find you.
You're not going to wake up alone.
I promise.
Chapter 15.
Blue stood at the bottom of the sinkhole
looking up.
He could just barely see the glow of
moonlight reflecting off some of the
rocks far overhead.
His tail flicked a damp patch of moss on
one of the rocks, and he shivered.
Do you think it's safe to go up?
Cricket asked.
Hive wings prefer to hunt by day.
Swordtail pointed out.
Their night vision is poor, and they're
lazy and arrogant, so I'm sure they're at
home asleep, confident they'll catch us
tomorrow.
Cricket blinked at him, looking slightly
hurt.
I'm not at home asleep, she observed.
Right.
Blue said.
That's not fair, Swordtail.
They're not all lazy and arrogant.
They're dragons, just like you and me and
everyone we know.
Some bad and some good.
Dragons who stolen your sister and spent
the last day hunting you.
So they can throw you in their secret
prison too.
Soartail said sharply.
That's Queen Wasp making them do that
Blue said.
They're not all like her.
So what?
They let her be like that, and never
complain or speak up, because it means
they get to be comfortable, Soritell
said.
Sorry, Blue.
I'm not in the mood to feel sorry for the
bad guys right now.
He spread his wings and launched himself
up to shaft.
I'll go check if the coast is clear.
Blue side is sore tail flew away.
The strange, frenetic energy of the
stimulant had worn off, and after
sleeping almost the entire day, Sortell
had woken up pretty much his normal self
again, which was great, except for how
his normal self could sometimes be a big
honking rhinoceros, trampling over
everyone else's feelings.
I'm sorry.
He said to Cricket.
Don't be, she said.
He's right.
I never worried about how we treat silk
wings or what happens to flame silks
before.
Neither did I, really, Blue admitted.
But you're helping us now.
You're not like the others.
If Queen Wasp could control my mind, I
probably would be, she said.
It's just luck or some kind of mystery
science that it doesn't work on me.
Sortell swooped back down toward them.
All quiet, as far as I can see and hear
he said.
If we fly now.
We should make it to Wasp Hive before
morning.
And then what?
Cricket asked.
Then we figure something else out, he
said.
That sounds like a sword tail kind of
plan, Blue Thought.
But he didn't have anything better to
offer, so he kept quiet.
Sore Tail spun a harness around Blue
again, and braced his forearms around
Blue's chest.
All right, he said.
Off we.
He vaulted into the air, and immediately
lost his balance, smacking into the side
of the canyon and thudding to the ground
again.
Blue's claws barked painfully against the
stone, and he yelped.
Oof.
Soartail grunted.
Sorry, let me just...
He braced his legs and shoved himself
aloft again, clutching Blue even more
tightly.
No luck.
Blue could feel himself slipping, even
with the harness, and sore tail's muscles
were clearly straining to hold him.
His wings beat as hard as he could.
But a moment later, he had to drop back
down.
Uh oh, Cricket said, hovering above
them.
Blue glanced up at the far, far distant
top of the hole again.
Uh-oh, was a bit of an understatement.
Sortell sized away the silk connecting
them, and crouched, gasping for breath.
If you can't carry him anymore, Cricket
said.
How are we going to get blue out of this
cave?
I don't understand why I can't.
Sortell protested.
I carried him all day yesterday.
And it was no trouble at all.
He flexed his arms and winced.
I guess I do feel a little sore now.
It was the stimulant, cricket said.
It made you stronger and gave you energy
but only until it wore off.
That is so interesting.
I wonder if anyone has any idea that it
has that effect on dragons, or if other
scientists have only ever used it on
plans.
Her eyes went a little dreamy.
Maybe for the science fair next year?
Do you have any more of it?
So tell asked, eyeing the pouch tied
around her chest.
She shook her head.
Now, and I wouldn't suggest taking it
from a normal state, she said, not
without some dilution experiments and
animal studies first.
I mean, you started off completely
paralyzed, and look what it did to you.
What it...
What did I say?
Swortell asked.
Did I sound like a total idiot?
You were fine.
Blue assured him.
It was adorable.
Oh, good.
Soartail grumbled.
Adorable is just the look I was going for
on our heroic mission.
So what else can we do?
Cricket said, studying the rocks around
them.
Blue, could you climb out?
Of course.
Swartail answered for him.
Silkwings are all great climbers.
Well, maybe, but all that way?
Blue said, his courage failing.
I mean, I don't mind the climbing part
but the maybe falling part, and the very
long way to fall, and the certain death
if I fall parts, those I'm kind of less
excited about.
Plus, there's no way he'll make it to the
top before morning.
Sortell said.
And then what do we do?
Climb back down, risk the open Savannah
again.
There might be another option.
Hang on, Cricket said.
She spread her wings and flew away.
Up and up till Blue could hardly see the
shimmer of her sunlight colored scales.
He had a horrible moment of imagining
that she might not come back, but she'd
reached the top, realize she could just
go home and leave them and all their
messy, troublesome danger behind.
Blue.
Sortell said, in a low voice.
Blue glanced at him, and saw pity in his
friend's dark blue eyes.
Remember how you warned me once about
falling in love with Luna?
Soritell said, folding his wings back.
You said we might not be partnered
together.
You said it would be better for both of
us if we could wait to fall in love until
we knew who our partners would be.
Blue looked down at his claws.
That felt like a very foolish thing to
say now.
As though a dragon could inject a nerve
toxin into his feelings and leave them
paralyzed until they might be usable.
But he'd imagined how Luna and Swordtail
would feel if Queen Wasp separated them.
And it had been so awful.
He'd been trying to protect them from
that.
This is much worse blue.
Swartail said.
She's a hive wing.
You can never, never be with her.
You should tell her to go home now, before
it's too hard to say goodbye.
I think it already is.
Blue said softly.
At least for me.
Sortell put one wing over Blue's back and
arrested his head against blues.
I was afraid of that.
He said.
Cricket came swooping back down in a
flapping of wings and landed on an
outcropping a little ways above them.
There's a crevice near the top, she
said.
It's not very big, but I think Blue could
hide in it.
If we can get him to it by morning, he
could wait out the day there, and then
we'd keep going to Wasp Hive tomorrow
night.
Blue felt the tension ripple through
Swordtail's body.
He knew what he was feeling.
Another day's delay.
A whole night wasted on one wingless
dragon climbing out of a hole.
When Luna was out there and needed their
help, now.
You can go on without me, if you'd
rather.
He said to Swordtail.
He could see that sword tail was
tempted.
After all, what use was Blue going to be
in a rescue anyway?
He couldn't exactly fight.
And if they had to escape in a hurry, he
would massively slow them down.
No, don't do that.
Cricket said.
I was hoping you'd use your silk to help
Lou climb out.
She pointed up.
To catch him if he falls.
Oh, Swordtail said.
Light dawning in his eyes as he saw what
she meant.
Of course, that's a good idea.
Cricket is full of good ideas, Blue
said.
She ducked her head and smiled at him, and
he felt his heart explode.
Definitely too late.
I can say goodbye to her.
Even if it means it'll hurt more later.
I still want to be with her for as long
as I can.
All right, let's try this, Soitel said.
Again shooting silk from his wrists.
This time, the thicker, stronger strands
that were usually used for building web
bridges.
He wound it around blue, leaving his
limbs free to climb, then leaped out to
the ledge above cricket, still holding
the other end of the silk.
Go ahead.
He called.
All right.
This is happening.
Blue thought.
He sent up a silent prayer to Clearsight
and started up the side of the Rocky
Canyon.
In fact, it was easier to climb than he'd
expected.
There were a lot of little crevices and
nooks for him to dig his talons into, and
the stone, overall, felt much sturdier
than the webs he'd grown up clambering
around on.
At least the rocks didn't bounce and sway
in the wind.
And when he did stumble, losing his
footing for a moment, he felt the
strength of the webbing catch him, the
strength of sore tail, just above him
braced to save him before he fell.
And cricket was beside him the whole way
suggesting the easiest paths, pointing
out places for him to rest, not for the
1st time.
Blue felt very, very grateful for his
friends.
Even though the climbing went well, it
still seemed to take forever.
It was a really deep hole after all.
Blue's whole body was aching before he
was halfway up.
He found himself daydreaming wistfully
about honey drops, and tiny sugar bees
and silk hammocks, and when at last
cricket said, it's here.
It's just above you.
He looked up and saw that the sky was
already pale gray, and most of the stars
had disappeared.
Cricket was right.
They were near the top, and he'd be able
to climb out early the next night.
If he wasn't caught by then.
With one last heave, he hauled himself
onto the ledge next to Cricket, letting
Swordtail lift him with the webbing.
He sprawled there, breathing hard, and
wondering if his legs would ever work
again.
Sortell poked his head over the rim of
the sinkhole, and squinted in the
direction of Wasp Hive.
I don't see anyone yet, he said, flying
back to them, but you should still get
hidden to be safe.
Back here.
Cricket flicked her tail at the rippling
stone of the rock wall.
Blue crawled over and saw how the bend of
the rock and the dangling plants hid a
narrow crack, just big enough for him to
squeeze through.
He was amazed that Cricket had even found
it in the 1st place.
She held the green leaves aside, so he
could wedge himself in, and he discovered
that the crack extended into the rock
like a small cave, so he could go farther
in, squishily turn around and lie down.
Cricket poked her head in and watched him
settle.
Do you want company?
Which would be kind of cramped.
Or do you want the whole space?
But alone.
Company, Blue said.
If, if you don't mind.
I don't mind, if you don't mind my wings
in your face, she said.
She wriggled back out to tell sword tail
and blew her the whoosh of his friend's
wing beats retreating back down to the
safety of the lake cave.
Then Cricket was wedging herself in
through the gap, making little squeaking
noises as she tried to keep her wings
clear of the rough stones.
Blue pressed himself back as far as he
could, and after a minute, she managed to
get all the way in and lie down facing
him.
Thank you for your delightful
invitation.
She said, in a pretend lordly voice
adjusting her glasses.
I adore what you've done with the place.
I'll be expecting tea and sliced avocados
of course.
Blue put his chin on his talons and
chuckled.
Don't make me think about food.
I can't stop thinking about food, she
said.
I'm starving.
Those fish I caught for breakfast, we're
so small, and super weird.
Did you see that they didn't have eyes?
Oh, right, I showed you.
Fish with no eyes.
Do you think that's because there's no
light down there?
I guess I wouldn't rather eat something
with eyes, but you should have tried them
anyway.
I could have caught more.
That's all right, Blue said with a
smile.
I can wait for something in the vegetable
family.
Cricket studied him.
What will you do with Luna?
she asked.
I mean, if you can set her free.
Where will you go?
Queen Wasp isn't going to stop looking
for you.
I have no idea.
Blue said slowly.
Honestly, he'd been imagining getting
Luna and going home to their mothers.
A part of him still felt as though this
was a big misunderstanding, and if he
could only convince Queen Wasp of how
harmless they were, she let them go back
to their normal lives.
I wish we could do that.
Why can't there be a way?
Although, would it ever feel the same?
Now that I know about the flame silks, and
the mind control.
Would we ever feel safe again?
Maybe you could go live in the caves with
the reading monkeys, Cricket said, with a
dreamy smile in her voice, as though she
was making a joke, but actually thought
that sounded amazing.
That one we saw did look very welcoming.
Blue laughed in a stabby kind of way.
But, I'd go farther away if I were you
she said.
As far from Queen Wasp as you can.
Like one of the peninsulas, he asked.
I thought they were too dangerous for
dragons.
That's what we're told.
Crickets said, nodding.
But maybe it's not true.
Blue wasn't so sure.
He'd seen drawings of some of the plants
in the poison jungle, and they certainly
looked as if they'd be happy to eat a few
dragons, or impale some dragons, or melt
some dragons and convert their bone
sludge into nutrients.
You could go farther than that, though
Cricket said hesitantly.
I could, he said.
How?
Maybe...
Across the ocean, she said.
He stared at her with wide eyes.
Her body blocked most of the dim light
from outside.
So he couldn't really see the expression
on her face.
Was she joking?
Are you joking?
He asked.
The distant kingdoms aren't real.
The tilt of her head said she was
puzzled.
Of course they are.
That's where Clearsight came from.
Yes, but...
But Clearsight was magic.
Blue had always imagined the night black
seer dragon. as a mythological figure
like a star becoming a dragon and flying
down to visit them.
We say she came from the distant kingdoms
but we might as well say she came from
the moons or the sky.
The moons and the sky are real places too
cricket pointed out.
Not places we can go, he protested.
But we could go to the distant kingdoms
Cricket said.
I'm sure of it.
It's just another big island, somewhere
out to the east, full of other dragons.
He stared at her silhouette.
Thinking of how different their
educations had been.
At Silkworm Hall, he'd learned to revere
Clearsight, and accept the wisdom she'd
passed down in the book without
question.
He'd never been taught to think of her as
a regular dragon like him, from a normal
kingdom like his.
Other dragons like Clearsight.
He asked.
Is it a whole continent full of dragons
who can see the future?
I don't know.
Cricket said.
Maybe. wouldn't it be so interesting to
find out?
Can you imagine being the 1st dragons to
cross the ocean in 1000s of years?
I mean, what kinds of tribes live over
there?
Do they look like us?
Do they have other powers?
Do they have reading monkeys?
But if it is real, and it's that easy to
get there, Blue argued.
And Clearsight wouldn't be the only one
to have done it in all that time.
He shook his head.
I think it's a myth.
I think it's the perfect place to hide if
Queen Wasp is looking for you, Cricket
said.
But you're right, that it wouldn't be
easy to get there.
We'd have to find out how Clearsight did
it.
Magic, Blue said promptly.
Cricket leaned forward and bopped his
nose with hers.
Magic is just science we don't understand
yet, she said.
So maybe we can figure out her science.
How exactly?
he asked.
With books, Cricket said, as though that
was obvious, there must be clues in a
book somewhere.
He unfurled his antennae, sensing danger
and put one of his talons over hers.
Shh.
There were sounds coming from outside.
Chapter 16.
Blue and Cricket waited intense silence.
Wing beats, voices.
Oh, whoosh.
And then a cracking sound, like an
antelope's neck being broken, and
munching noises as it was devoured.
Blue shivered.
Who said you could eat?
said one of the voices.
Deep and sharp and female.
I didn't eat all day yesterday.
Another voice answered, whiny and male.
You know, she never lets us while she's
in control.
So I figure, as long as we're out here
and in charge of our own schools for once
we can hunt breakfast and run away silk
wings at the same time.
The other hive wing growled.
But there was a noise of ripping meat, as
though she'd taken a chunk of the prey
for herself.
This is a waste of time.
She muttered, chewing.
Who cares about one stupid dragonette who
might or might not have fire in his
silk?
He probably got eaten by a pack of lions
or fell down a hole and died already.
A hole like this one?
The voices drew nearer, and blue felt
crickets wings trembling.
Should we check down there?
Ugh, said the 1st dragon.
My patrol went down there yesterday.
It's dark and wet and haunted.
I think we can skip it.
Hello.
The 2nd dragon shouted down the chasm
making blue jump.
Hello, annoying wingless dragon.
Are you dead at the bottom of these rocks
or almost dead?
Could you croak?
Yeah, I'm here, totally dead.
Carry on, so we can all go home and say
we found you.
His companion actually laughed, which was
the most surprising part of the
conversation so far from Blue's point of
view.
Come on, finish your intestines so we can
get going, she said.
There are some scrub thickets over by
Tetsi Hive that I think are worth
checking out.
It felt like a long time, and a lot of
chewing noises later when they finally
flew away.
Blue let out of breath, and wondered how
long he'd been holding it.
His limbs were aching and heavy from the
long night of climbing.
And now that the danger had passed.
He felt his eyelids drooping.
It seemed safe enough to sleep.
If anyone found him, he couldn't exactly
escape in a hurry anyhow.
He rested his chin on the ground and
closed his eyes and slept.
Blue slept for most of the day, drifting
in and out when there were sounds of the
hunt overhead.
But each time he woke.
Cricket was there.
And he felt safe enough to sleep again.
At last, she nudged him awake, and they
squeezed out of the hidden crevice onto
the ledge outside.
The sky was just turning purple blue, and
a few stars were out.
Blue stretched out all his cramped
muscles, while cricket flew down to get
sore tail.
After that, it took only a little more
climbing before he reached the top of the
sinkhole, and scrambled onto safe, flat
ground.
It was strange how dry it felt up here
after the dampness of the deep cave.
Dust billowed up between his claws as he
cut off the silk harness and threw it
down the hole.
Now that he wasn't flying though, wasp
hive looked horribly far away.
Could they possibly make it there before
dawn?
Even if they did.
Would there be anywhere else to hide as
safe as the sinkhole?
I'll scout ahead, Swartell called, soaring
away.
His deep blue wings were soon swallowed
up by the night.
And all blue could see of him where the
little flickers of white along his back
like a flurry of snow moths.
Cricket landed to walk beside Blue
between the tufts of grass and stabby
little thorn bushes.
He glanced down at his talons and
realized that a lot of the paint had
flaked off, probably from wading in the
lake, and scraping against the rocks.
His real colors were showing through all
over his body, glints of aquamarine and
violet, shimmering like buried jewels.
They went as fast as they could.
Although sometimes they had to detour
around particularly dense shrubs, or ant
hills as big as they were.
At one point, a scorpion ran across
Blue's foot, and he nearly shrieked, but
managed not to.
The air was full of buzzing and zipping
and the tall grass rustled as snakes
glided out of their way.
Two of the moons were full.
The other was barely a sliver behind a
veil of clouds.
Cricket tipped her head back to look up
at them.
Did you see the comet about half a year
ago?
she asked.
The one that looked like an extra moon in
the sky.
It was so big.
I wished so much that I had a telescope
to study it with, but there's only one in
Cicada Hive, and Lady Scarab won't lend
it to anyone.
You know lady scarab.
Blue asked.
You know Lady Scarab?
She replied skeptically.
No, we just, we ran into her, and the
sugar dream.
Early on Luna's metamorphosis day.
She was.
I feel like nice is the wrong word.
But she was sort of fiercely not awful to
us.
That sounds like her, Cricket said
ruefully.
Fiercely not awful.
Blue sensed there was more to cricket's
connection with the old dragon, but she
didn't seem to want to talk about it.
He changed the subject to astronomy.
And they happily discussed constellations
and her theories about other planets
until Blue realized they were reaching
the outskirts of Wasp Hive.
They crested a small hill, and studied
the structures laid out below them.
Wasp Hive was not quite like the other
hives.
It was bigger, for one thing, and the
oldest hive on Pantala, so it was built
in a heavier, more ornate style.
They were carvings of cruel eyed wasps
adorning the entrances, brandishing the
wealth of the hive in their excess wood
and onyx inlays, an enormous marble
statue of Queen Wasp, loomed over the
ground floor doors, so anyone entering
that way would have to pass under her
merciless gaze.
But most dragons would enter at a higher
level.
Blue glanced up at the moonlit webs
twining overhead.
He could see the dark forms of silkwing
family clusters up there. 100s of
sleeping dragons, like stones seen
through water.
Did any of them know about flame silks?
Did any of them help imprison and feed
dragons, like Luna and his father?
And did they hate it every day?
Or was it just a normal job to them?
He wondered if the chrysalis extended
across hives, and whether any of them
were in it.
All around the hive were neatly laid out
rows of enormous greenhouses, at least 30
of them, in concentric circles
surrounding the base of the hive, some
were wild with growth, leaves rioting
against the glass roofs.
Others were quieter, with orderly rows of
vegetables and soil boxes visible
inside.
That many greenhouses, so much glass.
She needed fire to make that glass to
build these, Blue thought.
Fire she took from silk wings, from my
dad.
Flame silk was necessary to everything
the queen did.
She wasn't going to let them go easily.
Soratell landed softly beside them.
The main door is barred for the night, and
possibly guarded inside as well.
There's no way in there.
He tipped his head back to study the
hive.
Let's think.
Could we climb to one of the ledges?
Cricket asked, using the vines and your
silk for blue?
Blue eyed the smooth walls of the hive
uncertainly.
It looked like a much more treacherous
climb than the one out of the sinkhole
and the nearest opening was a very long
way up.
Or, he said slowly, could we hide in one
of the greenhouses?
At least until we know a little more?
That's a good point, Cricket said.
If we go into the hive, we might get
trapped in there, and it might not even
be the right place to look, right?
But if we find a place to hide, tomorrow
I can go in and ask around about where
the flame silks might be.
Blue gave her an alarmed look, by
yourself.
Of course, she said.
You 2 are probably all over the wanted
posters by now, but who cares about me?
I'm just a hive wing, doing normal hive
wing things.
Like suddenly appearing in a hive that's
not your own?
Blue said, asking obvious questions about
the very thing that's got the queen
running dragon hunts all over the
Savannah.
They won't be obvious questions.
Cricket objected.
They will be very subtle.
I am an exceptionally subtle dragon, sir.
Hmm, Blue said dubiously.
Besides, it won't be suspicious because
everyone will be talking about flame
silks right now, she pointed out, and
someone has to know where they are.
Sortell was shaking his head.
That's another day wasted.
He said.
Luna's only going to be in her cocoon 5
days.
We have to find her before she comes out
and before Blue starts his own
metamorphosis.
Blue twitched, startled.
His own metamorphosis.
Thortell was right.
That was... soon.
Very, very soon.
Where am I supposed to have my
metamorphosis if I can't go back to the
cocoon?
And how can I help Luna if I'm stuck
inside my own silk?
I say we storm the hive right now.
Soritell went on, I fly in, start
knocking over guards, Force them to tell
me where she is.
I'd call that a splendid plan, Cricket
said.
If it resembled a plan in any way, You'll
end up on the wasp hive version of
misbehavior's way, before the sun is over
the horizon.
Blue agreed.
And the wasp hive version might be more
like headless corpses way.
Cricket added.
Soretail stamped his feet.
I can't sit around all day again.
We are not sitting around, Cricket said.
We are spying and gathering information
and thinking.
You'd be surprised what a useful step
that is when it comes to plans.
She started down the hill toward the
greenhouses, and the 2 silk wings
followed her.
Sortail grumbling under his breath.
Blue felt guilty for being on Cricket's
side.
Of course, he wanted to rescue Luna just
as much as Swortail did, but he didn't
want to fight any guards, or demand
answers, or rush in all teeth bared.
He kind of wanted to do whatever would
get him in the least trouble.
That would also help Luna.
The greenhouses were all the same size
which was remarkably large, and divided
from one another by neat gravel paths.
Stakes with signs and arrows printed on
them pointed the way to particular types
of plants, and a list was affixed to the
door of each greenhouse.
Carrots, beans, eggplants, on one.
Clementines, limes, on another, papyrus
bamboo, on a third.
They avoided the greenhouses that were
too tidy, where every corner was visible
and headed for the ones that looked the
most overgrown.
These are probably tended every day.
Blue realized. as they walked between the
towering glass walls.
He was starting to feel anxious about his
plan.
Gardeners will come in to water the
plants and find us.
I will bonk them and conk them out
Swordtail declared.
Poor dragons.
Just trying to do their jobs and take
care of some plans.
They don't deserve a day of being knocked
unconscious, plus a massive headache.
Blue thought.
Well, said his brain unexpectedly.
You don't deserve to be chased across the
Savannah, and treated like a mass
murderer.
So perhaps there's a little unfairness to
go around.
He wrinkled his forehead, thinking about
that.
Did their injustice toward him mean that
he'd be justified in hurting them?
He wasn't the kind of dragon who ever
hurt other dragons, but he could imagine
what Luna would say.
You're allowed to fight back.
You should, when the world is like this.
Look, Cricket whispered, pointing to one
of the last greenhouses in the innermost
circle near the back of the hive.
The plant growth inside was dense and
leafy.
But what was even more interesting was
the fact that the door was covered with a
silk spun web barrier.
They crossed to it and read the sign
beside the door.
Do not enter, by order of Queen Wasp
Property of the Queen.
Trespassing punishable by maiming
dismemberment, impaling, and death, in
that order.
Blue lightly tapped the silk with one of
his claws, and the threads vibrated.
This is here, so she'll know if anyone
tries to break in.
Can you recreate it?
Cricket asked Swordtail, from inside?
Seems like a perfect place to hide if no
one can come in here.
Except, you know, Queen Wasp, Blue
pointed out.
Yeah, but she probably won't?
Cricket guest.
This sign is really clear though, Blue
said anxiously.
No trespassing at all.
Maiming, and impaling, and death.
I mean, this science seems to think it's
a really serious rule.
I think keep blue safe from brainwashed
hive wings is a more serious rule.
Cricket said firmly.
Yeah, I can do this, said Swordtail, who'd
been studying the web.
It might not be an exact match, but it
should look convincing enough from a
distance.
As Blue watched nervously.
Swartail carefully dismantled the web
enough for cricket to open the door.
She stepped inside and let out a small
gasp.
It's really hot in here.
She whispered back to them.
How does she keep it this hot?
I have a guess.
Swordtail hissed.
He scowled at the silk spiraling out of
his wrists as he started reweaving the
door cover.
Blue squeezed in behind Cricket, and felt
the humidity hit him, along with several
flapping wet leaves.
It was like walking into a storm cloud.
He glanced down and wondered if the stone
floor was lined with flame silk to keep
it this temperature.
Why do you think Queen Wasp keeps
everyone out of here?
Cricket whispered to him.
Do any of these plants look unusual to
you?
I recognize some of them, but not all of
them.
Huh.
She brushed his shoulder with her wing
and they moved farther into the tangle of
greenery.
That was a good question, Blue realized.
When he hadn't thought about.
Because he was so tangled up in anxiety
about breaking the rules.
What was in here that Queen Wasp wanted
to keep secret?
Why was this place so forbidden?
Now he could see that there were beds of
dirt edged with boulders, and something
like a path between them.
But the plants had grown so wild that
they vaulted over the paths, twined their
branches together, and flung down
curtains of hanging moss and trailing
vines to disrupt any possible order.
He and Cricket had to dock and weave
through the greenery, and he kept getting
his claws snagged on roots and unexpected
runners.
There were flowers everywhere too.
Glorious purple exploding stars.
Delicate pale orange orchids, clusters of
petals, the color of bananas, and odd
little globes and ruby red, and sapphire
blue.
What are these?
Cricket whispered, mostly to herself?
Fingering a vine of bright pink
tendrils.
And those.
Why haven't we studied these?
How did she get these 2 to grow next to
each other?
Whoa.
Is that a new kind of fern?
She wandered ahead, murmuring questions
while Blue stopped to watch a really
surprisingly cute snail, sauntering
slowly up a tree trunk.
Suddenly, Cricket's voice cut off with a
shriek that was quickly muffled.
Blue's head jerked up.
Was Queen Wasp here, inside the
greenhouse?
Had she caught cricket?
He ran after her, stumbling as he fought
through vine tangles, and got smacked in
the face by 80 more large wet leaves.
He had to explain to the queen that none
of this was Cricket's fault.
He had to turn himself in.
He pushed through a curtain of moss, and
felt himself seized by strong claws.
They threw him to the floor, flipped him
onto his back. and tied all his talons
together before he could even blink.
He opened his mouth to yell for cricket.
And another vine immediately looped
around his snout, snapping his jaw shut.
It felt as if barely a moment had passed
but there he was, lying on the ground
completely helpless.
Blue craned his neck to look for cricket
and spotted her, tied up the same way he
was, and propped against a tree.
Standing over her, was a wiry, dark green
dragon.
So, not Queen Wasp, he thought.
Could that be the silk wing who covers
the door for her?
He tried to twist around to see his own
attacker, and realized there were 3 of
them all together.
All of them had scales and shades of dark
green, and they were all poised and
waiting to catch Swordtail, who was
blundering toward the noise Blue and
Cricket had made.
And then.
Blue noticed something.
Their captors.
They had 2 wings each, not four.
Long, graceful, swooping wings, shaped
like leaves.
Chapter 17.
Leaf wings.
They weren't extinct.
They were here.
In Queen Wasp's greenhouse, attacking
dragons, real actual leaf wings.
The posters were right.
I should alert a hive wing authority
immediately, Blue thought, feeling a
little hysterical.
But I can't, because they'll arrest me.
But Leaf Wings, this close to Wasp Hive.
He tried to grunt loudly to warn
Swordtail, but it didn't do any good.
The trio of leaf wings moved with a
ruthless efficiency.
And within a few heartbeats, Swordtail
was tied up next to blue, blinking with
similar bewilderment.
Are there any more?
One of them asked.
I'll check, said another, and he quietly
melted off into the trees.
There was a long moment of silence.
Blue glanced over at cricket again.
She was watching the leaf wings with the
same wide eyed expression she'd had when
she saw the reading monkey in the cave.
This is not an exciting scientific
discovery cricket.
He wanted to shout.
These are very dangerous dragons.
The leaf wings had tried to wipe out both
their tribes in the last war.
Wasn't she deathly afraid of them?
He tried to look at the leaf wings with
cricket's eyes.
Maybe he would be less scared that way.
Maybe he just needed to see them as
fascinating and unusual, instead of
deadly and really extremely deadly.
The 2 that had stayed were both female
and their faces were similar enough that
he wondered if they were related.
The one standing by cricket looked no
older than he was, about 6 years old.
Although he had no idea if leaf wings
grew differently than silk wings.
Small gold scales were speckled along the
edges of her wings and talons, and across
her snout, crinkled up in her scowl.
The other one was a lot older and
bigger.
With an air of authority about her that
made Blue instinctively want to hide, or
say he was sorry, or both.
Her scales were lighter green with
patches of brown.
And she had strange, pale burn scars
splattered across her talons and up her
forearms.
Her scowl was also pretty terrifying.
Both dragons had several small pouches
hung about them, woven from long grass, or
fashioned from leaves, Blue wondered what
was inside, but had a sinking feeling
that he would regret finding out.
What are they thinking?
He wondered.
The matching scows were a pretty good
clue that whatever it was, the general
sentiment was hostile.
How long have they been here?
What are they here for?
Are they glad they caught us?
Or annoyed that we stumbled into their
hiding place?
Most important?
What are they going to do with us?
The leaves rustled, and the male leaf
wing returned.
He was a green, dark enough to disappear
into shadows, and wore a small white
seashell on a cord around his neck.
He shook his head at the others.
No one else.
Good, said the older female.
Did they break the web on the door?
Yes, he said, but rebuilt it.
Useful of them, she said.
Huh, Blue thought, momentarily distracted
from his panic.
How did the leaf wings get in?
They can't spin silk, so they couldn't
have covered the door themselves.
Could.
Could Queen Wasp know they're here?
He doubted that.
Queen Wasp hated leaf wings for refusing
to accept her rule.
Why would she keep 3 of them stashed in a
greenhouse?
Across from him, Cricket flicked her tail
trying to get the smaller leaf wings
attention, but the scowling dragonette
ignored her.
The tall female, who seemed to be the
leader of the group, scanned her 3
captives with calculating green eyes.
At last, she stepped forward and yanked
the rope off Blue's snout.
Ow he yelped.
Who are you?
she demanded, and what are you doing
here?
She jerked her head at cricket.
Two silk wings with a hive wing?
Do you work for her?
No, Blue said.
She's my friend.
The youngest leaf wing let out a scornful
laugh, but Blue's interrogator looked
intrigued.
Hive wings don't befriend Silk Wings, she
said.
They control you.
They enslave you.
They order you about.
But then, that's what you signed up for
isn't it?
I, um, Blue said, I didn't sign up for
anything, I think.
True, said the male leaf wing.
Too young.
Don't be so literal, hemlock.
The leader scoffed.
You, tell me your names.
I'm blue, he said, and that's cricket.
And that's.
He trailed off as he turned to Sortail
and bound him furiously shaking his
head.
Ah, someone else.
Trying to keep secrets won't do any good
at this point.
The leaf wing said.
I only see 2 ways for this to end, with
you all helping us, or dead.
In the former case, it'll be much easier
if we know your names.
Or we could skip to the latter case right
now.
Sortell growled, and the little leaf wing
bared her teeth at him.
What?
What are your names?
Blue tried, thinking that was
astonishingly brave of him.
The leaf wing smiled slightly.
I'm Belladonna, and that's Hemlock.
Our daughter is sundew.
Why would you tell them that?
Sundew snapped in a burst of fury.
They can't help us.
They'll turn us in the moment they get a
chance.
We should kill them now and leave their
corpses somewhere that'll really scare
those worms in the hive.
She lifted one of her wings and pulled a
fiery red centipede out of a pouch.
It flailed violently at the air, waving
all its feet and hissing.
Sundew, Belladonna said warningly, save
that for later.
Corpses lying around will notify the
queen we're here, which would make our
mission harder, remember?
Sundew dropped the centipede back into
its pouch.
Her scowl deepened.
Besides, Blue said, killing us would
probably make the queen very happy.
And I think maybe you don't want to do
that?
Belladonna narrowed her eyes at him.
The queen wants you dead.
Why?
Well, he said, but he'd never been a good
liar, and he couldn't come up with
anything fast enough, and he didn't know
what the right thing to say might be.
So he went with the truth.
She wants me locked up, in case I'm a
flame silk.
He held out his wrists, which looked as
ordinary as ever, other than being
covered in flaking paint.
And she probably wants sore tailed dead
because he attacked some guards to save
my sister.
And then he escaped cicada hive.
Cricket.
She doesn't know about cricket yet.
I hope.
But if she did, she'd be mad because
cricket's been helping us hide from her.
A helpful hive wing?
Belladonna said thoughtfully.
She regarded cricket in a way that made
Blue think of quicksand. and crawler
vines at midnight.
That does sound like a useful dragon to
know.
Sounds like a bunch of 4 winged lies
sundew spat.
If Queen Wasp wanted you locked up, you'd
be locked up.
Not necessarily.
She wants your whole tribe dead, and
apparently you're, uh, not all that
dead.
Blue pointed out.
By the way, how are you not dead?
Are there a lot of you left?
Where have you been living?
None of your business.
Sundew hissed.
As if we tell you anything.
Tree killers.
Blue thought, startled.
What an awful name.
Was that how Leaf Wings saw the other 2
tribes?
Of course, it must be.
After all.
That's what we did.
Even the silk wings, though?
The silk wings only cut down trees under
orders.
Mostly they stayed out of the way as much
as they could.
But if I were a leaf wing, all I would
see is hive wings destroying my home and
silk wings helping, or standing by.
If you are trying to hide from Queen Wasp
Belladonna interjected, what are you
doing in her greenhouse?
Blue hesitated again.
Sortel was shaking his head so hard, Blue
thought it might topple right off his
neck.
But so what if these leaf wings knew
about Luna?
The longer he talked, the longer they all
stayed alive.
And maybe if he explained, and promised
not to tell anyone they'd seen the leaf
wings, Belladonna would decide to let
them go.
After all, it had to be pretty clear that
he and his friends wouldn't be talking to
Queen Wasp or any hive wing guards
anytime soon.
We're looking for my sister, he said.
She's a flame silk, and Queen Wasp took
her.
We think she's keeping all the flame silk
somewhere around here.
Belladonna, hemlock, and sundew, all
glanced at one another, suddenly alert.
Bats, sundew started.
Yes, Hemlock answered.
Ah ha, said Belladonna.
What?
Blue asked.
What aha.
It seems, Belladonna said, taking a step
closer to him, that we can be of use to
one another after all.
We.
Can?
You see, Belladonna went on.
We know where the flame silks are.
Blues jaw dropped.
Cricket sat up, her ears twitching and
her eyes bright.
Even sore tail looked suddenly more
excited than worried.
Where are they?
Blue asked.
Did you see a new cocoon there?
Was it all right?
We can take you to their prison
Belladonna said.
We can even help you sneak in to rescue
your sister.
You just have to do one thing for us
first.
Blue's heart sank.
Whatever the leaf wings wanted, it
couldn't be good, or safe, or smart.
I won't hurt anyone, he said.
You don't have to.
Belladonna said, with her quicksand
smile.
We are not here to attack the hive, or
fight any dragons, no matter what your
queen's propaganda says about us.
We are here for one little thing.
And since we've been having quite a lot
of trouble figuring out how to accomplish
our goal, I think you've come along just
in the nick of time, a desperate silk
wing, and a helpful hive wing are just
what we need.
For what?
Blue asked.
What do you want us to do?
If you want our help finding your
sister?
Belladonna said smoothly.
All you have to do is steal the book of
clear sight for us.
Chapter 18.
Blue felt a reverent shiver run through
him, even thinking the words book of
clear sight.
He'd spent a 100 nights lying in his
hammock, gazing up at the silk shrouded
stars, and imagining what it had been
like to be her.
The greatest seer who ever lived, the
wisest of dragons, grandmother to an
entire tribe.
The legends said Clearsight had been able
to see the future.
But not just one future, all the possible
futures.
She had used that power to keep the
tribes safe during her lifetime.
They had survived hurricanes, forest
fires, and a malevolent princess or four
thanks to Clearsight.
Her children and grandchildren and great
grandchildren were protected from every
danger, growing strong and powerful, and
more numerous as the years went on.
Then.
When Clearsight saw her peaceful death
approaching, she left one last gift for
her descendants, a book that foretold the
future.
It warned them about everything in the
years to come.
The lightning strike that sheared away
part of the sea cliff, the population
explosion of sharks in the bay.
The possible spread of a devastating bark
disease in the forest.
Clear sight wrote it all down.
Centuries of warnings, so that she could
continue to protect her beloved hive wing
children, even long after her death.
The book of Clearsight, was the hive
wing's greatest treasure.
It was the reason they were the most
powerful tribe in Pentala.
Queen Wasp had used it to defeat the leaf
wings in the war.
It made her invincible.
And surely, Blue thought.
Cold tentacles trailing through his
mind.
Surely, it included warnings about any
dragons stupid enough to try to steal it
from her.
She might even know they were here right
now.
I know, Belladonna said, studying his
face.
I thought the same thing, but we've made
it this far.
And we've been hiding in her own
greenhouse for 4 days without anyone
showing up to capture us.
If the book has warned her about us, she
hasn't bothered to do anything about it
yet, Hemlock added impassively, Belladonna
shot him a look, we don't need them
Sundew cried.
I can steal the book of Clearsight by
myself.
You can't even get near the front door by
yourself.
Belladonna observed.
Neither can we, Blue said.
We're no use to your plan.
We're wanted fugitives.
She isn't, Hemlock said.
Flicking one clawed cricket.
That was true.
Cricket could.
But cricket was shaking her head.
Blue's small flame of hope spluttered
out.
Of course she would say no.
He couldn't blame her.
She'd never even met Luna.
She wouldn't risk her tribe's entire
future to save a silk wing she didn't
know.
Helping a pathetic dragon hide from
hunters was one thing, an exciting
adventure, complete with anti paralysis
smoke, and reading monkeys.
Stealing the book of Clearsight, though?
That was an unforgivable crime.
She'd be betraying her whole tribe, not
just her queen.
No, Belladonna growled, suddenly
furious.
She darted across to cricket, and seized
the hive wing's jaw in her talons.
You don't say no to me, Hivewing.
You have no right.
After everything your tribe has done to
our homes and our dragons.
Don't hurt her.
Blue cried.
He tried to pull his talons free, but
they were bound tightly.
Look, can't you understand why she'd
refuse?
She wants to protect her tribe, same as
you.
You say you're not here to hurt anyone.
But then what are you planning to do with
a book once you have it?
Belladonna hissed in Cricket's face and
shoved her away.
All we want to do is level the wind
currents.
She spat.
Do you really think it's fair that the
hive wings have had this secret knowledge
for so long, that they've abused it to
dominate and destroy other tribes?
Do you think that's what your precious
clear site intended?
Cricket looked down at her feet.
Blinking rapidly.
Queen Wasp, has already read the whole
thing, Belladonna went on.
She probably even has a copy somewhere
unless she's an idiot.
We just want to read it too.
Then we'll all know the same things.
We'll have the same advance information.
The leaf wings won't have anything more
than what the hive wings have had for
generations. equality.
That's what we're looking for.
Seems only fair.
Hemlock agreed.
But, um, Blue said nervously.
But then won't you use that information
to attack the hives?
Belladonna's eyes glittered.
That depends on what the book says.
Stop being so nosy.
Sundew said fiercely.
Her talent twitched toward one of her
pouches, but whatever was in there.
She stopped herself from bringing it
out.
Either you help us or you die.
It's very simple.
Blue glanced at SwordTail.
He could see instantly that SwordTail was
fine with his plan.
He'd be happy to help even leaf wings if
it meant saving Luna, and he didn't care
what happened to the hive wings
afterward.
But cricket.
This was too much to ask.
And yet, the truth was, it would be
impossible to pull off without her.
Blue closed his eyes and took a deep
breath.
I need to talk to my friends, he said.
Give us some time to think about it.
To think about it?
Sundoo growled.
She picked up a fallen branch and started
snapping it into jagged splinters.
Arrr.
You have until midday, Belladonna said
beckoning to her daughter.
Then, we start formulating our plan.
She turned and disappeared into the
leaves, with sundew stomping furiously
along behind her.
Hemlock untied the vine around sore
tail's snout, then stepped across and did
the same for cricket.
He paused, as the vine dropped away, and
met Cricket's eyes.
Choose wisely, he said to her.
And then he, too, slipped away into the
foliage.
Blue looked up.
This section was so overgrown, that he
couldn't see the walls or the ceiling of
the greenhouse.
It was like they were in a cave made of
leaves.
But he could tell from their bright green
color leeching into the plants that the
sun was rising outside.
He wondered if hunters were out already
looking for him.
Had anyone noticed cricket was missing
yet?
He rocked himself onto his side. and
scooted awkwardly over the rocky ground
until he was next to her.
She gave him a half hearted smile, and
nudged his neck with her nose.
I'm sorry.
He said to her, I'm really, really sorry
I dragged you into this.
Cricket looked very surprised.
Did you?
She said.
I am pretty sure I dragged myself into it
or leaped into it, with all 4 feet and
all 4 wings.
I might have been yelling, wee adventure
in my head, if I didn't say that out
loud.
Well, maybe, he said, but you couldn't
have expected this.
Neither could you, she pointed out
reasonably.
Being captured by leaf wings?
It's kind of amazing, isn't it?
I can't believe they're still alive.
Where have they been all this time?
I must say they're a little more
belligerent than I would have imagined.
She moved her jaw from side to side
wincing.
Really?
Blue said.
We were taught that leaf wings would kill
us on site.
So to me, it seems quite friendly of them
to postpone killing us until later.
Cricket gave them a rueful smile.
Is there any chance they won't kill us at
all?
she asked.
Maybe if we help them, Blue said, or get
away from them somehow.
Blue glanced across at Sortail, who was
flailing around on the ground, trying to
bite away the vines binding his talons.
Um, sore tail, he said.
What do you think?
I think they're listening to us.
Sortell growled, so it's no use trying to
make any escape plans.
True.
Belladonna's voice called from somewhere
up in the branches.
But I think we should help them, so I
tell said.
They have a point.
The hive wings did destroy all their
trees.
Queen Wasp used the book's knowledge to
nearly wipe them out.
So why shouldn't they get to see the
book?
I don't care.
As long as they take us to Luna.
The only thing I'm not sure of is whether
we can trust them to help us, after we do
what they want.
You can, Belladonna's voice called
again.
Of course you can.
You ungrateful Beatles.
Sundew yelled from somewhere else.
We are not lying conniving hive wings.
We're leaf wings.
We are honorable.
If you want to be in this conversation
Blue shouted, just come back and be in it
already.
There was a moment of wrestling silence.
No, no, said Belladonna's voice.
Carry on. pretend we're not here.
Sortail snorted.
Well, I'm worried.
Blue said to Swordtail.
First of all, I'm sure it's impossible to
steal the book.
Secondly, even if we could, giving it to
a tribe who tried to wipe us all out once
upon a time, seems like maybe a bad
idea.
That's not what we, Sundew bellowed.
Shh.
Paladonna hushed her.
We're leaving anyway, aren't we?
Sortell said.
We can't ever go home.
You and me and Luna and IO if we can find
her.
And you too, if you want to come, he said
to Cricket.
We'll have to find a new place to live.
Far away from Wasp, and the hives, and
all her zombie hordes.
So why should we care what happens to her
or them after we're gone?
We'll be safe, far away from here.
But what about everyone else?
Blue asked.
Burn it and Silverspot?
Your parents, all the dragons we went to
school with.
All our teachers, Cricket's sister.
Don't you care about any of them?
Soretail coiled his tail in close and
spread his wings.
I care about Luna, he said.
That's it.
Blue couldn't imagine that was true.
Blue cared about all of them.
Every dragon he'd ever spoken to, and all
the ones he'd never seen.
There were dragons out there eating
blueberries, and dragons laughing at
clumsy tiger cubs, and dragons learning
to dance, and dragons crying as though
their hearts would break over missing
homework.
He'd been all of them in some way.
And he couldn't just toss them into the
talons of these angry, vengeful dragons
and fly off.
He turned back to cricket.
She'd managed to snap off a twig from the
bush behind her, holding it between her
teeth and passing it to her bound
talons.
She caught Blue's eye, and tapped the
dirt with his stick.
I'm not sure we have a choice, she said
out loud.
Awkwardly, she wrote, Pretend to agree.
Escape later.
Blue tilted his head at her.
Could they do that?
Say yes to the Leaf Wings plan?
Agreed to go after the book, and then run
off once they were inside the hive?
They wouldn't have the leaf wings help to
find Luna.
But with luck, they could find her
themselves.
It felt underhanded.
He didn't like lying to anyone, or
breaking promises.
Of course, he didn't love stealing
priceless artifacts either.
It's like Sundew said, right?
Cricket went on.
We do what they want, or they'll kill
us.
I won't let them kill you.
Blue said.
Something like a, ha. came from the
direction of sundew's voice, followed by
a shh, and the sound of a scuffle.
Cricket tapped her message again, watching
him significantly.
Let's hear their plan, she said.
If stealing the book means helping your
sister and not dying, I can do that.
They are right that Queen Wasp and the
librarian already know everything that's
in it anyway.
Soratel had given up on untying his vines
and lay in an undignified heap on the
path, frowning at them.
From his angle.
Blue was pretty sure Sortell couldn't
read what cricket had written.
But it didn't matter.
Once they were away from the leaf wings
he'd explain, and Sortail would
understand.
Sounds like we're all in agreement
Swordtail said.
Blue sighed and leaned forward to brush
away Cricket's message.
All right, he called.
We'll steal the book of Clearside for
you.
Chapter 19.
Cricket's plan began to fall apart
immediately.
In the 1st place, the leaf wings were
adamant that sundew had to go with them
to sneak into the temple.
What?
Cricket said.
How?
There's no way to get her through the
hive unnoticed.
The 1st guard who spots her will kill
her.
In fact, any hive wing who sees her would
probably do the same.
It's true.
Blue agreed.
They are terrifying posters about you
everywhere.
We've been working on that, Belladonna
said.
Blue couldn't help thinking she seemed
remarkably unconcerned about sending her
daughter into danger.
The tall leaf wing produced a pair of
leaves that were similar in shape to the
2nd smaller pair of wings on a silk
wing.
Sundew stood still, shooting daggers at
cricket with her eyes, while Belladonna
and Hemlock fastened the fake wings below
and behind her real ones.
Using a system of rigging them with vine
ties under sundew's many pouches.
No flying.
Hemlock said sternly. touching sundew's
snout.
But as long as she keeps her wings folded
it should be convincing enough inside the
hive, Belladonna said, walking up to the
guards outside, in sunlight, with plenty
of opportunity for them to watch her
coming, that was the part we were having
trouble with.
She smiled at cricket, a smile that went
nowhere near her eyes.
That's where you come in.
She's still very green and leafy looking
cricket protested.
Even her real wings look like leaves, and
she's so green.
Blue.
There aren't any silk wings that green
are there?
He spent a moment trying to remember all
the green silk wings he knew before he
realized that cricket wanted him to say
oh no, never that green.
We can fix that too.
Sundu said spiritedly.
She dumped out one of her pouches, sending
a rainstorm of flower petals to the
ground.
Without choosing carefully.
She grabbed a scarlet flower and rubbed
it on her shoulder, leaving a patch of
reddish green.
Let me, hemlock said, gently taking the
flower out of her talons.
He sorted the pedals quickly into piles
by color, then started applying rubbings
of yellow, red, and blue in an even
pattern.
Cricket watched skeptically, but Blue was
fairly impressed.
It wasn't as thorough as the paint
cricket had put on him, but it did make
sundew look much less like a leaf wing by
the time hemlock was done.
Although maybe not quite a silk wing.
She looked a little too furious to be a
real silk wing, and the combination of
colors wasn't exactly beautiful.
The belladonna might be right.
It was at least possible now that Sundew
could pass through the corridors of Wasp
Hive without getting caught.
Wait, that's bad, he remembered.
We want to leave her behind.
We'll never be able to escape with her
watching us.
But there was no way to convince the leaf
wings without raising their suspicions.
And then it got worse.
These 2 stay behind with us, Belladonna
said, pointing to blue and sword tail.
No way.
Swordtail blurted.
Cricket folded back her wings and lifted
her chin.
I'm not going without them, she said.
I won't do it.
I don't trust you.
And I don't trust you, hive wing, said
Belladonna, which is exactly why they're
staying where I can keep an eye on them.
You can have them back when I have the
book.
No, Cricket said, standing her ground.
I can't do this alone.
You'll have sun do, Belladonna pointed
out.
Yeah, Sundew said, you'll have me.
That's like the opposite of being alone.
I can do anything 20 dragons can do.
I need my friends, Cricket said firmly.
Belladonna and Hemlock exchanged a long
thoughtful look.
Finally, Hemlock said, just one.
Both, said Cricket.
One, said Belladonna.
Choose which?
Or we'll kill one of them and make your
choice very easy.
Cricket hesitated.
Blue felt awful for her.
How could they all escape if one of them
was stuck in the greenhouse, but there
wasn't anything she could do.
He could see that.
Lou.
Cricket said, in a subdued voice, I'll
take Blue.
You should take sword tail, he said.
He's a better fighter than me, if things
go bad.
I assume that's what she's for.
Cricket said, nodding at Sundew.
I really want you to come with me, Blue.
Please?
He realized that she was scared.
Maybe even more scared than he was.
She had gotten into this for him, and she
felt safer with him than Swordtail, who
she barely knew, and who had a tendency
to say mean things about hive wings.
Blue was afraid he'd be more than useless
to her.
But if she wanted him, he'd go to the
ends of Penthala, or anywhere she asked.
Of course, he said.
Maybe they'd have a chance to slip away
from Sundew.
Maybe they'd come up with a way to save
Swordtail and get out of this, even if he
couldn't think of any solutions right
now.
Hemlock cut them loose, and let Cricket
use some of the flower dye to cover the
spots where Blue's real colors were
showing through.
The result was lopsided and weird looking
like he had some kind of scale disease
where bits of him were flaking off.
But maybe that would make other dragons
especially hive wings, keep their
distance from him.
The day felt endless.
And yet it was alarmingly soon when
Belladonna said, It's dusk, time to go.
Blue took one of SoraTail's talons in his
and squeezed.
We'll come back for you, he said.
I know, Swartell said, with the book.
I know you can do it.
How do I tell him we're only pretending?
Blue thought desperately.
How do I warn him he needs to escape?
There was no way.
Hemlock was standing next to him, watching
them like a hawk.
Right, Blue said.
See you soon, swordtail.
Sundew led them through the tangled
greenery to the back of the greenhouse
facing away from the hive.
Carefully, she tapped on a pane of the
glass wall.
Then wedged her claws in the cracks
around the edges, and levered it out.
Oh, Cricket said.
I wondered what you did to get in.
Oh dear, isn't that going to be bad for
the plans?
I don't care 2 frogs about the plants.
Sundew snapped.
Go on.
Cricket ducked through the opening.
As Blue crouched to follow her, he saw
Belladonna poke sundew between the
shoulders so she'd stand more upright.
Make us proud, she said to her daughter
do not fail.
Remember, this is what you were hatched
to do.
Remember how evil they are.
Let your rage carry you.
Yes, Belladonna, Sundew said firmly, I
will not fail.
And then Blue was outside, on one of the
neat paths, standing next to cricket
under a whale gray sky.
Low clouds blotted out the moons, and
most of the stars.
The rainy season was definitely upon
them.
Sundew emerged a moment later, sliding
the glass back into place behind her.
They slipped silently between the
greenhouses, Waving toward the front of
Wasp Hive.
As they got closer, Sundew held up one
talon to stop them, then darted to the
next corner and peered out at the hive
entrance.
Two guards.
She whispered, then this should work.
She dug into a pouch, and carefully
pulled out a wooden box, which she opened
to reveal a flower the size of a stingray
and the color of moonlight.
Take this, she said to Cricket, carefully
do not crush any part of it until you get
close to the guards.
Then make them look at it, and smash it
under their noses.
What will it do?
Cricket asked, eyeing the beautiful white
bloom.
Is it poisonous?
Where did it come from?
I don't want to poison anyone.
It won't poison them.
Sundew said impatiently.
It'll just knock them out for a while.
Don't you inhale it though, or you'll be
useless to us.
Cricket held the flower as far away from
her as she could, took a deep breath, and
stepped out of the cluster of
greenhouses.
She moved slowly, cautiously hobbling on
3 legs, so she could hold the flower up
in one talon with infinite gentleness.
It hit blue suddenly, that this was a
dangerous turning point for cricket.
Up until now.
She hadn't been seen with the fugitives.
She could have returned home at any
moment, slipping back into her ordinary
life with a shrug, and an excuse about
mind control and hunting, or something
like that.
But now she was facing real hive wing
guards, who were likely to remember her.
Whatever happened next, Cricket would be
in trouble.
Probably really bad trouble.
I'm so sorry, cricket.
Blue thought mournfully.
I wish.
His thoughts trailed off.
He couldn't say, I wish we hadn't met.
Because that was the furthest thing from
the truth.
He wished she was safe.
That was all.
Both guards leaped to their feet when
they saw her approaching.
Halt.
One of the guards called.
Cricket stopped where she was, halfway to
the door, and the guards started
whispering to each other.
Blue glanced over at Sundew, who was
watching with tension humming from every
bone in her body.
She looked ready to sprint out there and
stab the guards.
If they so much as sneezed funny.
So, he said to her, your mother said you
were hatched for this.
What's that all about?
Sundew looked over her shoulder at him
incredulously.
Are you seriously making small talk with
me right now?
No, he protested.
That wasn't small talk.
That was big talk.
Actual talk?
I actually want to know, I mean.
It's nothing mystical, Sundew growled.
She wanted a daughter to carry on our
family's legacy.
She trained me my whole life for one
purpose.
This.
Stealing the book of Clear Side.
She narrowed her eyes and paused for a
moment.
Sure.
That didn't sound like the whole story
but now the guards were calling cricket
forward again.
Who are you?
one of them asked.
Why weren't you back by curfew?
And what have you got there?
asked the other.
I found something amazing.
Cricket said.
The queen will want to see it right
away.
It was hard to hear her from here.
Her voice was much quieter than the
guards.
Blue strained to listen.
Unless it's a map to that blasted flame
silk.
She's going to bite your head off, said
the 1st guard.
I tried the librarian 1st if I were you
little dragon.
She likes unusual things.
And she's a bit less murdery than the
Queen, agreed the 2nd guard, smiling.
Blue felt a sharp twist of guilt.
These guards were so friendly.
And they were going to be in so much
trouble if Blue and sundew got into the
hive, and Queen Wasp found out.
Would they lose their jobs?
Or would their punishment be even worse?
He worried at one of his claws.
Why did it have to be such nice friendly
guards in their way?
A voice in his head that sounded like
Luna whispered, maybe they're only
friendly, because they're talking to a
hive wing.
Have you ever seen a guard be that nice
to a silk wing?
Did you even know they could smile?
These same guards might have been out for
the last 3 days hunting you.
They might have been in a unit that came
to shove me in a cage.
They might spend their other shifts
poking flame silks with spears to make
them burn faster.
Blue shivered, trying to shake off the
voice.
So what is it?
The 1st guard asked, craning his neck as
cricket approached.
Isn't it beautiful?
she said.
And it smells like nothing I've ever
smelled before.
She held out the flower between the 2
guards, so they both leaned in to sniff
it.
And then Cricket squeezed her claws shut
crushing the pedals in her grip.
Blue couldn't see exactly when it hit
them, but a moment later, the guards
crumpled to the ground.
One of them hit his head on the hive wall
as he fell, and cricket flinched, reaching
toward him too late.
She crouched over him, folding in his
blade wings and checking his pulse.
The prolescent flower lay where she'd
dropped it on the dirt, its edges brown
and wrinkled now.
Sundew sprinted toward the entrance, and
Blue scrambled to follow her.
Leave them.
Sundew snapped at cricket.
I don't know how much they got, or how
long it'll last.
If I were you, I would have shoved it
right up their snouts.
Well, I wasn't going to do that.
Cricket said crossly.
And it worked fine, didn't it?
What kind of flower is that?
Is it related to nightshade?
Blue bent over the 2nd guard?
surreptitiously making sure she was
alive.
She was, and that she'd fallen in a
comfortable position.
Sundew strode on without waiting, and
both cricket and blue had to jump up and
run after her, under the malevolent gaze
of the giant queen wasp statue.
The ground level doors to the hive were
massive and ostentatiously made of wood
with wasps carved all over them, and a
profile of the queen on each side.
Sundoo paused in front of one for a
moment, then reached up and raked her
claws across the queen's elegant snout
leaving splintery furrows in the wood.
That was unnecessary, Cricket protested.
You ruined a really nice carving.
Wait until I get to her actual face.
Sundew snarled.
She yanked the door open a crack and
peeked through.
Then shoved it a little farther and
squeezed herself through the gap.
Blue and Cricket went next, spilling out
onto the streets of Wasp Hive's lowest
level.
What they saw was a deserted street of
warehouses, rows and rows of blocky
buildings, each a perfect beige cube
reaching from floor to ceiling, with one
large door.
Storage, blue guest, although of what
exactly he wasn't sure.
Each door was marked with a symbol, all
of which were unfamiliar to him.
He only had a moment to think about it
because sundew had already started up the
path that led to the next level.
Blue ran after her and caught her
shoulder.
What?
she snapped.
Let cricket go first. he said, and walk
like a normal silk wing.
We don't charge around with, I have
somewhere to be and someone to set on
fire faces.
Even if your disguise was way better than
it is.
Walking and scowling like that, will get
you caught in a heartbeat.
Fine. she said, fuming.
Show me how you walk.
Blue turned to cricket.
Have you been here before?
He asked her.
Do you know where the temple is?
Yes, she said.
My class visited the temple last year, and
my dad took me a couple of times.
It's up in the center of the hive.
He nodded and stepped back so she could
lead the way.
Then he ducked his head and trailed after
her, looking as harmless and
inconspicuous as he could.
Sundew fell into step beside him, growling
and muttering under her breath.
Tuck your chin a little more.
Blue suggested softly, keep your eyes on
the ground.
Don't look directly at any hive wings.
Try not to make any noise.
She hissed at him.
You're just like I always pictured Silk
Wings, she spat.
Subservient worms.
He stopped midstab and frowned at her.
We are not, he said.
We're pacifists, yes, and we follow the
rules, but it's kept us alive, hasn't
it?
There's a lot more silk wings left in the
world than leaf wings, I bet.
He added hurriedly, since he wasn't
actually sure.
Up until this morning, he'd have guessed
the number of leaf wings left was zero.
But he must have been right, because she
spun and glared at him.
If you'd been willing to fight with us
we'd all still be alive.
Or we'd all be dead, he pointed out.
The significantly more likely scenario.
I don't know why Willow wants to save
your tribe.
Sundew snapped.
You're as much of a problem as the hive
wings, with your nodding and smiling, and
agreeing to let them trample all over
you.
I'd throw you all into the sea if it were
up to me.
Cricket came back around the bend in the
tunnel.
Can we try to be a little more quiet?
She said.
We'll be at their residential levels
soon.
Which meant more dragons around, and more
hive wings who might overhear sundew and
blue arguing.
He bit back everything he wanted to say
to the leaf wing and hurried after
cricket, walking like he normally did
around hive wings, which was a perfectly
fine way to walk, he thought, in that it
kept you out of trouble, and it was
polite, and with sundue right?
Was he confusing obedience and good
behavior, with letting the hive wings
trample all over him?
What else was I supposed to do exactly?
He wondered.
Stare right at hive wings, speak up, pick
fights, end up on misbehaviors way all
the time, like sore tail.
I don't like being yelled at.
Acting the way I do has been a good way
to avoid that.
Wasp Hive was constructed much like
cicada hive, but bigger, with wider
hallways and tunnels, and higher ceilings
on each level.
The walls of the tunnels were painted
with black and yellow stripes, or 6 sided
honeycomb patterns, alternating by level
weavings and posters of queen wasp, glared
at them around every bend.
The tunnels became busier as they
ascended, and blue drew closer to cricket
with a nervous jittering in his chest.
They passed a family of hive wings
arguing over where to go for dinner, a
silk wing carrying a basket of clean
blankets, a pair of hive wings, singing
and teasing each other about getting the
words wrong.
Everyone seemed so normal.
Their lives were carrying on, despite
days spent under the queen's mind
control.
A few of them nodded politely at cricket
but nobody even glanced at blue or
sundew.
And then cricket slowed down, flicking
her wings back as she stepped out of the
tunnels and onto a polished floor made of
real wood, not tree stuff.
Blue bit back at gasp as he followed her
onto the smooth surface.
It gleamed in waves of gold and amber and
brown, all the way across the vast space
in front of them, to the foot of the
temple of Clearsight.
Chapter 20.
Blue had read that the temple of
Clearside was the most beautiful
structure in the world.
He knew that it had been built by
Clearsight's grandchildren, then
partially destroyed 100s of years later
during the war with the leaf wings, and
then moved to be reconstructed here in
the heart of Wasp Hive, where it could be
kept safe.
Books had told him that it was made of 60
different kinds of wood, all polished and
painstakingly fitted together, so it
looked like a perfect miracle.
But books couldn't describe the feeling
of peace that hit him when he saw it.
The temple wasn't an enormous towering
structure, as he'd always imagined.
It was no bigger than the cocoon, but
built with elegant balance and graceful
proportions.
The columns that lined the front of it
were of a wood so dark, it was almost
black, embedded with tiny flecks of
quartz that looked like distant stars.
The roof swept into dragon tell points at
each corner, and a central dome was
covered in curved golden wood tiles that
looked like scales.
It sat quietly in the center of the vast
wooden courtyard, surrounded by
reflecting pools, and little nooks lined
with bookshelves.
Even at this hour, blue saw few dragons
curled here and there on a bench, beside
a pool, on a bamboo mat between shelves
all of them reading.
Tiny flame silk lanterns glowed beside
them, a few floated on the water of the
pools, and others hung from the rafters
of the temple.
Another light glowed on the dome, and
when Blue looked up, he realized there
was a skylight overhead that pierced all
the levels all the way up to the top of
the hive.
In the distance.
He could see the stars, and the corner of
one of the moons shining down on the
temple.
It must be covered with glass to keep the
reins out, but it was kept so clean it
looked like a direct hole to the sky.
The effect was somewhere between magic
library and peace garden.
And Blue found himself consumed with
sadness, that he'd never been here
before.
And most likely would never be able to
come here again.
He wished he could live like these hive
wings, with this place at his claw tips
every day.
He wished he could work for the librarian
taking care of the temple and all these
books, sweeping the floors and feeding
the coy, and keeping it beautiful, and
never getting yelled at by angry leaf
wings, or chased by angry queen zombies.
Instead, he was here to destroy this
peaceful place by stealing the one thing
it was built around.
They walked toward the temple as quietly
as they could, a long carpet of dark blue
silk stretched toward the temple door and
muffled their talon steps.
Golden dragonflies and green lizards, were
woven in a subtle pattern through the
carpet.
It was more beautiful than even Blue's
favorite cocoon weavings, and it felt
impossibly ancient.
He glanced sideways at sundew, to see if
the aura of the temple had calmed her
down at all.
She caught him looking and hurried to
scowl back onto her face.
Don't you think it's amazing?
He whispered.
No, she whispered back ferociously.
She waved her tail at the carvings around
them.
How many trees had to die to make this
place?
He didn't answer.
He felt in his bones that the temple was
worth everything it took to make it.
But he could also imagine how hard it was
for some do, mourning the vast forests of
trees that used to cover Pentala.
Queen Wasp and the hive wings had
destroyed all of that.
Not just the leaf wings homes, but the
spirits of the trees they'd clearly loved
too.
Two hive wing guards stood on either side
of the arched temple door, holding long
spears.
Blue felt panic stirring in his chest.
He tapped Cricket's wing and she paused
turning back to him.
Sundu and I don't have wristbands, he
said softly.
These guards.
I think they'll notice.
Cricket nodded, as though he'd drawn her
attention to an interesting fish.
She strolled off the carpet path and over
to one of the pools, sitting down beside
it, and beckoning for blue and sundew to
do the same.
Those aren't the only guards, she
murmured, when they were beside her.
She crouched closer to the water.
There's another pair guarding the inner
door, and in the room with the book
itself.
There's always either 2 more guards or
the librarian.
The book is in a wooden case, which is
locked, and only the librarian has the
key.
Where is the librarian if she's not with
a book?
Sundew whispered.
She lives in a back room of the temple, so
she can be near the book at all times.
Once a librarian is chosen.
She never leaves the temple again.
Blue had known that.
Yikes.
What would it be like to be a dragon who
was never allowed to fly or see the sky?
Even though the temple was perfect, he
couldn't imagine anyone who'd be happy to
be trapped in it forever.
So possibly 6 guards, plus the
librarian.
Sundew muttered.
You know, it would have been quite
helpful if you'd mentioned any of this
earlier today during the planning
stages.
I forgot until I saw the temple, Cricket
said innocently.
Sorry, I haven't been here in a while.
Sundew growled softly and started poking
through her pouches.
Cricket caught Blue's eye and gave him a
small, nervous smile.
Blue was sure Cricket had remembered the
details of the guards all along, but she
was still trying to find a way to get out
of stealing the book.
He wished he could do something to help
her.
He wished he could think of a way to
rescue Luna, protect the tribes from an
invasion of leaf wings, save the book of
Clearsight, and escape with his friends.
Ideally with a minimum of danger, violence
or dragons yelling at him.
His heart stopped suddenly.
Maybe there was one possible way out of
this.
The problem was, it was risky and
insane.
But then, so was stealing the book of
Clear Sight.
We could tell the guards, he thought.
We could turn in sundew and expose her
disguise.
We give her to Queen Wasp.
We tell them where Belladonna and hemlock
are hiding, so the soldiers can swoop in
and save sore tail and catch them.
We'd be heroes.
Wouldn't we?
Surely capturing 3 leaf wings and
exposing a plot to steal the Book of
Clearsight would be the greatest gift
they could ever give Queen Wasp.
She would have to forgive them for
everything else.
Wouldn't she?
He tried to follow that thought.
Would she forgive Sordail for attacking
her soldiers?
What about IO?
Could she be forgiven too?
Would Queen Wasp let Blue and Luna go
back to their safe, ordinary lives with
their mothers?
Maybe if they promised to give all their
flame silk to her?
Would she let Sortell and Luna be
partnered together?
What about his father?
When she set him free too?
If he was even still alive?
What about all the other flame silks?
If there were others, Would she think 3
leaf wings were a fair trade for however
many silk wings she had trapped in her
flame silk factory?
If not, could he accept his own freedom
and Luna's, knowing he'd left others
behind?
Or what if Queen Wasp took the
information?
Destroyed the leaf wings, and then gave
them nothing in return.
He might betray sundew and break his
promises, only to end up in a 1000 times
as much trouble as before.
He'd be walking straight into the queen's
clutches with no leverage.
And how would we explain cricket?
He realized.
What if telling the queen about the leaf
wings?
And how we found them, and where we've
been for the last 3 days.
Means she figures out that cricket can't
be mind controlled.
He needed to keep her out of this if he
did it.
He had no idea how.
He needed to ask cricket for advice.
He needed to think, but he didn't have
time.
Sundew slipped something out of one of
her pouches and palmed it.
She nodded to Cricket.
Walked straight inside.
Don't look guilty.
What are you going to do?
Cricket whispered.
Something effective?
Sundu hissed.
Let's go.
Cricket led the way back to the silk path
and headed toward the front door of the
temple.
One of the guards was watching them
intently, while the other had his gaze
focused on his spear.
Blue found it harder and harder to
breathe.
Should he do it now?
He could run forward and throw himself on
the guard's mercy.
If he was going to betray sundew, he had
to do it before they were caught in order
to earn Queen Wasp's gratitude.
But cricket.
Is this what she would want?
He heard whisking sounds from behind him
like 2 tiny puffs of air.
He glanced back at sundew.
She jerked her chin at him.
Keep walking.
Cricket had reached the steps of the
temple.
This was it.
The guards would step forward and demand
to see their wristbands.
They'd arrest him and sundew on the spot
and it would only be a moment before they
realized sundew's 2nd pair of wings was
fake.
Turn her in.
Turn her in now.
Blue took a deep breath and focused on
the guard who'd been watching them.
Which is when he realized.
The guard wasn't moving.
His eyes were still fixed on the carpet
where they'd been, several steps back.
His black wings, spotted with large
yellow and red splotches, were halfway
raised and his mouth was slightly open, as
though he'd been about to speak.
But he was as still as the statue of
Queen Wasp outside.
As still as the prisoners on misbehaviors
weigh.
Blue whipped his head around to the other
guard.
She was paralyzed the same way, frozen
with her spear and her talons, and a
slight frown on her face.
How did son do do that?
Only hive wings had that kind of nerve
toxin, and only a few of them.
And as far as blue knew, they could only
wield it from up close by stabbing little
stingers into their victims.
But Sundew had done it from a distance
somehow, and so quietly, that none of the
dragons in the temple grounds had even
looked up from their books.
Unless someone looked carefully at the
guards, it was possible no one would
notice they were paralyzed at all for
most of the night.
Keep moving, Sundu whispered.
You're both staring.
Cricket shook herself and stepped through
the archway.
Blue wished he could pull her aside and
talk.
She must be terrified.
At least, he was terrified.
The room they stepped into was as
tranquil as the grounds outside.
To their left, a painting of clear sight
took up almost the entire wall, with
small lanterns flickering on either side
of it.
She looked kind and wise.
Light blue had always imagined.
Offerings were piled below the painting.
Bundles of wilting marigolds, tiny silver
sugar cakes, little weavings of poems.
To their right, the wall was divided into
100s of small cubby holes in a honeycomb
pattern.
Most of the holes held scraps of paper
wishes written by dragon claws, dreams
for what they hoped the future would hold
folded and tucked inside.
A desk stood in the corner with more
paper for anyone who wanted to write one
of their own.
Blue imagined all the dragons who had
come through here.
All their shaking talons asking clear
sight for hope, for luck, for love.
Hive wings and silk wings alike visited
the temple and believed in clear sight.
She helped them believe in a better
future.
Will they lose that faith without the
book?
If we steal it?
Does this all fall apart?
Will anyone come here anymore?
He knew what he wished he could ride on
one of those scraps of paper.
Please keep my friends safe.
Please, tell me what to do.
Cricket didn't pause in the antechamber.
She kept walking toward the inner
sanctum.
Blue, who had slowed down to look around
was able to watch sundo as she went past
him.
He saw her lift something to her mouth
and swiftly blow into it, once, slight
tilt to the right.
Twice.
She had uncanny aim.
He saw the moment each guard froze.
Spears slightly lifted, mouths ajar, as
though they'd sensed a threat and were
about to order them to halt.
Whatever she was shooting.
The guards were no use to him now.
He couldn't hand over sundew to a pair of
statues.
How are we going to get out of this?
There had to be more than just guards
between them and the book.
Maybe the case would be impossible to get
into?
He really hoped it was.
Cricket stepped between the 2 guards
casting them each a nervous glance.
Neither of them so much as twitched.
With a deep breath, she opened the double
doors and stepped into the final room.
This one was small and shadowy, and
perfectly square, like standing inside a
wooden box.
Blue squinted at the glimmering ceiling
and realized that it was inlaid with
Moonstone stars.
The only light in the room was a lantern
that hung over the case that held the
book.
Blue caught his breath.
He knew it wasn't the book itself, but
the case was carved to look like a book
too.
A book with dragons sweeping across the
cover and clambering around the spine
tails twining into vines, wings spilling
into clouds, eyes like suns.
The podium holding out the case was
shaped like a leafless tree, branches
spreading to support the book.
For a moment, he couldn't understand why
Queen Wasp had allowed that here, when
trees were forbidden in all other art.
Then he realized that the podium was
probably as old as the temple, from a
time long before Queen Wasp's decrees.
A time before the forests were
destroyed.
He stepped to cricket side, and she
reached to brush his shoulder with her
wing.
He knew she felt it too.
The sacredness of this place, the magic
of the book of clear sight.
But if sundew felt it, she didn't let it
slower down.
She shoved past them, darted to the
podium, and grabbed the case.
It didn't move.
For a moment, she wrestled with it
furiously, trying to pick it up, but the
case was inextricably joined to the
podium, and when she tried to pick that
up, she discovered it was as firmly
rooted to the floor, as though it had
grown from the wooden planks.
With a growl of frustration, Sundoo
seized the lock and tried to yank it
off.
Blue realized that that too would fail.
And then her next step was going to be
smashing the ancient case, he stepped
toward her, trying to raise the nerve to
argue with her.
And then a voice spoke, from the darkest
patch of shadows at the back of the
room.
Stop.
The book of Clear Sight is not for you.
The librarian stepped into the light.
A tall, bony dragon whose scales were the
pale orange of unripe apricots, marked
with a zigzagging triangle pattern of
black along her spine and tail.
She wore a dark silk veil that shrouded
her face.
Little dragons, she hissed.
I've been expecting you.
Chapter 21.
She knows.
She knows everything.
The book told her we would try to steal
it, just like I knew it would.
Blue's hard hammered loudly against his
ribs.
They were trapped.
If I talk fast, maybe I could still turn
sundew in.
Maybe they don't know where Belladonna
and Hemlock are.
The queen might still have mercy on us.
If we go quietly and tell her
everything.
If I don't fight.
If I follow orders, if I keep my head
down and say I'm sorry.
But staring into the librarian's hooded
face.
He knew he couldn't do any of that.
He couldn't handle leaf wings over to the
queen's cruelty.
He couldn't bow his head and go back to
being obedient now that he knew about
flame silks, and the mind control, and
the chrysalis.
After seeing the guards closing in on
Luna, he knew he'd never trust the queen
again.
The librarian took another step forward
and tilted her head towards sundew.
A hiss escaped from under the veil.
You're a leaf wing.
She snarled.
You seem surprised, Sundew said
mockingly.
I thought you were expecting us.
Didn't your precious book tell you I'd be
a leaf wing?
A leaf wing?
A silk wing.
And a hive wing, the librarian mused
looking at each of them in turn.
She seemed to stare at cricket the
longest, and then suddenly she reached up
and ripped off her veil.
Her eyes were blank and white as pearls.
Cricket gasped, flinching backward.
What strange treason is this?
The librarian ward.
Why can't I get inside your mind, worm?
Blue jumped in front of her, not even
really knowing what he was doing, only
that he needed to be between cricket and
the queen who could see everything.
I'm the one you're looking for.
He cried.
Blue, Luna's brother, the maybe flame
silk.
He rubbed at his arm, so the paint flaked
off a bit more, and his true colors shone
through.
See?
I'll turn myself in.
Please, just let them go.
Never.
The queen snarled in the librarian's
voice.
She reached for them with long stingers
sliding out from under her claws.
And then sundew cannoned into the
librarian's side, and slammed her into
the wall.
The librarian turned with a shriek and
slashed at sundew's face, but sundew
ducked and spun in the same movement
smashing her tail into the librarian's
chest.
The librarian was bigger and stronger, but
the leaf wing fought like a cornered
tiger.
They wrestled furiously around the tiny
space, hissing and clawing and kicking at
each other, until sundew suddenly seized
the librarian's head and threw her to the
floor.
She caught one of the hive wing's wrists
as the stinging claws came for her again
and snapped the arm bone with a brutal
crack.
The librarian screamed again and stabbed
her back claws into sundew's underbelly.
They rolled into the wall, leaving a
smear of blood along the floor.
What would clear sight think of us?
Blue thought with despair.
Fighting over her legacy like this.
What did she see in this vision?
And what did she think of it?
Was she proud of the librarian for
defending the book?
Did she hate us for trying to steal it?
He looked up, as though her spirit might
be in the moonstones above them, watching
the scene unfold.
I'm sorry, clear sight, he thought.
I never meant to cause trouble like
this.
I didn't ask for it.
I tried to be good.
Something sparked in the stones, a bright
reflection that dazzled his eyes for a
moment.
He looked down and saw where it had come
from.
An object on the floor that had caught
the light of the lantern, a key.
The key.
It had been torn from the librarian's
neck in the struggle with sundew.
He glanced at Cricket, but she was
crouched by the door with her talons over
her face, and he felt a wave of enormous
guilt crash over him.
The queen knew Cricket's secret now, and
it was all his fault.
Her whole life was going to change, even
if they did somehow manage to escape this
room.
She could never go home.
The queen would want to find her. and
figure out why she couldn't control her.
Queen Wasp, had taken Luna's life, and
cricket's life.
She'd taken the free will of her entire
tribe.
She'd taken the lives of 1000s of leaf
wings and their beloved trees.
It was time someone took something from
her.
Blue snatched up the key and leaped
toward the case.
With trembling claws, he fit the key in
the lock and turned it.
Please forgive me, clear sight.
He felt the weight of all the rules he'd
never broken, settling over his scales
and sinking into his heart as he opened
the lid of the case.
There it was, the real book of clear
sight.
It was much, much smaller than he'd
expected.
And it wasn't bound in gold either.
The leather cover was dyed blue, but had
no other decoration.
It was soft and worn, as though it had
been red a 1000000 times.
The pages inside were ancient, flaking
around the edges and yellowed with age.
It smelled like books, and a far off hint
of pine forest.
He lifted it gently into his talons.
Wait, Cricket said, and he turned quickly
to her, but she wasn't speaking to him.
She was talking to Sundu, who had the
librarian pinned against the wall.
Don't kill her, Cricket said.
Why not?
Sundew demanded.
Her stomach was bleeding, and her fake
wings had been torn off, along with a few
of her pouches.
She was breathing heavily, raggedly, as
was the librarian.
Because she's not the one fighting you.
Cricket said.
She took a step closer and peered into
the librarian's eyes.
The queen is, Does the queen control
you?
All the time?
Is that why you always wear the veil?
The answering glare was as blank and
white as ever.
It would make sense, Cricket said
softly.
That's the one way to be sure the
librarian never reveals the book's
secrets.
The tribe thinks 2 dragons share the
book's knowledge, but really, only the
queen does, because the librarian isn't
herself anymore.
Blue shuddered.
He thought being trapped in a temple for
her whole life was bad enough.
But it was even worse.
The librarian was trapped in her own mind
unable to get out, or make any of her own
decisions ever again.
Sundew study the dragon with sharp eyes.
I heard rumors that the hive wing queen
could control her subjects.
But I thought they were just stories the
old ones made up to frighten us.
The queen in the librarian barked a
laugh.
No, she said, it's all true.
I can control all of them.
That's why every dragon in the hive is on
their way to surround the temple right
now.
I can't move the guard who paralyzed, but
I can reach everyone else.
The moment you step outside this temple
they will kill you all.
But you're not sending them inside.
Cricket murmured.
Because you don't want them to know you
control the librarian this way.
Let's try something, Sundu said.
Hivewing.
It's cricket, cricket corrected her.
Cricket.
Sundu amended.
And something about using her name, the
young leaf wing sound like a real dragon
for a moment, not just a swiftly moving
ball of fury.
Find my pouch with a large A marked on
the outside.
Cricket searched the pouches on the floor
then edged close enough to sundew to poke
through the pouches still clasped around
her.
Found it, she said.
Open it very carefully. sundew instructed
and take out the jar inside, but don't
open that until I say so.
Any chance you can be a little more
ominous about this?
Cricket asked wryly.
She drew out the jar and held it between
her front talons.
Now, Sundew said, I want you to open it
and shake it out on her tail, then get as
far away as you can.
Cricket up into the jar over the
librarian and jumped back to Blue's
side.
Two small black ants fell out, landed on
the librarian's tail, and clung to it
with their small wriggling legs.
Their antennae searched her scales as
though puzzled.
What are you doing?
The queen demanded.
When you're inside a dragon?
Sundew said.
You can fill everything they can, can't
you?
Or else you wouldn't have screamed when I
broke your arm.
Yes, Cricket answered for her.
I know she leaves dragons when they're
hurt or dying.
Oh, I see your game, the queen scoffed.
I can take a lot more pain than a broken
arm though.
I'm not afraid of anything you can do to
this body.
That may be, said Sundew, but I'm
guessing that's because you've never been
bitten by a bullet ant before.
Blue had never even heard of a bullet ant
and from her silence, he guessed the
queen hadn't either.
They all watched the tiny ants circle for
a moment, and then start climbing up and
up the librarian's tail, and along her
spine.
The librarian didn't move and didn't move
and didn't move.
And then, as one of them ran toward her
neck, she flicked her wing instinctively
to knock it off her.
Instead, it latched onto the wing tip and
bit down with little pincer jaws.
The scream that came out of the librarian
was like nothing blew had ever heard
before.
She collapsed as though her bones had
melted, and Sundew dropped her to the
floor, where the dragon lay shaking all
over, and screaming that terrible
scream.
Sundew stepped over the patches of blood
on the floor. took the jar from cricket
and neatly scooped up the 2 ants without
letting them touch her.
She screwed the lid back on very tightly
and packed it away again in her pouch.
Then she crouched by the librarian's head
and peeled open one of her eyelids.
Had enough?
She asked the white eyeball beneath.
This pain is going to last half a day
just so you know.
It's not stopping anytime soon.
I'll kill you for this, the queen
hissed.
And then abruptly, the eye rolled back
and became a normal eye.
Dark orange irises and dilated pupils
stared up at sundew.
The librarian stopped screaming.
You...
You did it, she said in a strained
voice.
Ow.
Oh.
I know it's worth it, but ow, it's hard
to really know that right now.
I tried once before to hurt myself badly
enough that she'd set me free, but it
didn't work.
This is so much worse though.
She sat up. holding her wing out at an
awkward angle and moaning softly.
Is she really gone?
Sundew asked.
The librarian nodded.
Yes.
For the 1st time in years.
She inhaled and exhaled slowly, then
glanced at her wing and winced again.
If she's really gone, then here.
Sundew said.
Digging out a pair of dark green leaves
from another pouch.
To this and spit it on the spot where the
ant bit you.
It'll deaden the nerve, and should dull
the pain for a while at least.
Thank you, the librarian said.
She put the leaves in her mouth and
started chewing.
It'll also make your tongue feel very
weird, Sundu added, just to warn you.
The librarian agreed, making a face.
Has the queen been controlling you all
this time?
Cricket asked.
The librarian nodded. talking awkwardly
around the leaves in her mouth.
Ever since the initiation ceremony.
I woke up from the ritual with her inside
my head.
When she sleeps, she makes me sleep.
She's always in there.
She shuddered.
I was so proud to be chosen.
I never knew what it would mean.
I had no idea she did this.
That's horrible, Blue said softly.
The book felt fragile and warm in his
talons.
He wanted to protect it with all his
heart, and he was sure anyone who wanted
to be the librarian must feel the same
way.
They didn't need to be brainwashed into
it.
Queen Wasp didn't even give them a chance
to show their loyalty.
She forced it upon them instead.
She'll be back in your head as soon as
she thinks it's safe.
Cricket pointed out.
I know, the librarian said, nodding.
But even a moment to be myself, is more
than I ever thought I'd have again.
She spread the leaf paste over the edge
of her wing, and the pain lines around
her eyes relaxed.
Oh, thank clear sight.
Sundew glanced across a blue.
So, she said, we have the book, which is
great, but we're surrounded by hive
zombies who would really like to kill us
which is less great.
Can you throw bullet ants at them?
he asked, or blow dart them?
I don't have many more blow darts, she
said, or enough bullet ans for everyone
in the whole hive, although that would be
my kind of revenge.
She started collecting the pouches she'd
lost during the fight, checking their
contents, and resettling them around
her.
She kicked the pair of fake wings into
the corner.
I'll help you, the librarian said
quietly.
You will?
Blue said, surprised, but we're stealing
the book.
Your whole purpose in life is to keep it
safe.
The librarian looked at the book in his
talons, and her eyes were sadder than any
dragons he'd ever seen before.
I think it's time someone else knew the
book's secrets, she said.
And if the queen kills me for it, I'll
still be better off than I was this
morning.
How can you help us?
Sundew asked practically, is there
another way out of here?
Not exactly, she answered.
But I can get you up to the dome at
least.
The librarian got to her feet. wincing
from the other wounds Sundew had given
her, and limped to the back corner where
she'd 1st appeared.
She couldn't put any weight on her broken
arm, and Blue wondered if sundew felt
anywhere near as terrible as he did about
that.
A secret panel in the wooden wall slid
aside at her touch.
And they all followed her through into
the librarian's quarters.
Compared to the other rooms of the temple
this one felt cold and empty.
A bamboo mat in the corner, and a small
bookshelf, were the only 2 items in the
room.
It looks like a prison cell, Blue
thought.
The position of librarian was supposed to
be the tribe's greatest honor, but
instead it was a trick, a snare set to
trap one of the brightest minds of the
hive wings, and keep her useless
forever.
Another panel set aside to reveal a
spiral staircase going up.
They climbed after the librarian, rounding
the last curve to find themselves in an
attic that smelled of wood chips and
boiled silk.
The underside of the dome curved over
their heads, and Blue saw a door on one
side that led to a small balcony.
What was this for?
Cricket asked, blinking around at the
dust and abandoned boxes.
She picked up an odd looking tool that
looked a bit like a curved dragon
tongue.
I think librarians used to make books up
here.
The librarian said wistfully.
Oh, Cricket said.
She ran one claw along the top of a dusty
table.
That's what I thought they did too.
Not anymore.
Not in a long time.
The librarian led the way to the balcony
door and peeked out through the glass.
Oh, dear.
Sundew edged in beside her and looked out
as well.
Hmm, she snorted.
I can take them.
Every hive wing and wasp hive.
Cricket said.
You are terrifying, but I still find that
a little hard to believe.
Unless you have something else alarming
in one of those pouches.
Blue said, hopefully.
Sundew tapped the floor thoughtfully with
one claw.
Maybe, she said, but I need fire to make
it work.
I have fire, Cricket said.
She scrambled to pull out the little
stone jar with a flame silk thread inside
and tipped it to show sundew.
Would this work?
The leaf wing's eyes gleamed.
I think so.
Be careful.
The librarian pleaded, as Sundew took the
jar in her claws.
Don't set the temple on fire.
You can have the book, but please leave
the temple.
Sandu hesitated, as though she would have
loved to set the whole hive on fire.
But after a moment, she nodded.
Stand back.
She took a branch covered with long, waxy
looking red brown leaves out of another
pouch.
With careful, slow movements, she dipped
the point of each one into the jar until
it touched the flame silk and caught
fire.
A bright flame flared for a moment on
each leaf, then vanished into curls of
reddish smoke.
Sundew handed the jar back to cricket, and
opened the door to the balcony, holding
the burning branch out away from her.
Now Blue could see the temple grounds, and
the hive wings who covered every inch of
space between the temple and the door.
Orange, yellow, red, and black scales
rippled like a vast sea of poisonous
snakes.
As sundew stepped onto the balcony of the
dome, every head snapped toward her in
unison, blank eyes latching onto her.
One branch of burning leaves seemed very
small in the face of all those talons and
teeth and claws.
Blue shivered, and he felt cricket put
one wing over his back and lean against
him.
I should be comforting her, he thought.
I'm the one who's ruined her life.
But if she was still willing to be close
to him, perhaps she forgave him.
Perhaps she still liked him anyway.
Sundew hissed at the crowd of hive
wings.
Smoke was rolling off the leaves now
growing thicker and thicker and redder
and darker.
She glanced at it one more time, checking
that it was all smoke and no flames, and
then she threw it with all her might
directly into the middle of the watching
dragons.
It hit a yellow black dragon, who shook
it off and hopped away with a yelp.
The dragon's closest to him began
coughing.
They sank to the ground, one by one
hacking and wheezing as the smoke
billowed up and out, swallowing the
dragons around it.
But it wasn't enough, for each hive wing
incapacitated by the smoke.
There were 5 more still grimly standing
between them and the only way out.
Capture the flame silk.
They intoned.
Kill the other two.
The buzz of their wings filled the
chamber.
As dragon after dragon rose into the air
and surged toward the dome.
Blue's heartbeat surged with panic.
Wait, that's not the only way out.
He looked up.
There was the skylight, and the stars far
above them.
The hole was barely large enough for a
dragon to fit through.
But he and cricket and sundew were all
fairly small.
If they could break the glass at the top
they could at least get outside the
hive.
Up, he shouted, grabbing Cricket's arm
and pointing.
We can go out the skylight.
She followed his gaze, then looked back
at him.
What about you?
She asked.
How do we get you up there?
Oh.
He twisted to look back at his wing buds
as though perhaps they'd have magically
turned into wings in the last several
heartbeats.
Will carry him.
Sunju threw open her wings and leaped up
off the balcony.
Let's go, and hold on to that book.
She started smashing hive wings aside
with her tail and talons.
He clutched the book to his chest.
Cricket whirled around in a panic and
grabbed a long, twisted silk rope from
one of the tables.
She and the librarian threw it around
Blue's shoulders and chest and tied it
fast.
They each took an end and ran to the
balcony.
I wish I had wings, Blue thought, closing
his eyes.
I wish I were more than a dead weight for
my friends to drag around.
The rope jerked tight under his arms, and
he was dragged smack into the balcony
railing, nearly tumbling over it before
the rope steadied, and he felt himself
lifted up, up into the air.
He tilted sideways almost immediately, as
the librarian's bigger wings soared ahead
and Cricket faltered under his weight.
Then Zundu swept up beside her and took
the rope as well, tugging him upright.
All he could do was dangle helplessly
holding on to the book for dear life
right below his talons, the smoke still
billowed, and the seething mass of hive
wings snapped and churned.
Three of them surged toward his feet, and
he kicked at them frantically.
Ah, help, he shouted.
A cascade of little red centipedes poured
down from above him.
Each dragon they struck let out a shriek
of alarm or pain, and dropped away
clawing at his face.
The dome was shrinking below him.
Blue looked up and saw sundew, then
Cricket duck into the skylight hole.
The librarian was hovering beside it
taking up the slack in his rope, waiting
to let them go 1st.
And then suddenly, she looked down at him
and her eyes were white again.
Nice try, she said.
Cricket, Blue screamed.
The librarian's claws slashed through the
rope connecting him to his friends.
He tumbled sideways, jerking to a stop at
the end of the severed rope, but feeling
the knot start to slip loose around his
chest.
Crickets shot back down the shaft and
flew at the librarian's face.
The librarian ducked away, gave her an
evil grin, and let Blue's rope fall from
her hands.
His stomach flipped as he started to
plummet.
Then jerked to a stop again, as cricket
caught the end of the rope.
But she wasn't strong enough to lift him
alone.
Even with her wings beating as hard as
she could, they were both sinking down
toward the hive wings.
Cricket, he yelled.
You have to go without me.
They won't kill me, but they're under
orders to kill you.
Take the book and go.
I'm not.
She started to shout back, but he was
already tossing the book up toward her.
She had to drop the rope to catch it.
She did it instinctively.
As he'd known she would.
She was as well trained to love the book
as he was.
All their lives, they'd known it was the
most precious object in their world.
She'd reach for it without thinking.
Even if her conscious mind would have
chosen to save blue instead.
As he fell, as a 1000 claws reached up to
seize him, he saw a cricket clutch the
book to her chest and shout his name.
He saw sundew pummel the librarian hard
enough to knock the hive wing out of the
air.
He saw Sundew grab Cricket's arm and pull
her away.
And he saw Cricket's last look back.
And he saw their tails disappearing away
up the skylight.
And then, all he could see was orange and
yellow and black and red, as the talons
closed around him.
And the queen had him in her grasp at
last.
Part three.
Metamorphosis.
Chapter 22.
Blue was dragged roughly through the hive
tunnels.
The Queen had dispatched 5 dragons to
take him away, which was 4 too many for a
dragon as harmless as blue.
It kept stepping on one another's toes
and growling, and bumping wings, and all
trying to hold onto his elbows at once
which he definitely did not have enough
elbows for them to do.
Their eyes were their own again.
So the queen had apparently decided she
didn't need to be concerned about blue
anymore, which meant all the rest of her
brainwashed subjects were off hunting for
cricket and sundew.
Did they get away?
Are they all right?
He worried and worried about this, as he
was shoved between blustering hive
wings.
They were descending through the levels
but to where, Blue had no idea.
He kept expecting the queen herself to
appear.
He jumped each time they turned on to a
level with black and yellow stripes.
They reached the bottom level with no
sign of her, though.
The guards pushed him out into the
streets of warehouses he'd seen on the
way in.
One flicked her wings at him, and he
realized the tips were sharp little
stingers, probably venomous, another kept
baring his fangs, so those could probably
kill him with just a scratch too.
Where are they taking me?
Blue wondered, staring at the blank walls
as they marched past.
How am I going to be punished?
He remembered the tortured faces on
misbehavior's way, and shivered.
This feeling, of being in trouble, of
having done something wrong, of knowing
so many dragons were angry at you.
This was everything he'd tried to avoid
his whole life.
He hated it.
He wanted to go back to his desk, and get
all the answers right on the quiz, and
have the teacher smile and say, nice work
Blue.
He wanted to dig out his good citizenship
award and show it to these hive wings to
prove he wasn't as bad a dragon as they
thought he was.
But...
I'm not.
I mean, I've done all the things they
think I have.
But that doesn't make me bad.
He clung to that thought like it was a
harness, and someone was lifting him
through the sky.
Yes, I broke hive wing rules, but I had
good reasons too.
I'm not trying to hurt anyone.
I just wanted to find my sister and set
her free.
Queen Wasp didn't have to be so secretive
and menacing and terrifying in the 1st
place.
The hive wing stopped suddenly in front
of a blocky building that looked exactly
the same as all the others.
The only difference was a carving on the
gray door.
This time of a small lantern.
Little sparks coming off it to indicate
it was glowing.
Blue suddenly had a guess about where he
was going.
One of the hive wings pounded on the door
in a series of knocks.
Three quick, 4 slow, too quick.
After a moment, it was flung open
revealing a wizened, mostly orange dragon
with black patches here and there.
He gestured for them to come inside and
slammed the door behind them.
Shapes loomed around them in the dim
interior.
Giant crates as far as blue could tell
stacked up to the ceiling.
They maneuvered between these, left, right
right?
left again, until Blue lost track.
But he thought they were about in the
center of the warehouse when they reached
a wide open, well lit space, surrounded
by a circle of watchful hive wing
guards.
At first, Blue thought they were staring
into empty space, or perhaps at one
another across the way.
It wasn't until he got closer that he
realized they were looking down.
Down through an enormous sheet of glass
at a stone cavern below the floor.
That was also where all the light was
coming from.
The dragon from the door shoved him past
the guards before Blue could take a close
look.
But he caught a glimpse of cauldrons that
seemed to be full of molten gold, and
dragons moving between them.
Shortly beyond the circle of guards, the
old dragon shoved aside a crate, and
heaved open a trap door underneath
revealing a set of stairs descending into
the earth.
He started down, and Blue's guards nudged
him into following.
Lamps punctuated the turns of the
stairwell, but they seemed unnecessary.
The glow from the light at the bottom of
the stairs could have illuminated a
stairwell 3 times as long.
Blue had to shield his eyes and blink
hard for a moment when they reached the
bottom.
His head ached, as though he'd walked
right up to the sun.
What's this?
A gruff voice demanded, while Blue's eyes
were still adjusting.
The flame silk everyone's been looking
for, came the answer.
Can be.
Someone poked his shoulder.
Wrong color.
Ah, did his scales just fall off?
It's paint or something?
said another dragon.
She started scraping at his scales with
her claws.
Yeesh!
Look, it comes off.
That just scrubber.
Wait, this little scrap is the dragon
we've been hunting across the Savannah?
Someone else chimed in.
He's not a flame silk?
He hasn't even got wings or silk yet.
We knew that idiot, said the 1st voice.
He's just probably a flame silk.
We have to keep an eye on him in case he
is.
Oh, boring.
When does metamorphosis?
Dunno.
Soon I reckon.
Blue's heart gave a nervous jump.
It was soon.
Really, really soon.
He kept forgetting to worry about it.
His was supposed to start right after
Luna's ended.
Would he have to spin his cocoon here?
Far away from his mother, his hive, and
the cocoon where he'd always expected to
transform.
He felt his wrist gingerly.
They seemed normal.
No pain, no burning feelings.
What if he went through his metamorphosis
and wasn't a flame silk?
What would the queen do with him then?
Sending him back home to burn it and
Silverspot didn't seem like the most
likely option somehow.
Someone arrived with scrubbing brushes
and briskly scoured the paint off his
scales.
He stood still and didn't struggle.
There wasn't much point in being a
different color now after all.
Besides, his eyes were finally adjusting
to the light, and he was transfixed by
his new surroundings.
They were standing on a ledge at the
bottom of the stairs, looking out over
the cave he'd glimpsed from above.
If he looked up, he could see the green
yellow, orange glow of the eyes watching
through the glass ceiling.
More hive wing guards were stationed down
here, peering into the cauldrons, and
occasionally poking the working silk
wings with their tails or spears.
Several of those silk wings were ordinary
dragons, doing ordinary work, transporting
cargo, carrying food and water, cleaning
putting out fires, but the rest, the rest
were flame silks.
Blue counted 9 at 1st glance.
They were scattered across the cavern
each on his or her own rocky perch.
Four of them were asleep.
Two were eating.
The other 3 had their wrists extended.
Fiery silk threads spilling out into the
massive stone cauldrons set below them.
He stared at them, trying to guess which
one was his father.
The large, bored one who looked like he
might fall asleep and topple into his own
silk fire.
The lime striped one, who was nibbling a
persimmon as though it had greatly
offended him.
But he decided to eat it anyway.
The one with pale pink wings whose talons
twitched constantly in his sleep.
And then, at last, he saw what he most
wanted to see.
An incandescent gold cocoon, tucked in
its own hollow on the far side of the
cave.
Luna.
He took a step toward her, hesitated, and
looked back at the guards.
The scrubbing brushes had been carted
away.
His original escorts had gone back up the
stairs, leaving the one guard from the
door, and the 3 who'd come to investigate
his arrival.
These 4 were all leaning on their spears
or chewing on strips of dried gazelle
chatting to one another.
One of them noticed his glance.
She grinned at him with all her teeth.
Go ahead, she said.
Get used to the place.
I gather you're going to be here for a
while.
The others chuckled.
Although Blue didn't think it was really
the most clever menacing comment she
could have come up with.
He took another few steps away, but they
all went back to their conversation and
ignored him.
I guess I really can walk around.
He'd expected a cage, or a paralyzing
nerve toxin, or some kind of beating
perhaps.
But maybe this was the queen's way of
letting him know how unimportant he was.
Or how trapped.
He could wander as far as he liked
because there was nowhere to go, and no
way out.
Blue clambered down from the ledge
hopping from rocky foothold to craggy
stalacmite, until he reached the same
level of the cavern as Luna's cocoon.
Behind him, he heard the hive wing guards
laughing, and he wondered if they were
mocking his winglessness.
Well, I won't be wingless much longer.
His biggest fear, his metamorphosis, was
only days away.
It didn't seem fair that he'd have to
deal with that too.
In the middle of everything else
terrifying.
His route to the cocoon led him past the
bored looking flame silk, who glanced up
with a spark of interest in his eyes.
Hey, said the flame silk, in a lazy but
commanding voice, who are you?
Blue hesitated.
He didn't want to alienate anyone who
might be a friend down here, and for all
he knew, this could be Admiral.
I'm Blue, he said.
My sister's in that cocoon over there.
Oh, said the other dragon.
He shook one of his wrists vigorously
watched the silk spool for a moment, then
turned his gaze back to blue.
Right.
The new blood.
Did you know we were coming?
Blue asked.
Some of us hoped, he answered.
Ad's been counting the days.
He nodded over at Luna's cocoon, and Blue
finally noticed that there was a dragon
sitting next to it.
Add Admiral.
Bloom moved forward, studying his
father.
Admiral was a shimmering blue green
somewhere between Blue's bright morpho
butterfly blue, and Luna's elegant
caterpillar color.
He had darker purple streaks along his
wings, and matching spots of white on
each one.
His eyes were brown, with a faint gold
tinged to them, and he traced one claw
around and around in an infinity loop on
the ground as he watched Luna's cocoon.
For a long moment he didn't look up.
Even when Blue stopped right across the
cocoon from him, but at last, Admiral
raised his head and saw his son, his eyes
lit up.
You're the other one, he said.
You're early.
Oh, yes, Blue said.
He gestured vaguely the guards on the
entrance ledge.
I was, uh, well, captured, I guess.
I'm so glad you're here.
Admiral said warmly, I'm your father.
I'm Admiral.
I know, Blue said.
My name's Blue.
Wait, you're glad we're here.
Glad that Luna and I are trapped down
here.
Just like you.
We have such an important job.
Admiral said, rubbing his wrists.
So important.
When do you think she'll wake up?
Blue calculated backward.
Not tomorrow night, the night after that
he said.
That would be 5 days from when she went
in.
Admiral nodded.
I can't believe one of mine is a flame
silk, he said.
And maybe both.
Club Tell was taken out to have eggs a
year before me, but neither of his had
any flame whatsoever.
His chest swelled with pride.
But Blue looked around at the cavern
again.
Isn't it?
Sorry, but isn't it kind of terrible?
Being a flame silk.
Terrible.
Gosh, no, said Admiral.
I mean, I'd make some changes.
I'm working on that.
Working on what?
Blue asked.
Was his father also part of his secret
resistance?
Admiral waved at a rocky nest nearby
where piles of papers were neatly stacked
along the stone shelves around it.
Each stack tied with a pale gold thread.
Changing the system.
He said, solving problems.
With papers.
Blue squinted at them.
Their letters.
Admiral said patiently, my copies of them
obviously.
I write one to the queen every 7 days
outlining the current problems I see, and
offering proposals for fixing them.
Oh, Blue said, impressed.
That was a lot of letters.
So she writes back, or she comes to visit
you?
Well, neither, said Admiral, but she's
very busy.
Lots of hives to run.
Two tribes to manage, leaf wings to guard
against, the dip in flame silk production
is just one of her many problems, which
I'm going to help solve.
There's a flame silk shortage, Blue
said.
No, said Admiral unconvincingly.
And it's not a problem, because we're
solving it, with her help.
He added, nodding at Luna's cocoon, and
hopefully yours.
Blue stared at him in alarm.
Was this your idea?
he asked. fathering potential flame silks
so more dragons could be trapped in this
cave.
Well, no, his father admitted.
The queen came up with that.
Very clever.
And works out well for me because, A
better company, and B, more signatures
for my petitions.
Petitions.
Blue echoed.
My suggestion was longer rest cycles
between production and more citrus in our
diet, which we got.
The citrus, I mean, tangerines for
everyone with every meal.
Every meal.
Really makes you wish for a lemon or a
banana now and then.
Good for us, though.
She vetoed the longer rest cycles.
That's all right.
So, what else have you changed?
Blue asked.
Oh, lots of things.
Admiral said with a modest shrug.
I started almost as soon as I got here.
Once I realized there was a system and a
way to accomplish real change within that
system.
Yeah.
Blue was intrigued.
Doing things inside the rules.
That sounded like something he could
handle a bit better than Swordtail and
Luna's revolution.
Maybe his father could teach him how to
do it.
Maybe there was a way to be a good dragon
stay out of trouble, and still make
things better.
Although, tangerines were not quite the
epic change Blue wanted to see in the
world.
Can I read some of your letters?
Blue asked.
Of course.
Admiral leaped excitedly to his feet, and
bounded over to his alcove.
He came back with an armful of papers and
laid them out in front of Blue.
Wait.
Is this flame silk?
Blue asked.
Touching the thread that tied one stack
together?
He squinted at it, puzzled.
Why isn't it setting the letters on
fire?
Admiral laughed.
This is great, he said.
I feel like such a dad.
I get to teach you so much.
There are different kinds of flame silk
buddy.
It wouldn't be much good to us if it only
burned everything in sight.
We need the kind for building webs too.
Something we can sleep on.
Stickier silk for climbing with.
We can choose which kind we produce.
He tipped his wrists up, flexed his claws
and glanced at the nearest guard, who
wasn't paying any attention to them.
Um, I'll show you later.
Not a good idea to waste any silk, you
know?
Blue flipped through the letters, thinking
about this new information.
It was quite a relief to hear that he
wouldn't accidentally set the world on
fire every time he used his silk.
Maybe going through metamorphosis with
his flame silk parent nearby actually was
a good idea.
Maybe the queen was trying to help me and
Luna by bringing us here.
And yet.
He glanced around at the cavern.
The flame silk dragons looked fine.
They didn't seem miserable.
But if they were so important and the
queen was willing to listen to them, why
were they kept imprisoned in this
cavern?
Why were they such a big secret?
At least from most other silk wings?
Why weren't they allowed to choose this
life?
Or something else?
Father, Blue said.
Do any flame silks ever leave this
place?
Sure, Admiral said unexpectedly.
I mean, I left, didn't I?
Long enough to have you.
Right, but how long was that for?
Blue asked.
Did you get to decide when and where you
went or who you were with?
Well, no, Admiral said, but it was a
lovely visit.
Cicada hive is so pretty.
That mosaic garden.
Wow.
Have you gone anywhere else?
Blue asked.
How often do you leave?
Um...
Admiral scrunched up his snout, as though
he was counting in his head, Blue leaned
forward, hopefully.
Right.
That was it, actually, that one time.
In your whole life, Blue asked, dismayed
you've spent your whole life in this one
cave.
Oh no, said Admiral.
I grew up in Hornet Hive.
Didn't move here until my metamorphosis
went into my cocoon there, woke up here
quiet a surprise, really delightful once
I realized how important we are, and what
an honor this is.
Blue regarded him skeptically.
Haven't you ever asked the queen if you
could leave?
Sure, Admiral said.
That stag on the end is vacation time
requests, and field trip proposals, and
some of my theories on how more flying
might improve our silk production.
Afraid I don't have any good evidence for
that though.
More of a wishful thinking kind of
hypothesis.
I realize that.
Completely reasonable that she always
says no.
Blue picked up another letter.
His father's handwriting was neat and
very legible.
His spelling was perfect.
His sentences concise and convincing.
This one was a politely worded outline of
a proposal for a skylight, or anything
like a window, suggesting that a little
sun on their scales might also be
beneficial for their silk output.
There were several letters below it along
the same lines.
With modifications to the proposal to
make it as cost effective, or easy to
accomplish as possible.
One even included a drawing of a sequence
of mirrors that could bring the sunshine
to them via a long path of reflections.
Blue could clearly see, from looking at
the cavern, that every one of these
letters had been ignored.
Who's the midget?
One of the other flame silks, the one
with green stripes shouted at Admiral.
Is that your offspring?
He's scrawny like you.
Is he a vacuous earthworm too?
Mind your own business.
Admiral roared.
He doesn't need to hear your toad sucking
voice.
Better than your millipedian claw waving
folder all, the dragon yelled.
Are you poisoning his ears with your
stupid ideas already?
Did you tell him the queen chews up all
your letters and spits them out?
Because they're the dumbest things she's
ever read?
That's not true.
And it would help.
If certain dragons weren't such trolls
about everything.
Admiral yelled back, as if anyone would
ever believe that less, citrus might be
helpful.
I swear, he said to Blue.
I think he sneaks over and reads my
letters, just so he can write ones
arguing for the exact opposite of
anything I propose.
Who is that?
Blue asked, wide eyed.
Why is he so mean?
That's fritelery, Admiral growled.
He just wants everyone to hate the world
as much as he does.
Don't talk to him.
He made an effort to smile at Blue.
See?
This is why I'm glad you're here.
It'll be nice to have someone new to talk
to.
Someone with a little perspective.
Someone who knows how to look on the
bright side.
You do know how to look on the bright
side, don't you?
I guess I do, Blue said.
Wasn't that what he'd spend his whole
life doing?
Finding a silver lining to any cloud
convincing himself that there was nothing
wrong with how silk wings were treated.
Ignoring Luna's complaints, assuming that
their safety was worth sacrificing a few
freedoms.
He looked down at the letters in his
talons again.
After all these years of trying to work
with the Queen Wasp's rules, in Queen
Wasp's Hive, under Queen Wasp's Control
and his father accomplished no more than
a handful of tangerines.
Had he accepted the loss of all his
freedom because he thought he could find
a way to make it work?
Didn't he want more out of his life?
Didn't he want to fight back?
Do I?
It was like cricket said.
Some rules were unjust, and some things
were more important than following the
rules.
He put down the letters, and arrested his
front talons on Luna's warm golden
cocoon.
It was very hot, but it didn't burn him.
This is not going to be our life, Luna.
He promised silently.
I won't spend the next 100 years writing
fruitless letters.
Father's way, obeying the system, hasn't
worked.
So we'll find another.
Or will burn it all down.
Chapter 23.
Admiral found a place for blue close to
his own nest, a hollow in the rock large
enough for a dragon to settle into, with
several crannies in the wall where he
could keep things, if he ever had
anything.
Apparently there was a request process
involving a number of forms.
At 1st the hollow seemed a little too big
to blue.
And then he fell to shiver across his
wings, as he realized his father was
thinking of Blue's future, and how much
bigger he might grow.
Admiral had chosen a nest where Blue
could spend the entire rest of his life.
But I'm not going to.
That's not going to happen.
He tried to believe it as he lay down to
sleep, but his dreams were restless and
unhappy.
He dreamed of getting his talons stuck in
a crevice and trying to pull them out.
He dreamed of letters piling up around
his claws.
He dreamed of clear sight, sitting on the
steps of her temple. looking down at him
with enormous disappointment.
When he woke up, his wrists were
itching.
Am I going to be a flame silk?
The cavern was quiet.
Most of the regular silk wings were gone
and 7 of the flame silks were asleep.
Blue climbed down to Luna's cocoon and
leaned against it.
He wished he could talk to his sister, or
cricket.
Is cricket all right?
Did she escape?
Or. His mind shied away from the
alternative.
He couldn't imagine the world without
cricket in it.
He couldn't imagine his own life without
A hive wing guard came stomping over. and
Blue sat up hopefully.
Maybe this dragon could tell him
something about what had happened.
But the guard went right past him and
jabbed Admiral in the side with one of
her sharp claws.
Admiral woke up with a snort, blinking
rapidly.
Time to spin.
The guard snarled.
You're late.
So sorry.
Admiral said, rubbing his eyes.
You're quite right.
I've been a little discombobulated by the
arrival of my children, of course.
Otherwise, I'm always on time, aren't I?
Very punctual dragon.
That's me.
Very little reminding required.
Don't you agree?
Quit your yapping and excusing, the guard
grumbled.
Silk, now.
She dragged a cauldron out from under
Admiral's Nest, and thunked it into place
right below Admiral.
Of course.
Admiral held out his arms and closed his
eyes.
A long, dragging moment passed, and then
a thread of flame emerged from one
wrist.
It spiraled down into the cauldron
pouring slowly, like cold honey.
It was another long moment before a 2nd
thread appeared from the other wrist, and
this one seemed dimmer than the 1st.
The guard scowled at the slow moving silk
and Blue wondered what she was feeling.
Was she worried about what would happen
to the hives if there was a flame silk
shortage?
Or did the guards get punished if the
flame silks didn't meet a certain quota?
Or was there any chance she was actually
concerned about the dragons under her
charge?
What a weird life this would be?
He thought.
Every morning, you wake up and go through
a secret warehouse staircase into an
underground cavern.
You spend the day poking other dragons to
make them work. and standing guard so
they can't leave.
Isn't it boring?
It must be boring.
Especially for the ones sitting in a
circle in the dark warehouse, staring
through the glass all day.
The hive wing turned to leave, and
admiral's eyes popped open.
Sandfly, he said quickly.
Have you met my son?
This is Blue.
He says my daughter's name is Luna, and
she'll be coming out tomorrow night with
her wings.
And soak to add to the quota.
Isn't that wonderful?
Sandfly looked down at blue and the gold
cocoon.
She didn't say anything for a few
heartbeats.
Her scales were pale yellow, and speckled
everywhere with tiny black spots, like a
swarm of flies in the desert.
It was easy to see how her parents had
chosen her name.
They're very young, she said at length.
Blue couldn't tell if she was feeling
sorry for them, with a life of
imprisonment lying ahead, or if she was
pleased at the idea of how much silk
they'd be able to produce over the length
of that life.
Excuse me, he said.
I'm sorry to bother you, but I was
wondering, do you know what happened to
the dragons who stole the book of
Clearsight yesterday?
Sandfly leaped backward, as though he'd
jabbed her with an electric eel.
What?
She roared.
Half of the sleeping heads in the cavern
popped up and turned their way.
That didn't happen.
No one would dare.
Oh.
Blue trailed off.
It hadn't occurred to him that the queen
would lie to everyone about this. and
make the librarian lie too.
But now that he thought about it, he
wasn't surprised.
Losing the book of Clear Sight would be
pretty terrible for morale.
She could easily just close up the case
and pretend it was still in there.
That is, if cricket and sundew did escape
with a book.
What a horrible thing to say.
Samfly barked.
Behind her, Admiral gave Blue a pained
fix this, expression, I'm sorry, Blue
said.
I'm so sorry.
I meant the dragons who tried to steal
the book of Clearside.
Of course, the librarian stopped them.
Of course it's safe.
Um.
Those dragons, though.
Do you know if they got away?
Sandfly was shaking out her wings as
though they were crawling with
caterpillars.
Ugh, she said, I'm going to have
nightmares for days.
What kind of traitor would steal the book
of Clearsight?
That's so obviously wrong?
So obviously wrong.
Blue stared down at his talons.
The talons that had unlocked the case and
lifted out the precious book.
It was me.
I'm the traitor.
But the librarian had wanted them to have
it. when she was herself.
She'd said it was time for other dragons
to know the book's secrets.
He decided not to mention that, in case
Sandfly had another heart attack.
He was also carefully avoiding the fact
that one of the criminal dragons was a
leaf wing, in case that wasn't public
knowledge, and might set off a riot, Right
he said, trying one more time.
So the queen really wanted to catch
them.
But did she?
I have no idea, Sandfly said.
She settled her wings again.
I was down here until midnight last
night.
No one at home mentioned any public
executions yesterday, but maybe they'll
be held today or tomorrow.
Blue managed not to gasp or burst into
tears.
She assumes they were caught because
she's a hive wing, but she doesn't
actually know.
They might be safe.
Or they might be in another prison
somewhere, waiting to be executed.
If only he could escape and go look for
them.
But he didn't have cricket's clever ideas
or sore tails impulsive courage, or
sundew's helpful pouches of weapons.
He was just a little wingless dragon
stuck in a cavern of flame.
Still, he could at least try.
Blue spent the rest of the day exploring
every corner of the Flame Silk Cave.
He walked the entire perimeter, clambering
up and down the rocks wherever he needed
to.
The guards by the staircase gave him
weird looks as he went by, but they
didn't stop him.
Nobody stopped him.
Although he got the distinct feeling that
all the flame silks were watching him
whenever they thought he wasn't looking.
There were 3 female flame silks and 7
males, most of them quite a lot older
than Blue.
He guessed that Admiral might be the
youngest one the queen had.
A couple of them seemed to stay in their
nests all the time, cycling between
sleeping, eating and producing silk
without ever moving from their spots.
He saw a few others get up and fly around
although they couldn't go far.
There was enough room to spread their
wings, but they couldn't soar, and there
wasn't any wind to ride.
If this is my future.
Well, I never get to fly in the clouds.
How will I ever learn to fly properly
without any wind currents down here?
The guards and the flame silks seemed to
have a very precise schedule in their
heads.
They rotated production cycles and rest
intervals in careful synchronization, so
there were always at least 3 flame silks
working, even in the middle of the
night.
Blue had covered almost the entire cave.
By the time his father's turn at the
cauldron was done.
There were a few ledges and corners that
he hadn't figured out how to climb up to
yet, but he had walked between all the
stalagmites, and surreptitiously poked
his nose and every large gap in the
rocks.
So far, he hadn't found any secret
passages, though.
From across the cave.
He saw sandfly drop a bucket of food
beside Admiral, and roll the cauldron
away.
He started back, his head full of
questions.
Hello, dear.
One of the flame silks said, popping her
head over the edge of her nest, just as
he was about to pass her.
He jumped, and she giggled.
I'm Danaid.
My, aren't you a shiny one?
We haven't had any visitors in so long.
And now we'll have 2 new flame silks.
How delightful.
She sighed happily.
Her scales were so orange, she almost
looked like a hive wing, but there was no
black among them.
Instead, flecks of white dotted her spine
and long streaks of white striped her
wings.
She looked old enough to be Blue's great
grandmother.
I might not be a flame silk.
Blue said, checking his wrists again.
Not to worry, she said.
I'm sure you'll still be delightful
company.
Better than all these grousing old
dragons, anyhow.
Some of them can't keep secret.
She shot an irritated look at the pale
pink flame silk.
And some of them think very highly of
themselves.
I can hear you.
Fiddlery shouted from his nest.
We all can, called another.
I know, Danaid shouted back.
We are in a cave, but I'm having a
private conversation.
So stick your snouts somewhere else.
I told you, I thought you wanted me to
tell Fritillery that you like to
stripes.
The pink silkwing said in a wounded voice
Aren't you ever going to forgive me?
Well, I don't like them anymore.
Dene had snapped.
I think they make him look skinny and
arrogant and potato brained.
You wish you were as smart as a potato.
Fritillery bellowed.
Go suck a lime, Danae had shouted.
I hope your face gets eaten by dung
beetles.
Now, now, settle down, said one of the
hive wing guards in a bored voice.
Anyway, where were we?
Danae had said to Blue, her voice
suddenly all sweetness again.
And it wasn't my fault, the festoon
overheard me telling Heliconian, that you
thought he was stealing all the
radishes.
The pink dragon went on querulously.
You should be mad at him for
eavesdropping.
Not me.
I was, then they had snapped, but he died
5 years ago, you half wit.
Oh, right.
The pink dragon flopped sideways in his
nest.
Ignore them, sweetheart.
Then they had said to Blue.
Is it always like this?
Blue aft.
He waved his hands at the flame silks.
Like what?
The Naiad asked cheerfully.
The arguing?
He tried.
He'd seen at least 3 other shouting
matches erupt that morning while he'd
been searching the cave.
Who's arguing?
than they had said.
Was it old fritillery?
He's the worst.
Don't talk to him.
Zeneca is terrible too.
Always gossiping and bad mouthing
everyone.
You already know you can't trust pirate
over there.
The pink flame silk let out a grumbling
sigh, and turned his head away from
them.
Clubtail is perfectly nice, but by all
the hives, he never stops talking.
Heliconian ruins everything.
She flipped her tail over the side of the
nest and smiled at Blue.
Really?
I am the only one worth knowing.
Danaid, stop poisoning my son's mind
Admiral said, appearing a blue side
suddenly.
He's on my side, not yours.
There are sides, Blue said, confused.
No, Admiral said, but Danaid is
definitely on the wrong one.
Let me introduce you to the dragons you
should be friends with.
Then they had hissed at him.
You can't keep the new friends all to
yourself.
She cried.
New friends are for sharing.
Let him decide for himself who he wants
to talk to.
Eat bugs, Danaid, Admiral said sharply.
He led Blue away, his snout in the air.
Isn't she dreadful, he said, loud enough
for the orange silk wing to overhear?
She seemed all right to me.
Blue said.
No, Admiral said.
She's dreadful.
What is going on?
Blue asked, bewildered.
With what?
Admiral paused to toss Blue a tangerine
smiling.
It's just, you guys seem to spend a lot
of time fighting with each other.
Blue pointed out.
Do we?
Admiral looked surprised.
No more than most dragons, I'm sure.
Way more than the dragons I know, Blue
said.
Admiral flipped one of his wings
dismissively.
Well, I suppose we've all been stuck
together for so long.
There's bound to be a little tension here
and there.
Come meet Zeneca, though.
She's very sweet, and always has clever
things to say about the others.
Seneca shared her kale and kumquats with
them, and spent their entire conversation
glancing around the cave to make sure
everyone else saw that she was officially
getting to meet the new Silk Wing first.
She also made a point of warning Blue
away from Danaid and a few other flame
silks.
This went on with each Dragon Blue met
and by the time he wound up back in his
nest, He was exhausted.
He couldn't keep track of who hated who
except they all seemed to hate fritillery
which was mutual.
The cavern was seething with petty
rivalries, long held grudges, and easily
provoked tempers.
He flopped down next to Luna's cocoon, and
rested his head against it.
He couldn't wait for his sensible, funny
normal sister to come out.
No wonder they're starved for new
company.
Being trapped in here for so long has
turned them all super weird.
Almost my turn again.
Admiral said, shaking his wrists out.
He tapped the insides of his arms with
his claws, as though hoping it would wake
up his silk glands.
Father, Blue said.
Why do you all fight with each other?
Aren't there more important enemies?
Like who?
Admiral asked.
The queen.
The hive wings.
The guards who imprison you here, Lou
said, lowering his voice.
Oh, tosh, said Admiral.
The queen is our employer.
The guards keep us fed and safe and on
schedule.
Blue shook his head.
How could his father not understand that
this was a prison?
Maybe after you've been here for a
while.
You have to convince yourself you chose
this, so it all feels less awful.
He'd met 2 dragons among the flame silks
who he suspected weren't as resigned or
falsely content as admiral.
Heliconian was restless and fidgety and
glanced at the exits a lot.
She also asked the only questions about
the outside world, and what was happening
beyond the cavern.
And pirate seemed desperately unhappy
although he wouldn't say anything bad
about the hive wings.
Also, Fritillery, with his everlasting
bad temper.
Surely he wanted to escape.
I just think it's silly to be so mad at
each other, Blue said.
When there are far worse things going on
and dragons who are treating you far more
terribly than Danaid.
If you all could stop fighting and stand
together, maybe you could actually change
things.
No, no.
Admiral said firmly.
I would never work with Danaid or
ClubTail or White Spec.
They are selfish ignoramuses and wrong
about everything.
I can get things done through the queen.
Blue side.
He could see these dragons had baked
their opinions of one another in a
furnace, and were determined to stick to
their factions.
He slept poorly again that night, troubled
by dreams of searching for cricket
through the dark halls of her school.
No matter how many corners he turned, or
how many doors he opened, he never found
the library.
But he ran into Danaid, and Fritillery
and Pirate, over and over again, all of
them yelling over his head at someone
else across the room.
Then, just before he woke up.
He found a room with Luna's cocoon in it
but the threads were cut open, and no one
was inside.
He scrambled out of his nest before he
was fully awake, stumbling over his claws
as he hurried to her cocoon.
It was still there, still safe, still
warm.
The silk walls seemed thinner than before
so he thought he could see the shadow of
Luna on the other side.
He leaned against it again and whispered
Luna.
I miss you.
The silk moved against his scales, a
slight push and give, as though the
dragon inside was rolling over or nudging
him back.
She's coming out tonight.
Blue said, grinning, when Admiral came
over to check on him.
Even in this peculiar place, he couldn't
help feeling excited for Luna.
She'd finally have wings like she always
wanted.
But would she ever get to really use
them?
His smile dimmed as the cocoon rock
again.
Even though this was the last place he
wanted to be.
He was glad he'd be here for Luna when
she came out.
He was glad he'd be the one to explain
everything. instead of a bunch of
squabbling strangers.
Dad, Blue said.
What do you think will happen to me?
If I end up not being a flame silk.
You'll get one of the regular Silkwing
jobs down here.
His father said breezily.
Moving cauldrons or chopping food or
cleaning, that sort of thing.
But what if I want to go home?
Blue asked, wishing he could stop his
voice from trembling.
Would I really have to stay here?
Admiral drummed his claws on the rocks
below him.
Well, he said.
The queen doesn't exactly like to have
silk wings wandering around who know
where this cavern is.
Blue's shoulders slumped, and Admiral
hurried on quickly.
But tell you what, I'll ride her a letter
or lots of letters.
If you're not a flame silk, I'll think of
some very good reasons why you should get
to go home.
I'll convince her.
Don't worry.
It might take a while, but then maybe
you'll decide you want to stay.
It's quite nice here.
And this is where I am.
He finished, with a wistful note in his
voice.
I know, Blue said.
I'll think about it, he added, to make
his dad feel better.
That day passed much like the one
before.
Blue prowled all the corners again
looking for loose stones, or a breath of
air from outside.
He tried to avoid getting dragged into
the fight between the flame silks, but it
was almost impossible.
Every time he walked across the cave
someone would call him over, and then
someone else would start shouting about
how he shouldn't associate with worm
eating low lives like that.
And soon they'd all be arguing over an
offensive remark one of them had made 10
years ago.
And finally, Admiral would have to come
hustle blue away to safety.
But he did find a spot.
Just one. that gave him a spark of hope.
It was in the wall under the ledge where
the hive wings guarded the staircase.
Here the rock slanted back a ways into a
craggy corner, and when Blue ran his
talons over the stone, he found a hole.
It wasn't a very big hole.
It was just large enough for him to fit
one of his arms through it, but when he
did, he felt open space on the other
side.
Open space and a touch of chilliness, as
though there was another big cave back
there, or maybe even a passage.
The rocks he could feel on the back of
the wall seemed damp.
He tried peering through, but he couldn't
see anything but darkness.
He returned to his nest, trying to think
like cricket.
How would she get through the wall?
if she were stuck in here?
It was early evening when Luna's cocoon
started squirming.
He crouched beside it, touching the silk
gently with his talons whenever it seemed
as if it might rock too far away.
Their father was there too, watching with
shining eyes.
A crack appeared at one end of the golden
cocoon.
Blue held his breath as it widened
slicing off the tip.
Claws appeared in the gap, pushing away
the top of the cocoon, and then you could
see Luna's head, shoving her way out as
well.
Luna, he called.
I'm here.
You're doing great.
You're almost done.
She couldn't answer yet, but he saw her
antennae unfurl and wave at him.
Luna wriggled and heaved, and slowly
dragged her whole body out, until finally
she left the empty husk of the cocoon
behind her.
Whoosh, she said, collapsing on her
stomach on the warm rocks.
Her wings unfolded gracefully from her
back and spread out to dry, like
cascading petals of green sunlight.
They were beautiful.
You did it, blue cheered.
He lay down beside her and nudged her
snout with his.
Your wings are amazing.
So amazing, Luna.
His throat closed over everything else he
wanted to say.
She smiled sleepily at him.
Then why are you crying, little brother?
she asked.
Overwhelmed by my gloriousness?
Pretty much, he said with a sniffly
laugh.
I missed you so much.
Aw, she said, covering one of his talons
with hers.
It was only 5 days, silly.
Yeah, but they were really stressful days
he said.
She blinked at him for a long moment, and
then her gaze slowly shifted to the cave
walls behind him, and the glow of the
light from all the flame silk cauldrons
and the stranger watching them eagerly
from extremely close by.
She rolled her wrists in and stared at
them, then sat up abruptly.
Hi, said Admiral, oh wow, I can't believe
this is happening.
I'm so happy to meet you.
Luna stared at him.
Then at blue with an, explain this, face.
This is Admiral, Blue said.
Our dad.
He felt a twinge of pain in his own
wrists, and glanced down.
Uh-oh.
Where those pinpricks of gold, lava under
his scales?
This is the greatest day of my life
Admiral declared, with a most enormous
grin on his face.
Enough smiling.
Time to spin, Sandfly said, stomping up
and poking him in the shoulder.
I give them 3 days until they figure out
that you're the most annoying dragon in
here.
Fritillery shouted from across the
cavern.
Luna glanced around frantically, her
wings fluttering.
She leaned forward and seized Blue's
talons between hers.
Blue.
She said.
Where are we?
Chapter 24.
So, sore tail, might be nearby, Blue said
or might have been captured.
This is somehow too much information, and
absolutely not enough information at the
same time.
Luna said, rubbing her forehead.
Tangerine?
Admiral offered.
Thanks, she said, taking it and peeling
it quickly.
She'd been eating nonstop while Blue told
her the whole story.
Admiral, it turned out, had a stash of
food tucked away in his nest, and he was
surprisingly adept at tossing fruit while
spinning flame silk at the same time.
But the queen hasn't come down to yell at
you or anything?
Luna asked.
No, Blue said.
I really thought she would, or that I'd
get dragged into her throne room and
punished.
But this seems to be it.
She just had me thrown in here.
Like a lost thing that she found and put
back in its place.
Luna said grumpily.
I mean, I'm glad you weren't punished
Blue.
But the queen uses punishment mostly to
send a message to the rest of her
subjects.
So I'm guessing she didn't want to draw
attention to the fact that she has flame
silks, or that a little wingless silk
wing was able to hide from her for so
long.
That was only because I met cricket, Blue
said.
She's the one who figured out how to hide
me.
Luna rolled her eyes at him
affectionately.
Trust you to find the one good hive wing
in the entire tribe.
Now, I'll never be able to convince you
that they're all evil.
Because they're not, he protested.
There must be others as nice as cricket.
Maybe not as smart, or pretty, or funny
or kind, but probably a few that are
nice.
Luna shook her head.
I doubt it.
But even if they are, they never get a
chance to be, because of the queen's
brainwashing.
She shuddered from antennae to tail.
That mind control thing sounds so
creepy.
It is, Blue said.
I hope IO's all right.
Me too.
I hope she found the chrysalis.
Luna, did you know about the chrysalis?
A little bit.
Luna stood up, shaking out her wings and
testing different positions she could
hold them in.
I knew Sortell and IO had just met them.
I was hoping to join once I had my
wings.
I didn't quite figure on waking up in
here.
Blue winced, and she gave him a sharp
look.
Is your silk coming in?
Does it feel hot?
She took his talons and turned them over
to study his wrists.
It was hard to see if they were glowing
with all the light from the other flame
silk in the cave.
I'm supposed to spin my cocoon tomorrow
night, Blue said.
I wish I didn't have to do it in here.
He'd been nervous enough about his
metamorphosis when he knew it would
happen in a tranquil, peaceful safety of
the cocoon.
But it was much more unnerving to imagine
spinning his silk here, in this too
bright place, with its shouting dragons
and stomping guards all staring at him.
There must be a way out, Luna said.
She looked up at the guards by the
stairwell.
How many guards do you think there are?
Luna, Blue said.
There's no way we can fight them.
Just you and me?
That's crazy.
But now I can do this.
She said.
She held out one arm, and a flaming silk
thread burst from her wrist.
It hit one of Admiral's piles of letters
and instantly set it ablaze.
Ah!
Admiral cried.
He leaped over and knocked the burning
pile away from the others, then stamped
it out with his talons.
When it was a pile of ashes on the
rocks.
He picked up the fiery strand of silk and
brandished it at Luna.
This is not a toy.
Look what you did.
Now, how will I remember what I've
already written?
The queen doesn't like repetition.
This is terrible.
You need to learn to be careful with your
flame silk, young lady.
Sorry.
Luna said innocently.
Blue blanked at Admiral.
Dad, you're, you're holding the flame
silk, and your talent.
Why isn't it burning you?
Admiral climbed back into his nest, and
dropped Luna's flame silk into his own
cauldron.
It glowed a much brighter orange gold
than what was already in there.
Flame silk dragons can be burned by flame
silk, he said.
That would be absurd.
Wow, Blue said.
Wait.
So if some already burned me.
No, it will still burn you until you've
gone through metamorphosis, whether
you're going to be a flame silk or not.
Admiral said, Luna, come here and let me
show you the different kind you can
make.
Flame silk is a big responsibility.
Luna rolled her eyes at blue, but she
went over to their father and gave him
her full attention.
Blue side, rubbing his wrists.
His wing buds were tingling too, in a way
that was both exciting and
uncomfortable.
He wished he could go run through the
savannah.
Under the stars, just breathing air that
wasn't thick and hot and overly stuffed
with oranges.
He scrambled down to the central floor of
the cavern and made his way to the spot
under the staircase ledge, where he'd
found the hole earlier that day.
He guessed it was close to the middle of
the night.
Only 2 guards were on the stairs, and the
regular silkwing workers were gone, to a
cramped apartment home in one of the
warehouses, according to Admiral.
Most of the flame silks were asleep
Danaid, Admiral, and Fritillery were the
only ones awake, pouring silk into their
cauldrons.
Blue could feel Danaid's eyes on him as
he poked through the rocks.
He was out of sight of the staircase
guards here.
But the ones up above the glass could
still see him.
He glanced up to confirm this, and the
glow of at least 6 pairs of eyes stared
back.
So even if he could chisel through the
wall, he'd never get a chance to, there
was no way to do anything surreptitious
in here.
He found the hole again and slipped his
claws through, reaching for that feeling
of freedom.
The dark open space on the other side
that might lead anywhere, to the outside
world, to the sky and all its stars.
On the other side of the wall, unseen
something slipped gently between his
claws and squeezed.
Blue came this close to screaming his
head off.
But at the same moment, he heard someone
whisper, shh.
He bit down hard on his tongue and
froze.
Blue, the voice whispered.
He tilted his head closer to the wall.
Cricket?
Shh.
Yes, it's me.
And me, someone else whispered fiercely.
Is Luna all right?
Whispered a 3rd voice.
Sore tail.
She's amazing.
Blue said softly.
I can't believe you're all, Blue, don't
talk, Cricket interrupted.
They're watching you very closely.
It's suspicious enough that you're over
here with your arm in a hole.
If you keep talking to the wall, someone's
going to investigate.
She squeezed his claws again and let go.
Reluctantly he pulled his talon back
although it felt emptier than ever now, as
though it had found its missing half, and
now it had to be alone again.
He wanted to reach for her once more.
To be sure she was real, and really there
and really alive.
But he could see how that might look a
bit strange.
Danaid was pretending to look at her
wrists.
But she was leaning so far toward him
that she was in danger of toppling out of
her nest.
The eyes up above, stared and stared.
He wasn't sure they ever blinked.
Was that a hive wing power some guards
had?
No need for eyelids.
He sat down and started building a small
pyramid of pebbles, trying to look
harmless.
That was something he was usually pretty
good at.
The leaf wings were trying to build a
tunnel, Cricket said softly, to get into
the hive from below.
That's how they found this place, by
accident, as they were digging
underneath.
Did you find your father?
Sorry, I know you can't answer.
But Luna came out of her cocoon?
Are there a lot of blame silks down
here?
Oh, you can't answer that either?
I can't believe how big this cave is.
Not big enough, if you're trapped in it
for your entire life.
Blue thought.
He thought he should be more horrified by
the idea of leaf wings tunneling into the
hives.
Six days ago, the image of leaf wings
suddenly bursting out of the ground
inside his city, would have been the most
terrifying thing he could possibly
imagine.
But he'd met a few other, more terrifying
things since then.
Listen, Sundew hissed.
Cricket wants to get you out of there.
I do too, Sortell chimed in.
Right, but I don't care what he thinks.
Sundew clarified.
Cricket nearly died with me though, so I
kind of feel like I owe you guys one.
My parents have more important things to
do.
But I might be able to come up with a
plan.
Can you be ready tomorrow night?
Blue's heart sank.
He shook his head and shifted himself
around the rock pyramid, pretending to
reach for another stone, but really
angling so whoever was peering through
the hole could see his wing buds.
He heard cricket let out a soft gasp.
He's about to go into metamorphosis, she
whispered to sundo, but you have to get
him out now, tonight.
Oh, rotten bark beetles, Sundew
grumbled.
Fine.
I'll do it the messy way.
Blue.
Can you see a crack in the wall, near the
bottom, that arches around in a half
circle?
Blue glanced casually at the wall?
He spotted what she meant immediately.
It looked like a sun setting.
Can you and Luna fit through there?
If I can knock out the chunk of rock
underneath the crack?
He thought so.
Although we hadn't spent enough time with
Luna's wings yet to be sure how big they
were.
He was a little more worried about how to
fit Admiral through, but his father was
quite skinny.
He'd just have to squish.
Blue gave a very slight nod, scattering
his pebbles as though he'd gotten
frustrated with his construction.
Great.
Go get her.
And everyone be ready to run.
Good luck, Blue.
Cricket whispered.
Tell Luna I'm here.
Swordell interjected, very heroically.
You sat around in a greenhouse and then
followed me into a tunnel.
Sundu observed.
I'm not sure you qualify for a statue in
your honor just yet.
Shh.
Cricket scolded both of them.
Blue picked up a pebble and pretended to
peer at it closely, then set it down and
headed back over to Luna.
Everything all right?
Dane had asked as he went by.
She leaned her elbows on the edge of her
nest, watching him with wide eyed
interest.
Oh, yes, Blue said.
Just some pretty rocks.
I think my sister would like.
You will introduce her to me.
Won't you?
Danaid said.
And her voice was an odd mixture of pushy
and wistful.
No matter what your dad says.
Of course, Blue said. feeling guilty.
He couldn't stay here just to keep these
lonely flame silks company.
But he was sorry that escaping with Luna
meant abandoning them to their endless
quarrels.
Is there any way to bring them along?
Could they come with us?
He didn't know how to alert the other
flame silks without attracting the
attention of the guards, and given what
he knew about them so far, he was afraid
even the idea of an escape plan would
somehow trigger a screaming match that
would give everything away.
He hurried back to Luna, worrying over
the problem in his head.
Rescuing her was everything.
It was the whole reason he'd broken so
many rules and gotten in so much
trouble.
It was the most important thing, getting
her out of here.
But he wished there was a way to rescue
all of them.
Luna sat up as he approached.
And her eyes gleamed when she saw the
expression on his face.
She'd always been able to read him, ever
since they 1st hatched.
You've found a way out, she whispered
excitedly.
Our friends are here.
He whispered back.
Then let's go.
She jumped to her feet and looked up at
Admiral.
Hmm?
He said, blinking down at them.
I was just composing another letter in my
head, to thank the queen for bringing you
here, of course.
My letters can't all be complaints, you
know.
Oh, no.
That wouldn't do.
I must also show my gratitude when she is
so generous with us.
My thank you letter in regards to the
tangerines was a work of art.
He shot a regretful look at the pile of
ashes, as though wondering how many more
masterpieces had been lost to Luna's
flame silk, Father, Blue said softly.
We have a way out of here, but we have to
go right now.
Go?
Admiral echoed.
What do you mean?
We are going to escape, Luna said.
All 3 of us.
Come on, quick, while the guards are
looking sleepy.
But I'm in the middle of my spinning
rotation.
Admiral said, and I haven't made nearly
enough for the quota.
You're going to have to make it up with
all your bright, lovely silk.
They'll probably give you a turn in the
morning, once you've rested a bit.
No, Luna said firmly.
I'm not giving anyone my bright, lovely
silk.
It's mine, and I'm escaping with Blue
right now.
Admiral Twitched, as though the word
escape was finally crawling into his
ears.
No, no, he said.
The hives need our silk.
We're providing a great service.
We're very important.
You're very important.
You can't.
You can't leave.
What are you even talking about?
We're not allowed to leave.
That rule is pretty clear.
Come with us, please, Blue bagged.
This is no way to live, Father.
We could be together and free.
Out there.
Out where?
Admiral scoffed.
There's nowhere the queen doesn't
control.
No, no.
We mustn't anger her with ungrateful
stunts like escape attempts.
Oh, dear.
Oh dear, you'll get us all in trouble.
It'll make everything worse.
How could it be worse than this?
Luna asked.
In the beginning, there were chains
Admiral said, on our ankles.
I was the one who got rid of those.
It only took me about 4 years and 200 or
so letters, but I finally convinced her
we could be trusted without them, and now
you want to break that trust?
This is not a mutual relationship, Luna
said.
The queen is using you.
She's giving you next to nothing, and
you're letting her walk all over you
instead of fighting back.
We're not going to be a part of that.
She turned to Blue.
I don't think this is going to work.
We have to go without him.
Oh no, Admiral cried.
You can't.
You'll undo all the progress I've made
with a queen.
We have rules for a reason, you know, and
she'll be so disappointed.
So escape with us.
Blue couldn't give up.
He couldn't just leave his father here.
Father, you don't have to follow rules
that are unjust, and you don't have to do
everything the queen says.
Don't you feel like there are rules in
your heart that are more important?
About helping other dragons and standing
up for anyone who's being treated badly
and loving whoever you want, and choosing
to live your life in your own kind
peaceful way.
He glanced over and saw Luna staring at
him in surprise.
She reached out with one wing and pulled
him into a hug.
Wow, she said.
It really was a long 5 days, wasn't it?
Well, I just understood it.
Finally, he said, that there are dragons
who aren't safe, and dragons, I could
help.
And being a good little silk wing who
follows the rules was making my life easy
but also helping to keep a bad system in
place.
I didn't know before how bad it was for
so many dragons.
Like you, Father, like all the flame
silks in here.
This isn't right.
And you shouldn't want it for your
children, Luna said.
If you want to stay, that's fine, but
we're going.
She turned blue toward the center of the
cave.
No, Admiral said.
No, no, it's wrong.
I can't let you do this.
Guards.
Blue inhaled sharply.
The hive wings by the staircase whipped
their heads toward them.
His father was sabotaging their escape
turning them in to keep them trapped
here.
They had to run, but their escape route
looked a whole continent away, and it
wasn't even open yet.
Guards!
Admiral bellowed.
Listen.
Stop annoying the guards.
The Naiad shouted at Admiral. interrupting
him.
They don't want to hear your thoughts on
potassium at this hour, or ever.
It's not that, Admiral yelled back
although my thoughts on potassium are
very well researched and relevant.
But hey, guards, guards, my dragonettes
your brains are a pile of bananas.
Fritillery hollered from his perch.
Never one to miss out on a fight.
Your dragonettes are boring.
They are not.
Then Ad and Admiral roared in unison.
I think they're charming, then I had
yelled.
You don't even know them, Admiral
shouted.
They're my dragonettes, and they're
fascinating, but they're...
Well, then, they're the opposite of you.
Then they had bellowed.
What is happening?
Luna said to Blue, covering her ears?
There was something about the sparkle in
Danaid's eyes.
Blue wasn't sure if it was her usual
spirited fury, or if maybe.
I think Danaid might be trying to help us
he said quietly.
He glanced up at the guards.
They were sitting down again, rolling
their eyes at one another as though
they'd heard fights like this a 1000000
times.
Follow me.
Walk, don't run.
Act casual.
He climbed down through the stalagmites
trying to quiet his thudding heart.
Guards!
Admiral yelled again.
But as Blue had hoped, Admiral didn't
jump up and chase them.
He would have to stop his silk spinning
to do so, and that was yet another rule
he'd never break.
Shut up.
Pirate whined, sitting up and rubbing his
eyes.
Why are you making so much noise?
It's the middle of the night.
Yeah, some of us were sleeping.
Whitesbeck shouted.
You're not helping matters with your
bellowing.
Heliconian chimed in from the nest
closest to him.
Now all 10 of them were awake and
shouting.
It was perfect cover.
The high wing guards looked like the last
thing they wanted to do was come down and
get involved in this, and no matter how
much Admiral roared, they couldn't hear
his accusations over the noise of
everyone else.
Blue paused at Danaid's nest.
Thank you, he said, holding one talon up
to her.
She took it and squeezed it with a wink.
Whatever I'm doing?
It's great fun.
This is Luna, he said.
Luna, this is Danaid, who is definitely a
dragon worth knowing.
Danaid beamed over the edge of her nest
at Luna.
Nice to meet you, she said.
Now, scoot.
I can see something exciting is about to
happen.
She nodded over at the wall, and Blue
realized that the crack looked wider than
before, and some things seemed to be
coming through it.
You could come with us, he said.
I'm not sure my old heart could stand
running from my life, she said.
But if you find a more sedate way to get
us out of here.
Come back for me.
He nodded.
I will try.
I promise.
She went back to shouting at the other
flame silks as he and Luna moved away.
It was funny to think of Danaid wanting
anything sedate when she seemed so
delighted in the middle of chaos.
The stone gave a low crack as they
crouched beside it, and Blue realized
that it was being pushed out of the
wall.
By...
Were those roots?
He gingerly touched one of the thick
brown fingers that were shoving their way
through the crack.
It felt like branches, woody and knobbly
under his claws.
Sundew was growing something.
Somehow, faster than anything should be
able to grow, and it was shoving the
rocks apart, breaking through the crack
creating an opening.
He dug his talons in around the boulder
and yanked.
Luna did the same, and with a lot of
grunting and muscle pulling, they felt it
slowly give way until it tumbled out at
their feet.
The hole in the wall yawned at them and
on the other side, beyond the roots, he
saw 3 faces crowding in to peer through.
Swartail reached toward Luna.
You're safe, he whispered.
And I have wings, she answered giddily.
She shoved blue in front of her.
Go on, quick.
Suddenly, there was a furious pounding
overhead.
Smash, smash, smash, against the glass.
They'd been spotted.
That meant the guards were coming.
All the guards.
Blue dove into the hole, and wiggled
through into the dark, navigating a small
thicket of leafy branches.
He felt the warmth of cricket's talons
lifting him up, and saw a light glinting
off her glasses.
I'm so glad you're alive, he said
breathlessly.
I had a feeling you'd rescue me, except I
thought maybe I had to come rescue you
but I didn't know how.
You did rescue me.
Just by being you, she said.
Oh gosh, that wasn't corny at all.
Luna popped through and Soritail swept
his wings around her.
My love, he cried.
By the forest, all of you stop being
sickening and run.
Sundu cried.
She took off in a whirl of green scales
disappearing rapidly into the dark.
Luna produced a small wisp of flame that
lit up the tunnel just enough for them to
see, and they ran.
But before she did, for that moment in
the dark, Blue had glanced down at his
wrists, and saw tiny globes of fire under
his scales.
Chapter 25.
They ran and climbed and ducked and slid
down loose pebbly dirt slopes, following
the flicker of Luna's silk, and the flash
of sundew's tail up ahead.
Their escape root smelled like earthworms
and cut grass.
Twice they had to squeeze through gaps so
narrow, Blue was worried Swordtail
wouldn't fit.
Most of the time the ceiling was low
enough to scrape their heads, and
sometimes the dirt turned to damp mud
clogging up their talons.
But after a while.
They slowed down to listen, and they
couldn't hear anyone behind them.
Maybe they couldn't get through the hole
from the cavern.
Blue said.
Maybe sundew's fast growing roots had
blocked the way.
Or they got stuck at the bottleneck gaps
Soritell said, rubbing his shoulder.
They'll be out searching for the other
end of the tunnel, Sundew said.
Good thing it's quite a long way from the
hive.
She turned to keep going and they
followed, moving at a steadier pace now.
Soon the dirt tunnels shifted up and
released them into a stone cave, similar
in size to the flame silk cavern, but
cold and dark and empty.
From there on, they climbed through
natural passages in the rocks.
At one point, they hopped up the side of
a trickling waterfall that sprayed their
scales with mist.
Blue thought he heard a river rushing
somewhere close by.
He also heard odd, whispering, chittering
sounds inside the echoes, as though the
caves were haunted by musical squirrels.
Or reading monkeys, he realized.
These caves could be connected to the
ones where he and Cricket had seen the
little monkey creature.
Maybe there were lots of them living down
here.
Like cricket's science project, dream
come true.
And then, a long while later, he heard a
sound like distant roaring.
What's that?
He whispered to Cricket.
I'm not sure.
She answered.
The smell is different too.
Did you notice?
Doesn't it smell like salt and?
Fish, maybe?
Oh, oh, I know what it is.
Sundew.
Are we going to the ocean?
Just then they rounded a corner of the
tunnel, and there it was, the ocean.
They were standing in an enormous cave
that looked out onto the beach.
It was early morning.
Rivulets of water ran and branched and
reconvened all through the sandy floor of
the cave.
Seabirds dove and wheeled in and out
visiting their nests near the rocky
ceiling.
Cricket ran forward, her talons splashing
in the wet sand to the mouth of the
cave.
She opened her wings to the wind, so they
billowed out like pages flung into the
sky.
The waves roared cheerfully at her.
Oh, wow.
Luna said, waiting up beside her.
She spread her wings too, and they sat
side by side for a moment, gold, orange
black, and pale green.
Hive wing and silk wing gazing out at the
sea.
Blue sidled up beside them and looked out
at the beach.
It stretched away beyond sight in each
direction, with tall cliffs overlooking
the beach as far as he could see.
Up at the top of the cliffs, long grass
tossed and waved in the wind.
The ocean was so big.
He'd never quite imagined how big it
could be or how noisy or how active.
It never stopped moving, charging up the
beach, sprinting away, rolling and
turning blue, green, gray, with sprays of
white.
Have you ever been here before?
Cricket asked him.
I haven't, but I've always wanted to
visit the sea.
Doesn't it feel like a promise?
Like the night before an exciting
journey?
The distant kingdoms are out there, Blue.
I know it.
She squinted at the tossing waves, as
though she might be able to glimpse the
far off continent on the other side of
the world.
Clear site's home.
We could learn so much if we could just
figure out how to get there.
Luna gave a rueful laugh.
I'm afraid we have enough to deal with on
this continent, she said.
I'm all for exploring new worlds, but I
think we have to save this one first.
Or we could just leave, Cricket said, in
a quieter voice.
If it's too dangerous here.
Maybe we'd be safer over there.
Yes, we might be.
Luna said.
But the dragons we left behind would
still be in danger.
She turned as sore tail and sun dew came
up to join them.
Blue realized it was raining.
A quiet drizzle plip plopped across the
sand.
Turning the air misty in the pale dawn
light.
He held out his burning wrists so the
raindrops could cool them down.
Thank you for getting us out of there.
He said to Sundu.
Where are your parents?
Sulking, she said.
They didn't want me to reveal the
existence of the tunnel to the hive wings
even though we'd already decided we can't
use it.
Also, they're mad that I haven't given
them this yet.
She tapped one of her larger pouches, and
it made a thunking sound.
But they are not the boss of me, and I
told them they could have it once you
were free.
I'll meet up with them tonight.
And then what will you do?
Sortell asked.
Go back to the other leaf wings, she
said.
Figure out our next plan.
Since this one didn't go exactly the way
we expected.
Is that?
Luna started, pointing to the pouch.
Do you really have?
Sundoo reached in and drew out the book
of Clear Sight.
It looked even smaller and less mystical
in the daylight.
It just looked like a very old book that
someone had sewn together, a little
crookedly.
But it holds the secrets of our future.
Blue thought, with a shiver of awe.
And we could read it.
We could read it right now, and know
everything that's going to happen.
Can I show them?
Cricket asked sundew.
The leaf wing nodded, passing the book to
her.
Cricket found a flat, dry boulder, and
swept off all the sand on it with her
tail.
Blue sat down beside her, and Cricket
scooted closer to him, so Luna could sit
on her other side.
It's not what we thought it was, Cricket
said.
It's, well, it's something else
completely.
She opened the book to the 1st page.
Dear grandchildren, and great
grandchildren, and great great
grandchildren, and all the many great
grandchildren to come.
How funny it feels to know you so well.
When there are so many of you, I'm never
going to meet.
I see you all the time, especially when
I'm just on the edge of falling asleep
the future is so clear.
Suddenly.
Now that I won't be able to change
anything.
My time is almost up, and yours is just
beginning.
I won't be able to control anything after
this.
I won't be able to use my visions to
protect you.
To keep you all safe.
But then, one thing I've learned over my
long, strange, lovely life is that I
never could actually control the future
as much as I thought I could.
I should have learned that lesson with my
1st love, back home in Pyria.
But I kept trying anyway.
And I did manage to keep you all alive.
I battled the future for that much, and I
won.
But the future will always win in the end
because it continues on forever.
To where I cannot go.
So this is my last battle.
The last thing I can do to try and keep
my claws on the balance of the future.
To keep you safe as long as I can.
In this book, are my visions of what is
yet to come.
Some of it seems small, but I have
included everything.
Even if I can't tell yet why it's
important.
I leave you this, and hope that it will
make life better for both our tribes.
I hope you will use it to protect the
dragons around you, especially the ones
who are the most threatened, regardless
of who they are, and how you think you
feel about them.
There are some hard times ahead. as there
always are, everywhere.
And for everyone.
I'm sorry, I won't be here to help you
rebuild after the earthquake.
I hope I've written down enough advice to
get you through the famine.
But most of what I see is joy.
Your futures are full of joy.
What a miracle it is to be a dragon, alive
right now, and part of this wonderful
world.
Do you ever stop to think about that?
About what an odd and lucky thing it is
to be this soul inside this body, to live
in a world with so many marvels in it.
I am so grateful to have known and loved
you all.
All the hurricanes and earthquakes, and
fires, and storms, cannot break you.
If you remember a few things.
We are here to love with our whole
hearts.
Lean into your kindness and empathy in
the face of evil, but do not let evil
win.
You are the only dragon who can decide
who you want to be.
Don't let yourself get stuck on someone
else's path.
Search for what's true, and think for
yourself.
Over a 100 years ago.
I thought my life was finished, and there
was nothing left to live for.
I was so, so wrong.
Keep going.
The list of things to live for is
limitless, and it is possible to be happy
again.
And this one is going to sound ridiculous
coming from me.
Don't worry about the future so much, or
else you might miss out on the
extraordinary present.
Be happy, dragons of the future.
You can change the world with your joy
and your hope.
All my love, clear sight.
Blue glanced up and saw Luna wiping away
tears.
This is exactly how I imagined Clearsight
he said.
Of course you did, Luna said, with a
catch in her voice.
You have faith in other dragons, whereas
I thought she was a conniving manipulator
who deliberately set up her descendants
to be the most powerful tribe in
Pentala.
She shook her head.
Yep.
Me too. said sundew.
Oh, no.
Blue said, shocked.
She wasn't.
She wouldn't.
I see that, Luna said, waving her talent
at the book.
But at some point, that's what her
descendants decided to do.
Why didn't she see that coming and stop
them?
Because...
Cricket said softly.
It turns out, she wasn't all knowing and
all seeing after all.
She started turning pages, pointing to
the date up at the top.
After about 200 years, the flow of
visions slowed dramatically.
A hurricane here, a tsunami 90 years
later.
A few more tiny notes, full of question
marks.
And then, on a date marked about 900
years after the 1st she'd written, Take
care of the trees.
I think they might be in danger, but I
can't see why.
Help the leaf wings protect them.
I love you.
Good luck.
Cricket turned the page.
The next spread was blank, and so was the
next, and the next.
The last few pages of the book were
empty.
The last vision from Clearsight was dated
over a 1000 years ago.
Chapter 26.
Blue looked up at Cricket and Luna.
Blinking and confusion.
Where's the rest of it?
he asked.
What about the tree wars?
And us trying to steal the book.
And everything Queen Wasp knows.
She doesn't know anything.
Luna said furiously.
She was faking it the whole time.
The power of the book.
Everything that makes the hive wing so
superior, it's all lies.
In case you're curious, Sundew
interjected.
This is my not at all surprised face.
Cricket was nodding.
Clear sight never saw this far ahead.
She had no idea her book would be used
this way.
But Blue still couldn't wrap his head
around it.
But Queen Wasp said Clearsight wanted the
tribes to unite under her rule.
That was the whole reason Queen Monarch
gave up her throne.
Because if it was in the book of
Clearsight, it had to be important.
It was a lie blue.
Luna jumped up, and Thordtail came over
to stand beside her.
Wasp lied and used the book to seize
power.
And to drive out the leaf wings, sundew
said.
Queen Sequoia wouldn't agree to step down
without seeing the book first, which, of
course, WASP wouldn't allow.
Our queen said, if she'd seen it in clear
sight's own handwriting, she might have
considered it, which I think is insane in
the 1st place.
We don't need anyone else to be our
queen.
How could she?
Blue said, closing the book and resting
his claws on it.
I don't understand.
How could Queen Wasp read this?
And then decide to become the total
opposite of what Clearsight says to be?
Cricket put her talent over his on the
book?
Some dragons, care infinitely more about
themselves than anyone else, she said.
Which I think is hard for a dragon like
you to imagine.
Well, he said.
I am very angry about this.
Angry enough to do something about it?
Sundu asked.
She lifted her chin challengingly.
Like what?
Sortell asked.
We're going to take down the hive wings
Sundew said.
We could use some dragons on the inside.
Swortail snorted.
You may not have noticed, but we're not
exactly on the inside anymore.
We know dragons who are, though, Luna
said.
Giving him a significant look.
Wait, what does take down the hive wings
mean?
Blue asked.
Are you going to hurt them?
Sundew scowled at him.
That is sort of the point of a
revolution.
She snapped.
She snatched the book away from him and
stuffed it back in her pouch.
I thought you said you were mad.
Yes, but no, Blue said.
The hive wings have also been lied to, and
brainwashed and tricked.
The queen is the problem.
You have to fight her, not the whole
tribe.
I mean, we do.
We have to stop her.
His wrists flared with pain, as though
they were trying to remind him that he
had slightly more urgent things to do
first, such as, for instance, growing
wings.
Let's rest for a while, Cricket said
watching him with concern.
Everyone thinks better after sleeping.
She hopped down to a dry patch of soft
sand, in a sheltered corner of the cave
and dug a small hollow, Blue?
He gratefully slid down and sank into the
hollow next to her.
His wing buds were really starting to
ache, and his head felt strangely fuzzy
too.
He sort of wished he could spin his
cocoon now, and shut out the whole mess
and all the decisions they might have to
make.
But the thought also terrified him.
He didn't want to be cut off from Cricket
and Luna for 5 days.
With no way to know what was going on.
And what if something went wrong with his
metamorphosis?
What could go more wrong than turning out
to be a flame silk?
he thought.
Well, I don't need to sleep, Luna said.
I'm going to test out my new wings.
Want to come?
she said, bumping sore tails side.
Obviously, yes, he said.
Be careful, Sundew warned.
The hive wings will be out in force
looking for us.
It would be safer to stay inside until
dark.
Just a little flight?
Luna wheedled.
I finally have wings, and we're so far
from the hives.
I promise we'll be careful.
Sundew shrugged.
You're not my tribe, she said, but if you
get caught, I'm not rescuing you again.
Noted, Luna said, bounding to the cave
entrance.
Be back soon, Blue.
She soared up into the sky.
Scattering raindrops in all directions
with sword tail in her wake.
Blue side.
I wish I were that excited about getting
wings, he said.
I mean, I am.
I'm just... nervous too.
That sounds normal to me.
Cricket said.
But you'll be all right once it starts.
How are you feeling?
Do you have the same symptoms as Luna?
He lifted his wrists and she held them
gently while she studied them.
Your silk glands look very bright, she
said.
So did Luna's, he said.
Kind of golden and fiery, just like this
Wow, she said.
I might be best friends with a real flame
silk.
He couldn't squash down his smile.
Best friend.
Well, my circle of options is a little
smaller than it used to be. she said
flicking her tail at the cave, and it's
Sundew, who was sorting through her
pouches and grumbling.
But the truth is, I'd want you to be my
best friend, even if I knew every dragon
in Pantala.
Same, he said, resting his head on his
talons.
That's how I see you.
Best friend, best brain, best heart.
Aw, she said.
She lay down and snuggled up next to
him.
Are you totally asleep yet?
Before you fall asleep, can you tell me
about the Flame Silk Cavern, how does it
work?
How many dragons live there?
What are they like?
Blue drowsily tried to answer her
questions, but sleep pulled him down
inexorably, chasing away the pain in his
back and wrists.
It was peaceful with cricket by his side
and the rain pattering on the rocks
around them.
He felt calm again for the 1st time in
days.
He didn't know how long he slept, but he
woke suddenly, to the sound of screams
from outside, across the cave.
Sundew dropped a handful of twigs and
leaped to her feet.
The 3 of them ran to the cave entrance
and looked out.
Up in the sky, a pair of hive wings had
sore tail and Luna cornered, they circled
like hawks, jabbing and fainting, with
claws and spears and stingers on their
tails.
Luna!
Blue cried.
Starting forward, and immediately
stumbling over his talons, Sundu caught
him, pulling him back into the cave.
No way, she said.
You can't fight in your condition.
You can barely fight when you're not half
Lubion Silk.
She shoved him into Cricket's arms.
Make him stay here.
The leaf wing took off into the sky.
It was raining harder than before, with a
strong wind whipping up the seas.
Blue watched in a daze as sundew smashed
into the hive wings, taking them by
surprise.
One wheeled around to grapple with her
and Swordtail broke away to tackle the
other.
They struggled for several rain soaked
moments. talons slipping on wet scales.
Blue had always thought of Soretail as
the best fighter he knew.
The next to sundew and the soldiers, he
seemed badly outmatched.
The hive wing twisted to slash a claw
along his side, and Swordail roared with
pain.
Alone in the sky, Luna flung out her
front talons, Blue could see that she was
trying to protect Swordtail, that she was
trying to set his attacker on fire.
But her silk whipped out faster and
wilder than she'd expected.
The wind seized the golden strands and
flung them together, weaving knots over
Luna's head.
In a sudden heartbeat, a sail of flame
silk billowed out above Luna, and then
the storm roared in, snared the sail, and
blew her out to sea.
Luna.
Blue cried desperately.
His sister seemed to be struggling with
the silk, but she couldn't break free.
Lightning flashed, and a moment later, the
clouds had swallowed her up.
Sortail smashed his attacker in the face
and flew after Luna, shouting her name.
His wings beat frantically as he tried to
catch up.
Then he was gone too.
Sundew was left grimly battling the 2
hive wings alone.
We have to.
We have to go after them, Blue said.
His whole body was starting to shake, and
his wrists felt like they were literally
on fire.
Luna, sore tail.
You can't go anywhere, Blue, Cricket
said.
She put her wings around him and guided
him back into the cave, way to the back
toward the tunnels and secret passages.
It's starting.
We need to hide you somewhere safe.
Let's think.
But they'll come back.
She promised.
The storm will blow itself out, and
they'll fly back here and want to find
you safe and sound.
Okay?
You'll make things much worse if you go
out there and get captured by hive
wings.
She guided him down one of the passages
staring him around jutting spires of
stone.
Sundew, he mumbled.
Can take care of herself, she said, in
case you hadn't noticed, she's pretty
fierce.
Come on.
I think I saw a cave this way.
It's about as well hidden as we can get.
He couldn't argue.
He couldn't think.
Apparently his head was no longer
connected to his body.
The walls were shifting and rolling, and
kind of sparkling too.
He felt dizzy, and sick, and very hot.
It felt like an endless march before
cricket maneuvered him between 2 pillars
into a small curving cave with smooth
walls.
These ones really were sparkling, he
thought.
But actually, his eyes weren't to be
trusted, so who knew?
I wish I were in the cocoon, he said, his
teeth chattering.
I wish I were home.
I know, Cricket said sadly.
I know, Blue.
I'm so sorry you can't be.
He sank to his knees, and the silk
started to pour from his wrists.
It was bright and burning, flame silk all
the way through, and it wove swiftly
around his tail and talons.
Everywhere it touched him, his muscles
relaxed, and a feeling of peace slowly
swept over him, like a wave filling him
up.
I'll be right here, Blue, Cricket said.
He lay down, looking up into her
wonderful face, lit by the glow of his
flame silk.
I'll be here the whole time.
I'll be here when you wake up.
You'll be safe.
I promise.
Blue was a dragon who didn't like
change.
But in the last 5 days, he'd discovered
that his whole world was very different
than he'd imagined.
His queen was a controller of minds.
The book of Clearsight was a lie.
And his father was a prisoner in a flame
silk factory.
And Blue was in love with a hive wing.
He'd made it through all of those
discoveries.
He was stronger now.
He saw things more clearly.
Like Clearsight had written.
He had to keep going, and decide for
himself what kind of dragon he wanted to
be.
After everything he'd been through.
He knew he could handle a little thing
like growing wings.
The gold fire wrapped around him.
Blue closed his eyes. let the change
begin.
Epilogue.
Luna opened her eyes.
A seagull skittered away from her, calling
indignantly about dragons who pretended
to be food and then weren't.
She was lying in wet sand.
Wet sand was clumped between her talons
and in her ears, and in the cracks
between her scales.
Her face was half buried in it.
She was pretty much plastered with wet
sand from horns to tail.
A wave rushed up from behind her
swooshing under her back talons and tail
soaking her underbelly, and whisking away
again.
Luna pushed herself up to a sitting
position with a groan of pain.
She fanned out her wings to check them.
One was badly bruised.
She had a vague memory of being hit by a
hailstone.
And one of her back ankles twinged
horribly when she tried to stand on it.
She dragged herself up the beach, away
from the bustling waves.
Ow, everything ached.
She squinted up at the aggressively
cheerful sun.
How far had she been blown from blue and
sword tail?
This beach didn't look like the one where
she'd started out.
Instead of tall cliffs.
The sand here rolled up into low hills
with patches of shrubs.
Luna could see quite far up and down the
coast and inland, but she couldn't see
any sign of caves, or hives.
She rubbed her head, trying to remember
the map of Pantala.
She'd been in the air for days, tangled
in her silk balloon as the storm swept
her along.
She remembered nothing but white capped
waves below her.
Could she?
She couldn't be.
Surely.
Talons landed on the sand slightly uphill
from her.
Luna started back, lifting one wrist to
shoot fire if her wing was a hive wing.
But it wasn't.
This dragon was pale yellow, with light
brown triangle markings on her wings, only
2 wings, just one pair, like a leaf wing
but with her coloring, she definitely
wasn't a leaf wing.
And her wings weren't leaf shaped
either.
They looked closer to bat wings, but
covered in scales instead of fur.
The dragon took a step toward her.
And Luna realized there was something odd
at the end of her tail.
A barb, like she'd only ever seen before
on scorpions.
What are you?
Luna said fiercely.
Oh, you speak dragon said the stranger.
That's lucky.
What else would I speak?
Luna asked.
Who are you?
Where am I?
I guess I thought your continent might
have a different language.
The yellow dragon said with a shrug.
I'm Jerboa.
My Continent?
Luna echoed.
She lowered her arm.
Do you mean?
Did I really cross the ocean?
It looks that way?
Treboa said wryly, but not entirely
unscathed, I think.
Are you injured?
Just a little.
Luna tried to take a step and winced.
Yar, that's ow.
My name's Luna.
My hut is just around that bend.
Truboa said, coming over and levering her
wing under Luna's.
Hang on.
We'll be there in no time.
They started across the sand.
Luna found it much more difficult to walk
in than Jaboa did.
Her wing kept sagging unexpectedly under
her claws, or sucking around her talons.
I have to get back, Luna said.
My friends are over there.
They need me, especially my little
brother.
She tried to guess how long she'd been up
in the storm.
She was starving, but that wasn't much of
a clue.
Blue must have started his metamorphosis
by now.
Was he still in his cocoon?
Was he all right?
Well, you're not going far on these wings
today?
Traboa said.
But help is coming.
I have a feeling it'll be here soon.
Trabella's hut was tucked into a cove
cozy and well built, with a recently
thatched roof made of palm fronds.
Luna touched the wood of the door on the
way inside.
It was a real wood, and she was startled
to see it used for a house as small as
this.
Maybe Jerboa was wealthier and more
powerful than she appeared.
Or maybe it's different over here, she
realized.
Maybe there are still plenty of trees on
this continent.
Jerboa helped her over to a bed made of
more palm leaves, and Luna collapsed onto
it, surprised by how exhausted she was.
She was sure she'd slept on the beach for
a while after a crash landing, but the
walk to the hut had tired her out again.
Sleep for a bit, Treboa said, I'll make
fish stew.
Luna wrinkled her snout.
Um, she said, that's all right.
Do you have any fruit?
Or honey?
She added, hopefully.
Jerboa flicked her wings back with a
thoughtful expression.
Not a fish eater, she said.
What about crabs, or rabbits, or
seagulls?
Luna shook her head.
No animals, thank you, she said politely
and her stomach growled as if disagreeing
with her.
I'll see what I have.
Drabola glided off to another corner of
the hut, and Luna felt herself slipping
into a doze.
Sometime later.
Treboa shook her awake.
Talon, gentle on her shoulder.
Luna, our guests are here.
Luna blinked awake.
The light had shifted outside, and there
were quiet voices coming through the
window.
I'll go get them, Traboa said.
Don't be alarmed.
This is who you need to talk to.
She went out the door.
Luna tried to think, although her brain
felt overwhelmed and still muddled with
sleep.
Who was here?
How could they help her?
To who?
Said a new voice, which was attached to a
dragon ducking through the doorway.
He was smaller than Jerboa, closer to
Luna's size, but with the same kind of
wings and tail as Jerboa.
His scales were sand colored like hers as
well, and he wore a hoop earring in one
ear.
But following him through the doorway was
another dragon entirely.
She was black from nose to talons, except
for a few silver scales scattered under
her wings, and 2 teardrop silver scales
in the corners of her eyes.
A startled jolt ran through Luna.
Waking her up like a bolt of lightning.
This dragon looked like clear sight, or
at least, the way Clearside always looked
in pictures.
Luna sat up as the 2 of them came closer
with Jerboa behind them.
Oh, wow, said the one with the earring
noticing Luna.
What?
Said the clear sight looking dragon.
How?
I believe this is our 1st visitor from
the lost continent, Jaboa said.
She blew in with a storm.
The little black dragon sat down and
tipped her head, as though she was
listening to something far away.
I'm Moon, she said, and this is Kibley.
Are you really from across the sea?
I guess so.
Luna said.
It was kind of an accident coming here.
I'm Luna.
Hi Luna, said Kibley.
This must be pretty weird for you too.
You have so many wings.
I mean, that's cool.
Is it hard to fly with all those wings?
That's a silly question.
I can't believe we're meeting a dragon
from another continent.
This is amazing.
Are you, like, clear sight?
Luna asked Moon.
Can you see the future?
Moon's eyebrows shot up.
You know about clear sight?
I know some things about her, Luna said.
Thinking darkly of the book, and the lies
Queen Wasp had told about it.
I know she came from here, and she had
scales like yours.
I always wondered if there were other
dragons over here who could see the
future too.
I can, sort of.
Moon said.
Not as well as she could.
But I had a vision about you.
That's why we're here.
Was it about getting me home?
Luna asked, sitting forward and flaring
her wings.
Do you know how I can get back there?
Moon shot Khibli an uneasy look?
Not exactly, she said.
Although we can work on it.
I have some ideas.
Kibley said brightly.
Good, Luna said.
She settled back into the palm fronds.
She was suddenly sure that storm had
brought her here for a reason.
Let's figure out how to get me home, and
you can all come with me.
Especially you, Vision Dragon.
Me?
Moon said.
Oh, I don't know.
I haven't seen anything about, you have
to, Luna said.
This dragon could be the secret weapon
the silk wings and leaf wings needed.
My tribe needs your help.
Triumph sizzled through her veins.
We are coming for you, Queen Wasp.
And now we have a dragon who can really
see the future.
The reign of the hive wings is over.
A guide to the dragons of Pentala.
Hive wings.
Description.
Red, yellow, and or orange, but always
mixed with some black scales, 4 wings.
Abilities vary from dragon to dragon.
Examples include deadly stingers that can
extend from their wrists to stab their
enemies.
Venom in their teeth or claws, a
paralyzing toxin that can immobilize
their prey.
Or boiling acid, sprayed from a stinger
on their tails.
Queen, Queen Wasp.
Silk wings, description.
Silkwing dragonettes are born wingless
but go through a metamorphosis at age 6.
When they develop 4 huge wings and silk
spinning abilities, as beautiful and
gentle as butterflies, with scales in any
color under the sun, except black.
Abilities, can spin silk from glands on
their wrists to create webs or other
woven articles, can detect vibrations
with their antennae to assess threats.
Queen, Queen Wasp, the last Silkwing
Queen, before the tree wars, was Queen
Monarch.
Leaf Wings.
Description, wiped out during the tree
wars with the hive wings, but while they
lived, this tribe had green and brown
scales, and wings shaped like leaves
abilities, could absorb energy from
sunlight, and were accomplished
gardeners.
Some were rumored to have unusual control
over plants.
Queen.
Last known queen of the leaf wings was
Queen Sequoia, about 100 years ago, at
the time of the tree wars.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 11, The
Lost Continent, by 2 E T Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Peter Straw, executive
producer Paul R.
Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic ink.
Text copyright 2018 by 2E T. Sutherland.
Production copyright 2018 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.